THE
SENATE BUDGET A FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE WILL COME TO
ORDER GOOD MORNING IN RESPONSE
THE CALL BUT NINETEEN EMERGENCY
AND TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE HAS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. WE ARE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN THE
CAPITAL WITH SOME MEMBERS ABLE
TO PARTICIPATE REMOTELY TODAY
THREE MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE ARE HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM. SENATOR GROUP IS
ABSENT. THOSE PROVIDING
TESTIMONY BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
TODAY ARE ALSO PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY. FOR OUR REMOTE
PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE YOUR
PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS WILL
GREATLY HELP IN ELIMINATING ANY
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. I ASK THAT
EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED THAT YOU USE THAT
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM. EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO UNMUTE. PLEASE
SELECT ON MUTE BEFORE YOU BEGIN
SPEAKING. OUR I. T. PERSONNEL
WILL PUT YOU BACK ON MUTE WHEN
YOU ARE DONE. WAS RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK PLEASE MAKE SURE YOU CAN
BE SEEN ON THE SCREEN. STATE
YOUR NAME AND THEN YOU'RE READY
TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
IN THE HEARING ROOM. TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE ORVIS FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. WE WILL TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT INTO PARTS TODAY
. FIRST WE WILL TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON DISCUSSION ISSUES
FIVE THROUGH SEVEN. AT THE
CONCLUSION OF ISSUE SEVEN. AND
WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN WITH FIVE.
FIVE WE WILL THEN HAVE PUBLIC
COMMENT FOR THE REMAINDER OF THE
AGENDA AT THE END OF ALL
DISCUSSION ITEMS IN OTHER WORDS
FROM EIGHT TO TWENTY TWO WE WILL
HEAR THOSE PRESENTATIONS AND
THEN WE WILL HAVE A PUBLIC
COMMENT ON. EIGHT TO TWENTY TWO
. AND THEN WE WILL RETURN TO THE
VOTE ONLY ITEMS OF ONE TWO FOUR
. FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER AND
ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE HE WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. THE NUMBER
IS. 844-291-6364 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS THREE FIVE THREE ONE.
TWO EIGHT THREE. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE TELECOM
INSISTED WORKS PLEASE REFER TO
THE SENATE OUTDOOR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. WHEN WE MOVED TO PUBLIC
COMMENT YOU WILL BE PROMPTED BY
A MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE THEN
ZERO. PRESS THIS. ONLY ONE TIME
AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER THIS CAN BE A SHORT WAIT
ONCE RECEIVE ONCE YOU RECEIVE
YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU WILL WAIT
IN THE QUEUE. FOR THE MODERATOR
TO CALL R LINE
TIME YOU WILL BE ON MUTED AND
YOU ARE NOW READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY
AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK.
PLEASE MUTE THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR TO
GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE.
IT IS IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU
WE THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
OR HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
LASTLY FOR EVERYONE PHYSICALLY
PRESENT HERE TODAY PLEASE KEEP
YOUR MASKS ON. FOR EVERY NEW
KNOWS AND MOUTH AT ALL TIMES
FURTHER NEWMAN THANK YOU SO
MUCH. BEFORE WE BEGIN LET'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM MR HACKER
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE RAZA
HERE IS A- GROVE NEWMAN HERE. WE
NO WE HAVE A QUORUM MR HECKER.
KARAM HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED WE
WILL HOLD OUR VOTES UNTIL THE
END OF THE HEARING AS SUCH WE
WILL BEGIN WITH THE ITEMS LISTED
FOR DISCUSSION WILL BE
DISCUSSING ALL THE ISSUES LISTED
IN THE DISCUSSIONS SESSION
SECTION OF THE AGENDA- ONCE
HEARD TWICE. ONCE AFTER ISSUE
SEVEN AND AGAIN AFTER ALL
DISCUSSION ISSUES HAVE BEEN
PRESENTED. I JUST WANT TO SAY A
FEW WORDS AS WE DIVE INTO THE-
THE TRANSPORTATION AGENDA- THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET OF JANUARY
BUDGET PROPOSES JUST AS AN
EXAMPLE OF WHAT'S IN FRONT OF US
FOURTEEN BILLION DOLLARS ON THE
ISSUE OF EQUIPMENT BUSES. TRUCKS
FUELING INFRASTRUCTURE OF SET OR
NON CONSTRUCTION FUNDS THROUGH
VARIOUS PROGRAMS AND DEPARTMENTS
NOT INCLUDING TAX CREDITS. SO
HERE WE HAVE- AND THERE'S
VARIOUS NUMBERS THAT WE'RE GOING
TO GET CLARITY TODAY ABOUT IS-
BETWEEN FOURTEEN BILLION- IN
FEDERAL FUNDING COMING TO
CALIFORNIA- AND ON TOP OF WHAT
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
SPENDING ON TRANSPORTATION
CLIMATE. AND BUT WE DO EXPECT UP
TO FORTY BILLION DOLLARS IN
FORMULA OF FUNDS FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT- AND
TRANSPORTATION POLICIES ADDRESS
A NUMBER OF ISSUES AT THE SAME
TIME. THE MOVEMENT OF GOODS THE
MOVEMENT OF PEOPLE- UNLESS WE
ADDRESS THAT WE WILL CONTINUE TO
HAVE THIRTY ERROR ESPECIALLY
AREAS IN REGIONS WHERE THERE
ARE. A LOT MORE PEOPLE DRIVING
CARS AND FREEWAYS. WE HAVE IT IN
OUR POWER TO CREATE SYSTEMS OF
TRANSPORTATION THAT MOVE PEOPLE
AND GOODS IN WAYS THAT ARE MORE
EFFICIENT CLEANER AND ALSO HIGH
WAGE JOB CREATORS- WE HAVE A
GOOD HISTORY IN CALIFORNIA. OF
WELL WE HAVE A- HISTORY THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO MAKE BETTER
ON POLICIES THAT CREATE GO TO
GOOD JOBS AND PLA'S I COMMUNITY
WORKFORCE AGREEMENTS WE NEED TO
GREATLY EXPAND THE NUMBER OF
JOBS WITH THOSE STANDARDS
ESPECIALLY TO LOW INCOME AND
COMMITTEES OF COLOR AND WOMEN.
WHO UNFORTUNATELY TRADITIONALLY
ARE THE PRIMARY WORKERS IN LOW
PAID INDUSTRIES WE NEED TO THINK
ABOUT HOW TO CREATE GOOD
MANUFACTURING SERVICE OPERATION
MAINTENANCE JOBS IN- JOBS IN
TRANSPORTATION AND OTHER CLIMATE
PROGRAMS SO WE NEED TO CONDITION
CONTRACTS AND SUBSIDIES- THAT
WILL HAVE ENFORCEABLE
COMMITMENTS TO CREATING THOSE
GOOD JOBS. OUT REGION
RECRUITMENT QUALITY TRAINING AND
APPRENTICESHIP HIRING- SO WE'LL
MOVED TO- AGENDA ITEM FIVE BUT I
WANT TO GIVE MY COLLEAGUES ON
THE COMMITTEE AN OPPORTUNIST SAY
ANYTHING IF YOU WANT BEFORE.
ANYBODY CYNICAL I'VE- APPRECIATE
YOUR- YOUR OVERVIEW ON- OF
PRIORITIES. AND WHAT'S IMPORTANT
I'M GOING FORWARD- IT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME YOU KNOW ALL
WILL RAISE THE FEW ISSUES- I'M
CONCERNED WITH BUT THE HAVE TO
DO WITH CAPITAL EXPENDITURES IN
THIS SEEMINGLY- SIGNIFICANT
OPPORTUNITY THAT WE HAVE TO- TO
INVEST- IAN- PROGRAMS LIKE THE
INTERCITY RAIL PROGRAM WHERE. SO
MANY OF OUR METROPOLITAN AREAS
ARE- IN THE MIDST OF A PROJECTS
THESE ARE. HI DREAMS THESE ARE
THINGS THAT ARE HAPPENING AND IN
MANY CASES- HE YOU KNOW IN ORDER
TO CONTINUE TO EXTEND THE WORK-
THEY NEED FUNDING AND I KNOW THE
GOVERNOR'S- THE BILL HAS. SHOWN
THAT IN INVESTMENT IN IS IT IS
BASED BUDGET IN THE IN THE
BUDGET WE'RE LOOKING AT RIGHT
NOW- BUT I THINK IT'S WORTHY OF.
FURTHER DISCUSSION AS TO WHETHER
OR NOT- THAT COULD BE A MORE
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT- AND
THEREFORE. REALLY KEEP THINGS
MOVING UP AND DOWN THE STATE-
PARTICULARLY IN IN THAT
PARTICULAR PROGRAM SO- BUT I
AGAIN TO ZOOM BACK OUT- YOU KNOW
THIS IS CERTAINLY ONE OF THOSE
ONE OF THESE AREAS OF. BOB WE'RE
WE KNOW FROM THE PAST IT'S EASY
TO MISS IN A WINDOW OF
OPPORTUNITY- AND WE NEED TO IT
IT SEEMS SO OFTEN BASED ON MY-
CAREER OF A COUPLE DECADES SAID
YOU CAN MISS A DECADE OF
INVESTMENT JUST BECAUSE THE NEXT
DOWNTURN COMES IN- YOU KNOW WE
DON'T GET THAT CHANCE AGAIN SO-
I'M SO HAPPY TO BE. HERE ON THE
COMMITTEE- WITH MY COLLEAGUES-
YOU KNOW APPOINTED TO A SUB
COMMITTEE THAT'S DEALING WITH
THIS VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE THANK
YOU FOR. THANK YOU SENATOR
BECAUSE THE CENTER NEWMAN THANK
YOU MEASURE EVERT BRIEFLY
DETAINED SO APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUES IN THE
CRETACEOUS. AS WE GET INTO THE
HEARING TODAY- I SERVE AS THE
SENATE'S EX OFFICIAL REPRESENTED
THE CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
VISION. AND AS YOU'LL NOTE- I'LL
HAVE A BUNCH OF QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS- AS TO HOW CERTAIN
MONIES ARE BEING- BUDGET IN A
SPAN OF FOR WHOM- THEY WILL BE
USED THAT ALLOCATED MAIN
RESPONSIBILITY WILL WILL BE
GIVEN TO- BUT BEYOND THAT I
THINK STATE. SENATOR JUDGES
RIGHT WE KNOW WHEN A GOOD
POSITION- WE HAVE OVER THE PAST
SEVERAL YEARS MADE SOME TOUGH
DECISIONS- WITH REGARD TO. HOW
TO FUND INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENT I THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT. THAT WE MAINTAIN THAT
FRAME AS WE AS WE WORK THROUGH
THIS YEAR'S ENCOURAGING BUDGET
SO THANKS. THANK YOU CENTER
NEWMAN. SOME WHERE READY TO GO
AND AGAIN WE'RE GOING TO START
WITH ISSUE FIVE. THE
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
PACKAGE BOMB CALL ON THE
ADMINISTRATION TO PLEASE PRESENT
THE PROPOSAL. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
CARLOS ONE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
SECRETARY BUDGET ADMINISTRATION
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY. THEY'LL
BE PRESENTING OUR BUDGET
PROPOSALS INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. WE ARE TODAY
HIGHLANDERS. WAS A KIND OF.
SENIOR ADVISOR JOBS ANNOUNCING
AND DEPUTY SECRETARY FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL POLICY DONALD
MESABI HELP ANSWER QUESTIONS.
WILL START OPERATING INA REVIEW
OF THE TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE PACKAGE. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS IN NEW
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND MAINTENANCE OF THE EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE. THE PROPOSAL
NINE DOLLAR IN STATE INVESTMENT
IN THE STATE TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM. GLOBAL RECOVERY AND
POSITION THE STATE TO PURSUE
SIGNIFICANT FEDERAL FUNDING.
THESE INVESTMENTS WILL CREATE
QUALITY JOBS ACCELERATE
TRANSPORTATION OPTIONS SUPPORT
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS TO
ACHIEVE OUR GOALS AND PROVIDING
BETTER CONNECTIVITY THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. PACKAGE INCLUDES NINE
POINT ONE BILLION DOLLARS
INVESTMENT IN THE TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM. TODAY WE'LL BE
DISCUSSING FOUR POINT NINE
BILLION OF ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL. I'LL PROVIDE A BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF EACH COMPONENT. THE
FIRST INVESTMENTS THREE POINT
TWO FIVE BILLION GENERAL FUND
FOR HIGH PRIORITY TRANSIT AND
RAIL INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA STATEWIDE.
SUNNDAL OF THE TRAINS AND
INTERCITY RAIL CAPITAL PROGRAM
AND WILL INCLUDE BROWN TRANSIT
CONNECTIVITY BETWEEN STATE AND
LOCAL OR REGIONAL SERVICES
PROVIDE MOBILITY OPTIONS AND
REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
. THE NEXT INVESTMENT IS SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
GENERAL FUND TO ADVANCE ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS THAT
EXPAND WALKING AND BIKING
NETWORKS. INCREASES SAFETY AND
MOBILITY OF PEDESTRIANS AND
BICYCLISTS AND ADDRESS EQUITY
THROUGH PROJECTS TO RECONNECT
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE BEEN
HARMED BY THE TRANSPORTATION
DECISIONS OF THE PAST AND
PRIORITIZE MOVEMENT OF CARS OVER
PEOPLE. THE NEXT INVESTMENTS
FIVE HUNDRED GENERAL FUND TO
SUPPORT CRITICAL SAFETY
IMPROVEMENTS A GRADE CROSSINGS.
THIS IS A SITUATION WHERE A
RAILROAD CROSSING A HIGHWAY OR
STREET IN ST WHILE. THERE ARE
MANY OPPORTUNITIES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE TO ADDRESS THE MOST
DANGEROUS OF THESE CROSSINGS.
WHICH CAN BE DONE BY SEPARATING
THE ROAD AND RAILROAD INTO
SEPARATE LEVELS OR OTHERWISE
IMPROVING THE GRADE CROSSING TO
ADD MORE PROTECTION. IS
INVISIBLE TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
MORE CRITICAL GRADE CROSSINGS
ACROSS THE STATE. FILE FOR
DISCUSS TODAY IS IN AN- FOR
HUNDRED GENERAL FUND FOR
CLIMATIC PROJECTS. WITH SUPPORT
ON CLIMATE RESILIENCY AND REDUCE
RISKS TO INFRASTRUCTURE FROM
EXTREME WEATHER EVENTS. THE
PROPOSAL EMBRACES AND BUILD UPON
THE VISION OF A CLIMATE ACTION
PLAN FOR TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH ALIGNED OF
TRANSPORTATION SPENDING WITH
CLIMATE PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY
IN EQUITY BULLS. MAYBE SOMEBODY
TO TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
PROPOSAL MY COLLEAGUES I THINK
ALSO AND REPRESENTATIVES FROM
CALTRANS FOR THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCER AVAILABLE. TO HELP
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT
HOUSE. IT WOULD BE FROM FINANCE
LIKE THE COMMENT. KNOW DOUBT SIR
JAMES MORE FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE- BUT YOU KNOW WE'RE
WE'RE HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS ASSEMBLY CONCURRENCE
THE PROPOSAL. OKAY OF THE L. A-
PLEASE. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS FRANK MENACE WITH
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE- OUR OFFICE IN OUR
ANALYSIS HAS- ORGANIZATIONS AND
ISSUES FOR CONSIDERATION- FOR
THE GOVERNOR'S I'M
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
PACKAGE I'M FIRST- IN ORDER TO
MAXIMIZE IT WILL FUNDING FOR
TRANSPORTATION RECOMMENDED THE
LEGISLATURE TO THE GOVERNOR'S
PACKAGE IN THE CONTEXT OF THE
ANTICIPATED FEDERAL FUNDING
FROM. I HAD A J. AIM TO ENSURE
THAT THE STATE FUNDED YOU
STRATEGICALLY THIS COULD
INCLUDE- SUPPORTING LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES WORK FEDERAL FUNDS
ARE NOT A SIGNFICANT ARE ABSENT
AS WELL AS HELPING THE STATE BE
COMPETITIVE AND RECEIVING-
DISCRETIONARY. IN AND BUT-
GRANTS. KAMALA CONSIDERED.
EQUITY IN THE IN RAIL PLANNING.
IT EXTENDED THE LEGISLATURE
PARTNER IS- SOME OF BASE FUNDING
FOR PROJECTS- SHOULD BE PROVIDED
TO ALL REGIONS OF THE STATE-
THAT. GRAHAM IS A COMPETITOR
PROGRAM AND- A MORE COMPETITIVE
ALLOCATIONS COULD BETTER ENSURE
THE HIGHEST QUALITY PRODUCTS ARE
FUNDED. IT ALSO RESULTED IN
FUNDING APPLICATIONS THAT ARE
NOT UNDISTRIBUTED EQUITY
EQUITABLY ACROSS ALL REGIONS OF
THE STATE- THE LEGISLATURE COULD
CONSIDER PROVIDING FUNDING- FOR
TRANSIT RAIL PROJECTS OR
EXISTING- STATE FORMULA BASED
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS. BY
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL DEDICATED
FUNDS FOR DIFFERENT REGIONS-
SIMILAR TO HOW THERE'S A SET
ASIDE FOR THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA REGION- WE ALSO THE
LEGISLATURE REQUIRED. OF THE NEW
PROPOSED PROGRAMS TO ENSURE THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION PROVIDES.
INFORMATION REGARDING THE
PROGRAMMATIC OUTCOMES TO INFORM
FUTURE- POLICY AND FUNDING
DECISIONS PARTICULARLY FOR THE
HIGHWAYS TO BOULEVARD KIND OF
PROGRAM IN CLIMATE ADAPTATION
PROGRAMS. I'M CURRENTLY IN THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE PROPOSED-
THEY HAVE- NOW EVER SINCE THEY
HAVE SOME IN LIMITED
REQUIREMENTS FOR PROGRAM
EVALUATIONS. I'M HAVING ROBUST
EVALUATIONS WOULD BETTER INFORM
THE LEGISLATURE ON THE SUCCESSES
AND CHALLENGES OF THESE NEW
PROGRAMS AND IN TURN WHETHER AND
AT WHAT LEVEL TO CONTINUE
FUNDING- THESE PROGRAMS OR MANY
PROGRAMMATIC MODIFICATIONS ARE
NEEDED. AND THEN LASTLY WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE BE
MINDFUL OF THE STATE
APPROPRIATIONS LIMIT. I'M
MISSING MY GOVERNOR'S PACKAGE-
AS ANYWHERE ALLOCATION OF THIS
FUNDING WILL NEED TO BE- OR
SIMILAR NAMES ARE RELATED-
PURPOSES. I HAVE TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU MISTER
JIMENEZ. I THE WILL NOW START
WITH THIS FROM THE COMMITTEE I
LIKE TO JUST START OUT WITH- I
WOULD LIKE SOME CLARITY WITH
REGARDS TO THERE'S A STATE FUNDS
THAT WERE PROPOSING AND THEN
THERE'S OF COURSE FEDERAL
FUNDING. SO TO ME THE QUESTION
IS WHAT IS. WHAT REALLY HOW MUCH
ARE WE REALLY TALKING ABOUT THAT
GOES. TO THE STATE THAT THE
STATE- WILL DETERMINE. WHERE AND
HOW IT GETS SPENT AND THEN
THERE'S OF COURSE FUNDING THAT
COULD GO TO THE LOCAL- ENTITIES
LOCAL AGENCIES. SO IF SOMEONE-
MAYBE- MISTER QUANT OR ANYONE
ELSE COULD YOU CLARIFY THE
ACTUAL AMOUNTS THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT- I'VE SEEN YOU
KNOW THAT THE FIGURE OF FORTY
BILLION. IN FORMULA BASED
FUNDING FROM THE FEDERAL.
GOVERNMENT SO I WOULD LIKE SOME
CLARITY ON THAT BECAUSE I IT
APPEARS- THAT THERE'S A STRONG
ARGUMENT FOR US SPENDING MUCH
MORE MONEY ON TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE- SO IF YOU COULD
RESPOND TO THAT APPRECIATED. THE
MANAGER TO CONFIRM THE AMOUNT IS
FORTY BILLION DOLLARS OVER FIVE
YEARS FOR GUARANTEED FORMULA
FUNDING PROGRAMS- THERE'S ALSO
AN ADDITIONAL ADDITIONAL FUNDING
AVAILABLE FOR DISCRETIONARY
PROGRAMS AND I WILL TURN IT OVER
TO MY COLLEAGUE GILES JEFF NOT
TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CHAO'S RANTISI ADVISER ON
CALIFORNIA STATE TRANSPORTATION
AGENCY SO YES- THAT. OUR DAILY
RIGHT FORTY MILLION AND N. A
PORTION BY THIRTY- FIVE FROM FOR
HIGHWAY TYPE PRO ANOTHER
TENDERLY FOR TRANSIT. AND
PROBABLY FIVE YEARS WELL OVER A
HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS IN
FEDERAL DISCRETIONARY PROGRAMS
AND I THINK A LOT OF THEM ARE
YOU KNOW ARGUMENT FOR BUDGET
PROPOSAL IS SO RIGHT NOW- WE
WERE OFFERING UNDERTAKEN
RESOLUTION AND WE ARE HAVING
THERE'S AN AGGRESSIVE TIMELINE
OF THE WHITE HOUSE'S POSTED IT.
FOR STARTED TO DENOTE IS THE
FUNDING OPPORTUNITY FOR THIS
RAREST DISCRETIONARY PROGRAMS WE
SEE ONE PROGRAM WHAT THE DOOR
THE RESTART PROGRAM WORKS. A
NUMBER OF OTHER PROGRAMS TO GO
OUT IN THE FIRST QUARTER OF THIS
YEAR- AND- YOU KNOW WHAT WE
BELIEVE THAT WITH WITH THE
INFUSION OF INFRASTRUCTURE
FUNDING FOR THE STATE WE GET
BEING WELL POSITIONED TO. TO
TOOK TO LEVERAGE YOU KNOW
ADDITIONAL. DISCRETIONARY GRANTS
AS THEY COME OUT PROBABLY THE
SECOND CYCLE AT THE END OF THIS
YEAR ANZ IN EARLY NEXT YEAR FOR
ANY NUMBER OF DIFFERENT PROGRAMS
WITH AB TRADED FOR STRUCTURE
PROGRAMS LIKE THE IN FOR PROGRAM
OR DO PROGRAMS ON MEGA PROJECTS.
SO I THINK WE WOULD WANT TO SEE
A HALTER PROJECTS TO- TO AND
POTENTIAL POTENTIAL AWARDS. TO
SUPPORT FEDERAL ON THE PURSUIT
OF FEDERAL GRANTS PROBABLY AS
EARLY AS THE SECOND CYCLE OF
THESE ARE VARIOUS FEDERAL GRANTS. ARE COMING COMING OUT
DISCUSSION EARLY. THANK YOU I'M
- M. COULD YOU JUST. OF THE-
BILL OVER FIVE YEARS YOU SAID
THIRTY. TO HIGHWAY. THIRTY
BILLION HIGHWAY HIGHWAY TYPE
PROGRAMS TYPE PROBE DO NUMBER OF
FEDERAL. EVERYTHING FROM IN THE
FIRST TWO ZERO EMISSION BUSCA
FOR STRUCTURES- IN ABOUT TEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN IN- AND THEN
TRANSIT FORMULA GRANTS BUT THEN
THERE'S ADDITIONAL DISCRETIONARY
MONEY TO THINGS LIKE CAP- GRANT
AGREEMENT AND THEN THINGS LIKE
THAT FOR A FOR A FOR TRANSIT.
BUT ABOUT TEN MILLION FOR
TRANSIT IN ABOUT THREE MILLION
HIGHWAY TYPE I WOULD TYPE UP
ENFORCEMENT FORMULA. AND IS
THAT- I'M JUST TRYING TO THINK
AS PROP- I'M SURE WILL BE
PROPOSED. THAT THIRTY BILLION
HIGHWAY- REALLY A SAD AND OR CAN
IT BE USED FOR EXAMPLE PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION IS REALLY REALLY
IMPORTANT IN THE WHOLE STATE BUT
A SPECIALLY AND HIGHLY POPULATED
WE NEED MUCH MORE PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION AND AS I SAID
EARLIER THERE'S THE ISSUE OF
CLIMATE- THAT'S ALSO IMPACTED ON
THE MOVEMENT OF PEOPLE BESIDES
GOOD SO. COULD YOU HOW DOES
THAT- FIT INTO WHAT YOU JUST
SAID OF OUR POTENTIAL OUT OF
THIS FORTY BILLION DOLLARS FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. SEVERAL
ALSO MANAGE SEVERAL DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS A DIFFERENT SOME
DIFFERENT SETS OF GUIDELINES
AROUND THE MANY OF THEM ARE
LEGACY PROGRAMS- THAT WORD YEAH
WE'RE GONNA SEE SLIGHT AMENDMENT
IN THE GUIDELINES ARE A COUPLE
OF NEW. PROGRAMS ARE BEING
DEVELOPED ZERO MISSION ON THE
PROTECT FROM PROGRAM FOR CLIMATE
RESILIENCY BUT IN THE NUMBER OF
THESE FEDERAL. HIGHWAY PROGRAMS
THERE'S THE ABILITY TO FLEX
FEDERAL MONEY FOR EXAMPLE THE
SEGREGATION EDUCATION AIR
QUALITY PROGRAM TO REDUCE OUR TO
IMPROVE AIR QUALITY CENTER A
GOOD A WELL KNOWN. FOR FEDERAL
DECIDE PORTION OF PROGRAM WHICH
GIVES YOU THE ABILITY TO FLEX
MONEY TOWARD TOWARD JOB TRANSIT
TYPE PROJECTS- I BELIEVE THIS
THE SURFACE TRANSPORTATION BLOCK
GRANT PROGRAMS AND OTHER
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE CERTAIN
FLEXIBILITY SO- WE- GET IN THESE
GUIDELINES ARE GOING TO BE
MOVING FORWARD BY THE US
DEPARTMENT TRANSPORTATION WILL
GET THE SPECIFICS. ON YOU KNOW
WHAT OUR ABILITY IS GOING TO BE
TO DO FLEXING TO THESE TYPES OF
PROJECTS- AND THEN BEEN THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
TRANSPORTATION IS CURRENTLY SORT
OF WORKING THROUGH THIS WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AND KIND OF.
DETERMINING HOW THEY'RE GONNA
ALLOCATE MONEY MANY OF THEM
SERVING SUGGESTING STATE
PROGRAMS BUT AGAIN WE'LL SEE THE
FINAL GUIDANCE COME OUT FOR SIX
FEDERAL PROGRAMS MANY OF THESE
PROGRAMS DO HAVE FLEXIBILITY TO
DO. WHAT THE FLEX MONEY FROM
TRADITIONAL HIGHWAY PROJECTS TO
TRANSIT PROJECTS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I'D LIKE TO ASK MY
COLLEAGUES. ON THE COMMITTEE
SENATOR NEWMAN. A THEN CENTER.
IN THANK YOU MAY. TO ENSURE I
NOTED I AM THE SENATE.
REPRESENTED C. TO SEE AN EX
OFFICIO COOPER- IT YEAH AND I
THINK IT'S WORTH NO THAT THAT
THE CA. WAS YOUR CREATED AS AN
INFANT AGENTS. TO PROVIDE
DISTRICT. AND OF STATE FOR
ADMINISTERING TRANSFER FOR
PROGRAM. SO EXCESS ILEAGE X.
FOR ACT OF TRANCE CLIMATE
ADAPTATION. PROJECT FUNDING THE
MOST OF THESE FUNDS IN FACT THE
REMAINDER WOULD BE ADMINISTERED
BY CAL STAR AND CALTRANS- IT'S
LIKE I HAVE TWO QUESTIONS FOR.
THE ADMINISTRATION TOOL FOR YOU
KNOW FIRSTOF WHAT IS THE
RATIONALE. FOR SHIFTING THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR
ADMINISTRATIVE ADMINISTERING
THESE FUNDS AWAY FROM THE SEA TO
SEA. YEAH AND I GUESS CONVERSELY
- WHAT WE KNOW WHAT'S THE
RATIONALE FOR- SPENDING THESE MY
- THROUGH THE CITY'S. I THINK AS
THERE ARE SOME QUESTIONS AROUND
EQUITY IN DISTRIBUTION- THAT IS
HISTORICALLY BEEN AN AREA WHERE
THE CDC HAS PLAYED A VERY
IMPORTANT ROLE. IN AND MIGHT MY
THIRD QUESTION I GUESS IS
SHIFTING THE RESPONSIBILITY THAT
CONSISTENT. WITH THE STATUTORY
ROLE OF THE COMMISSION- AS IT
WAS ESTABLISHED BY THE
LEGISLATURE. THE QUESTION AND I
WILL HAVE. MY COLLEAGUE
UNDERSECRETARY WAS A KIND OF
RESPONSE TO THE QUESTION. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL IS
ALIGNED WITH- IT IS. IT
XCELERATED THE DISTRIBUTION OF
FUNDING. FROM THE GENERAL FUND
AND IN THESE ARE NOT TRADITIONAL
RESOURCES- THAT FLOWS THROUGH
THAT COMMISSION- AND PROMINENT
THAT STATE HIGHWAY AT COUNTY
THESE ARE. ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
IN PROPOSALS AND WE WILL WORK
CLOSELY WITH ALL OF OUR
DEPARTMENTS AND OUR STAKEHOLDERS
IN ORDER TO. DISTRIBUTE THE
FUNDING. AS EXPEDITIOUSLY AS
POSSIBLE. AND SERVE OUR RESPONSE
A MEDIAN OF THE RATIONALE THESE
ARE ONE FINE- IN MEDICAID
HISTORICALLY THAT HAS BEEN
PRECISELY THE ROLE CTC IS TO
ADMINISTER SIMILAR KINDS OF ONE
TIME FUNDING. GEORGE NOW I GUESS
NOT A MEDIA IS SOMETHING THAT WE
AS A BODY NEED TO CONSIDER- AND
I KNOW IT WILL COME UP THROUGH
BUDGET AND I'M SURE WE'LL
DISCUSS IT IN. THE
TRANSPORTATION AS WELL OBSERVE
THANK YOU MEASURE. THANK YOU
CENTER NEWMAN CENTER COURTESY.
I'M SURE OF YES AS PER MY
EARLIER COMMENTS ON THE T. R. R.
C. P. PARTICULARLY- IT AGAIN UP
I WOULD BE JUST BECAUSE FOR A
MINUTE AND DO SOMETHING IN A
SENSE OF MORE TO SENATOR NEWMAN
IN BY WAY OF BACKGROUND- I THINK
WE ALL HAVE- SOME FAIRLY DIRECT
EXPERIENCE WITH THE REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION OUR RESPECTIVE.
AREAS AND WAR IN A STATE
INVOLVEMENT THOUGH LIKE CENTER
NEWMAN NEWMAN'S WITH CTC SO GIVE
US A CALL PART OF THE CONTEXT
FOR ME. RAISING THE ISSUE- HINT
IN TERMS OF THAT I'M GONNA REYES
IN TERMS OF- THE T. I. R. C. P.
IT. IT SEEMS THAT- HAS BEEN AS
GRATEFUL AS I AM FOR THE THREE
POINT THREE BILLION DOLLARS A
PROPOSAL- GRATEFUL THAT WERE
EVEN IN A POSITION IN THE TO
MAKE THESE OVERALL INVESTMENTS.
IT IS IN AN AREA. THAT I KNOW IF
I WORK FOR TO SPEAK JUST OF THE
BAY AREA AND I DON'T DO THAT HOW
TO THE LACK OF- SENSITIVITY TO
GEOGRAPHIC EQUITY BUT THE
PEOPLE. I KNOW THE BAY AREA I
THINK THEY SERVE ON THE MEDICAL
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSIONER THE
MPO FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS. THE
TO KEY PROJECTS THAT WOULD BE-
COMPETING OR OR SEEKING FUNDS
YOU KNOW UNDER THIS PROGRAM-
PROBABLY COULD EASILY TAKE UP
THAT ENTIRE AMOUNT THEMSELVES
AND US JUST IN THE SHOULD THAT
THAT THAT ISN'T THE POINT I
THINK THE POINT IS IT IT JUST
JUMPS OUT AT ME AS AN AREA THAT.
COULD UTILIZE ADDITIONAL
AUGMENTATION AND BILL MY SENSES
MANAGER YOU'RE DOUBLING DOWN ON
THAT FIGURE WOULD NEED TO BE OF
THE QUESTION GOING FROM THREE TO
SIX BILLION FOR EXAMPLE
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU START
LOOKING AT WHAT I WHAT I THINK I
KNOW JUST FROM HEARING FROM
COLLEAGUES AS TO WHAT'S GOING ON
SO THE CALIFORNIA AND OTHER
PLACES WITH. SIMILAR PROJECTS
TO. WHAT WOULD. WITH A WE ALWAYS
REFERRED TO AS AS PART TO THE
SOUTH BAY OR THE TRANSBAY
TERMINAL IN SAN FRANCISCO OR- OF
THE CALTRAIN ELECTRIFICATION
PROJECT THAT COMES DOWN FROM SAN
FRANCISCO TO SAN JOSE- THE THESE
ARE. HIGH PRIORITY PROJECTS IN
THE BAY AREA THAT ARE. THAT ARE
UNDER WAY BUT- TYPICALLY WILL-
IN NEED OF NOT TYPICALLY BRIDGES
IN NEED OF ADDITIONAL FUNDING-
YOU KNOW ON THE ROAD SO EIGHT
WONDER HOW YOU TO THE ELOISE COM
ELIAS'S COMMENTS HOW YOU. GET TO
GEOGRAPHIC EQUITY WITH THAT KIND
OF A NUMBER WITHOUT. SORT OF
MINIMIZING THE IMPACT OF THE
NUMBER YOU KNOW WHAT IT IS
CREATING SORT OF SUCH A SMALL
CONTRIBUTION TO EACH PROJECT
THAT IT'S NOT REALLY HELPING
THEM TO SUSTAIN JOBS MAY NOT AS
I WAS ALLUDING TO EARLIER GET US
THROUGH. THE NEXT DOWNTURN- THAT
SAID- THOSE ARE COMMENTS AND I'M
MORE THAN HAPPY TO HEAR RESPONSE
TO THEM EIGHT I DON'T KNOW. I
UNDERSTAND THIS IS THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL SO I
DON'T. ASK YOU TO NEGOTIATE
AGAINST YOURSELVES BY SUGGESTING
YOU KNOW WHERE AND HOW TO
FURTHER AUGMENT THAT BUCKET-
THIS IS A TARC P. BUCKET BUT-
IT'S SOMETHING I THINK THAT WE
SHOULD BE- LOOKING AT THE
COLLEAGUES MANAGER IN IN ONE OF
THE QUESTIONS I HAVE I MEAN
CLEARLY. WHAT'S HAPPENING HERE
AS I UNDERSTAND IT IS A GENERAL
FUND AUGMENTATION OF THE PROGRAM
THERE FOR. THE PROGRAM EVEN
THOUGH THE THESE ADDITIONAL
DOLLARS WOULD BE COMING FROM THE
GENERAL FUND THEY WOULD STILL BE
. THEY WOULD STILL BE UNDER THE
- THE FORMULA IF YOU'LL
DISTRIBUTED BY THE SAME FORMULA
REQUIREMENTS RESTRICTIONS AND SO
FORTH- THAT THAT WE SEE IN THE
PROGRAM CURRENTLY. IN IN IT
RAISES A QUESTION FOR ME IN
TERMS OF MIGHT IT NOT BE BETTER
. UGH TO THAT MAKE SURE WE'RE
DISCUSSING. WHETHER OR NOT WE
REALLY WANT TO DO THAT SINCE WE
HAVE WILL TYPICALLY HAVE
LATITUDE WITH ENERAL FUND
DOLLARS AND HYPOTHETICALLY WE
COULD BE TAKING A LIST OF
PROJECTS. GOING BACK TO THE
ALEJO'S COMMENTS ABOUT
GEOGRAPHIC EQUITY IN PROBABLY OR
JUST GENERAL POLITICAL CONCERNS
. IN THEORY WE COULD TAKE A LIST
OF PROJECTS AND JUST SAY THESE
ARE AUGMENTED BY THESE DOLLARS
AS A MATTER OF LEGISLATIVE.
PRIORITY JUST LEGISLATIVE
ACTION- IN IT OR YOU KNOW WE
COULD WE COULD HAVE MONEY. JUST
GO DIRECTLY INTO THE PROGRAM BUT
BASED ON THE WAY THIS THIS
BUDGET RECOMMENDATION IS LAID
OUT IN IT AGAIN BE. SORT OF
COMPETED FOR WITH THE SAME
RESTRICTIONS ONE OF THE CONCERNS
I WOULD HAVE ABOUT THAT IS I
THINK THAT THERE ARE PROJECTS AS
I UNDERSTAND IT THAT WOULD NOT
BE ABLE TO COMPETE FOR THE
ADDITIONAL MONEY. UNDER TI RCP
IF THEY RECEIVE DOLLARS FROM
THAT PROGRAM IN THE PAST IT'S A
ONE AND DONE TYPE OF A PROGRAM
YOU'RE NOT. CURRENTLY ALLOWED TO
COME BACK YOU KNOW TO FINISH
WHAT YOU'RE DOING SO TO SPEAK IN
IN SEEK MONEY FROM THE PROGRAM
AGAIN. SO LET ME ASK IN THE FORM
OF A QUESTION AFTER MAKING ALL
THOSE COMMENTS. AM I CORRECT
THAT THESE DOLLARS. WOULD NOT BE
AVAILABLE. TO- BUT TO REAL PART
IN INTERCITY RAIL PROJECTS THAT
HAVE RECEIVED MONEY FROM THE
PROGRAM IN THE PAST. SENATOR ARE
TO RESPOND TO YOUR QUESTION YOU
KNOW I WANTED TO KNOW THE T. R.
C. G. IS A PRIMARY PROGRAM AFTER
WHICH TRANSIT REALPOLITIK
STEPHANIE FROM STATE RESOURCES.
WE WOULD BE ABLE TO IMPLEMENT A
NEW ROUND OF PROJECT AWARD WITH
A CALL FOR PROJECTS
APPROXIMATELY SIXTY DAYS AFTER
LEGISLATIVE ACTIONS TAKEN.
GETTING THIS POSITION WELL TO
ADDRESS OF THE PERSON FEDERAL
FUNDING. ALSO T. R. C. P. IS
WELL SUITED FOR SELECTING
PROJECTS THAT CAN COMPETE WELL
FOR NEW MONEY IN THE I. J. WHICH
INCLUDES A GREAT DEAL OF
INTERCITY RAIL FUNDING. IN
REGARDS TO YOUR- THE COMMENTS
ABOUT THE GEOGRAPHIC EQUITY
GEOGRAPHIC EQUITY IS A STATUTORY
REQUIREMENT IN THE J. R. C. P.
PROGRAM. AT THIS POINT I'LL TURN
IT OVER TO- UNDERSECRETARY WAS
THE. KIND OF TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION. THANK
YOU. IN TERMS OF THE GUIDE. FOR
PRODUCT OF PROJECTS UNDER THE
BUDGET PROPOSAL- THE- OF THE
ADDITIONAL. THROUGH A GENERAL
FUND APPROACH. WE WILL BE
LOOKING TO- ED TO MODIFY. THE TO
FOR THE ONE. SPECIAL CYCLE. THE
WE- ISSUE. AN I HAVE A CALL FOR-
THEY COULD BE. PROJECTS THAT
AREN'T TYPICALLY. ELIGIBLE UNDER
THE BEAST- REGULAR PROGRAM AND
THAT STANDARD WITH CAPTAIN TRADE
AND THEN SB ONE DOLLAR. HOW
CLOSE ARE YOU HAVE BEEN. THOSE
THROUGH THOSE GUIDELINES.
COMPLETED WAIT. BE INTO THE A
SHORTLY AFTER- ENACTMENT OF FUND
AND BUT- IT'S AN EGG. APPROACH
ME I. THAT WE COULD PUT TOGETHER
THE GUIDELINES AND ISSUE A CALL
FOR PROJECTS WITHIN ABOUT SIXTY
DAYS- OF THE NEXT ROUND OF
FUNDING. I THINK TO BE SOME-
PERHAPS MAYBE THAT'S JUST
SPEAKING THROUGH THE LENS OF A
LEGISLATOR TO ADD TO KNOWINGLY
SEND DRAFT WOULD- PUT THE
FRAMEWORK IS THAT YOU'RE
CONSIDERING IN IN TERMS OF NEW
GUIDELINES- I RECOGNIZE THE- IS
SOMETIMES DOING THAT KIND OF
THING IS- FRAUGHT WITH THE
ISSUES BECAUSE PEOPLE START
RELYING ON. A WITH THE DRAFT
GUIDELINES ARE GOING TO BE HERE
WITH WITH THOSE IDEAS ARE BUT-
THE FLIP SIDE OF IT IS HOW DO
YOU SUPPORTED AS A LEGISLATOR.
WHEN YOU'VE GOT. THE YOU KNOW
THE KIND OF CONCERNS THAT I JUST
REYES WITHOUT REPEATING ANY OF
THOSE- AND WITHOUT KNOWING
WHETHER OR NOT. YOU KNOW
PROJECTS IN YOUR REGION THAT ARE
KEY PROJECTS ARE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO- YOU KNOW COMPETE FOR
FUNDING OR SEEK FUNDING UNDER
THE NEW GUIDELINES SO I JUST I
JUST REYES SAID AS A- I'M NOT
ASKING. YOU TO COMMIT RIGHT NOW
ONE WAY OR THE OTHER TO-
ADVANCING THE LEGISLATURE
INFORMATION ON ON. MORE
SPECIFICALLY WHAT YOU'RE
THINKING IN TERMS OF- IN TERMS
OF THOSE GUIDELINES BUT- I JUST
WANT TO TRY TO IMPRESS UPON YOU
THAT WOULD HELP A LOT YOU KNOW
IN TERMS OF- SORT OF GOOD FAITH
YOU KNOW OF. US KNOWING. HAVE A
BETTER FEEL FOR. WHAT WE'RE
GONNA BE ABLE TO DELIVER THROUGH
THE PROGRAM GOING FORWARD. ON
THE FEDERAL SIDE I THINK THIS IS
PROBABLY MY LAST QUESTION-
MANAGER. OF THE ON THE- A VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR
COMMENTS IN I COULD TELL BY THE-
I THINK I CAN TELL BY THE
URGENCY IN YOUR IN YOUR VOICES-
THE TROOPER EAGER TO. GET THIS
MOVING- YOU KNOW GET THOSE
GUIDELINES- GET. PROJECTS
ALIGNED WITH FEDERAL INVESTMENT.
BUT WHICH I THINK PROBABLY
JUMPED OUT AT ALL OF US HERE ON
THE COMMITTEE- AS WELL AS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY AGAIN OPTED WE DON'T
WANT TO MISS. WHAT WOULD BE THE
QUESTION I HAVE IS WHAT WOULD BE
. THE NUMBER YOU WOULD WANT
INTII RC P. IF WE ALL HAD OUR
DRUTHERS IN TERMS OF MAXIMIZING
MAXIMIZING- ALIGNMENT IN
OPPORTUNITY YOUR- WITH A FEDERAL
PROGRAM IS IT THREE POINT THREE
BILLION OR- IS IT A HIGHER
NUMBER. THANK YOU FOR YOUR YOUR
YOUR QUESTION OR COMMENT. AND I
THINK WE ALL KNOW THERE IS NO
SHORTAGE OF AGREED TO IT TRANSIT
AND RAIL PROJECTS AND THAT THAT
COULD USE- SOME ADDITIONAL
FUNDING AND THE STATE PROPOSED
PACKAGE- FOR INFRASTRUCTURE- IS
- TRANSACTION- AND RAIL
INVESTMENTS- AND- ACROSS THE
STATE. AND WOULD IT BE
SUFFICIENT FOR SOME OF THE EARLY
FEDERAL PROGRAMS THAT WERE SEEN
COME OUT AND WE'RE TYPICALLY
THERE CAN BE A TEN OR 20% STATE
MATCH- FOR THE PROJECT AND IT
WOULD STILL PROVIDE. A
SIGNIFICANT OPPORTUNITY TO
LEVERAGE THOSE ADDITIONAL.
FEDERAL GRANT OPPORTUNITIES. IT
A TO GIVE A GOOD BY THE WAY OF
THE QUESTION I MY- IS- HE IS A
WE DON'T FALL SHORT OF WHATEVER
IT THE MAXIMUM MATCHES THE- BILL
WILL NEED OR THAT WE COULD PUT
UP I MEAN WALKING INTO IN A
NUMBER. EITHER OF THE THREE
BILLION IS THREE POINT THREE
BILLION IS- IF EVERYTHING AFTER
THAT IS DIMINISHING RETURNS
BECAUSE WE CAN'T MATCH IT. I
MEAN OBVIOUSLY. SOMEBODY SHOULD
SAY THAT BUT IF WE'RE NOT SURE
THE I GUESS THE PERIL IS OF
COURSE THE WE SETTLE ON THREE
POINT. THREE BILLION IN THIS
PROGRAM FOR EXAMPLE- AS
ADMINISTRATION AS A LEGISLATURE
AND THEN. IN THE FALL SHORT OF.
OF TAKING FULL ADVANTAGE OF- OF
THE POTENTIAL FOR FEDERAL MATCH
SO AGAIN I'M NOT I THINK YOU
ANSWERED THE QUESTION. FROM YOUR
STANDPOINT BUT I WANTED TO. JUST
GET ON THE RECORD WHAT MY
CONCERN IS ABOUT THAT- IN EIGHT
AND AGAIN I APPRECIATE YOUR
RESPONSES- HERO WE'RE ALL
EXCITED ABOUT SEEING THIS
INVESTMENT COMING ALONG. HERE
AND I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE-
PARTICULAR IN TERMS THESE RAIL
PROJECTS THAT WE'RE NOT GETTING
INTO A SITUATION- THAT WE MIGHT
BE ABLE TO AVOID. YOU KNOW WHERE
- WHERE WE HAVE. UNFINISHED
PROJECTS HE HIGH- THERE'S A I
LOVE I LOVE THE TITLE THAT IT OF
THE FIX IT FIRST PROGRAM WE USE
THAT AT THE REGIONAL LEVEL IN
THE BAY AREA IN TERMS OF TAKE
CARE OF WHAT YOU HAVE FIRST- I
THINK THE NEXT HIGHEST PRIORITY
FOR ME IS YOU KNOW FINISH WHAT
YOU STARTED. IN I THINK THAT'S
WHERE MY SENTIMENTS COMING FROM
MAKING SURE WE DON'T HAVE.
POSTER CHILD PROJECTS- OUR
HEROES SORT OF THE REAL THE REAL
PROJECT TO KNOW WHERE BECAUSE WE
CAN'T GET THE REST OF THE WAY.
SO THANK YOU AGAIN MANAGER.
THANK YOU SENATOR- NOW THIS AND
BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO- ISSUE SIX
I WANT TO CLARIFY. THE AMOUNTS
HERE- THIS IS FOR THE FIVE
BILLION IN GENERAL FUND FOR
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE.
BUT THERE WAS FROM LAST YEAR
SINCE WE DIDN'T APPROVE LAST
YEAR'S. ALL WE CAN GO FORWARD
WITH THE- AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT
HAD BEEN PROPOSED LAST YEAR. IS
THIS HOW DOES THIS TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT WHAT WE DIDN'T DO LAST
YEAR. WITH WHAT'S BEING PROPOSED
FOR THIS YEAR- THAT'S ONE QUICK
QUESTION HOPEFULLY THERE'S A
SHORT ANSWER- AND TO I GUESS IS
IF A SERVER CORTEZ THE WEEK THE
QUESTIONS ARE ASKING ABOUT
GUIDELINES WAS OUT ABOUT. THE
WAY TO PRIORITIZE THAT WAS NOT
THE POINT OF YOUR QUESTION
BECAUSE OF MY QUESTION IS HOW
WILL THE ADMINISTRATION-
PRIORITIZE- PROJECTS WITH THESE
RESOURCES WITHOUT. GETTING OUR
ABOUT WHAT YOU'RE ASKING IS WELL
I HEARD. A RESPONSE THAT THE
GUIDELINES TO ANSWER QUESTION TO
ME THAT THE GUIDELINES WILL BE
CHANGING TO ALLOW GREATER
LATITUDE THAN WHAT. WOULD BE
ALLOWED TODAY UNDER TRC P. BUT
WHAT I WAS RAISING IS WHEN DO WE
GET TO SEE THOSE BECAUSE- IT
WOULD BE ONE TO PUT THE
GUIDELINE INTO A FOR. AFTER THE
FUNDING IS APPROVED. BUT WHICH
KIND OF PUTS US. OPERATING A
LITTLE BLIND SO TO SPEAK THAT WE
VOTE AND THEN WE FIND OUT IF OUR
PROJECTS ARE ARE GOING TO BE
ELIGIBLE OR NOT HI THAT'S WHAT I
HEARD BUT I'D- OKAY I DON'T
KNOW. IF I SAID THAT CORRECTLY
IN ANY TYPE OF THE SAME QUESTION
YOU'RE ASKING THEM SENATOR. SO-
AT THE QUESTION OF PRIORITIZING
AND ALSO WHAT IS THE ACTUAL
AMOUNT AS COMPARED TO LAST YEAR
AND THIS YEAR'S IT TOGETHER IT'S
A TWO SEPARATE COULD YOU CLARIFY
THAT. THE QUESTION MANAGER. FOR
THIS QUESTION I'D LIKE TO
REQUEST- BERMAN FINANCED TO WIN
. OKAY THE MISTER MOORE-
STOCKWELL'S FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE OKAY. ABOUT WHAT
EXISTS OF LAST YEAR- THIS THIS
PROPOSAL IS A BILLION DOLLARS
MORE ON THE TRANSIT SIDE THAN
THAN WHAT WAS IN LAST YEAR'S
PROPOSAL- WE'VE ALSO INCLUDED A
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS MORE FOR THE- FOR THE-
ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION AND
COMMUNITY PROJECTS- OVER ABOVE
THE FIVE HUNDRED MILLION THAT WE
HAD THAT WE HAD- PROPOSED LAST
YEAR. ADDITIONALLY WE'VE
INCLUDED THE FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR- I CLIMATE
ADAPTATION THAT WAS A ARE ON
LEGISLATIVE I REQUEST FROM LAST
YEAR SO WE'VE TAKEN B. THREE
BILLION DLLARS AND THEN GENERAL
FUND PROPOSALS THAT WERE- SORT
OF HELD OVER FROM LAST YEAR AND
THEN WE'VE ADDED TO THAT- BUT
JUST FIVE TWO BILLION DOLLARS.
IN ADDITIONAL REQUESTED FUNDS.
OKAY OKAY- END UP THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE VIOLENCE
IS THAT THE ANSWER TO THE
QUESTION A PRIORITIZING. MADAM
CHAIR THE GUIDELINES WOULD BE.
THE SECOND WITH- CRITERIA AND
ELIGIBILITY THAT WAY AND
IDENTIFY. ALIGNED WITH THOSE
CRITERIA AND WOULD HELP
PRIORITIZE THE FUNDING AS WELL
AS A GEOGRAPHIC. OF THE FUNDING
AND THAT WOULD BE SPECIFIED IN
THE GUIDELINES. OKAY WELL AS YOU
CAN HEAR THAT THE GREAT
IMPORTANCE TO US IS
UNDERSTANDING HOW. NOT ONLY THE
TOTAL AMOUNT OF MONEY BUT HOW
AND WHAT. THE NEEDS ARE THE
PRIORITY- SO THAT WE COULD BE
ENGAGED IN THAT BECAUSE- I THINK
IT'S MORE ABOUT NEEDS- AND-
OVERALL PRIORITIES THAT WE HAVE
FOR THE FOR THE STATE SO. WE
WOULD REALLY LIKE TO SEE THAT AS
PART OF THETRANSPORTATION
BUDGET THANK YOU YES CENTER
NEWMAN. JUST A REALLY GREAT
COMMON AS I LISTEN SO- I THINK
I'D I'D I'D LIKE LET ME ADD
WHICH WE SHOULD ALSO GIVE SOME
THOUGHT COLLECTIVELY ABOUT HOW
WE- CONVEY TO THE PUBLIC- WHAT
WE'RE DOING HOW WE'RE DOING IT
WHY IT'S VALUABLE. OUR
ACCOUNTABLE- AND WE ARE WHAT
WE'RE TALKING WE'RE TALKING AND
AMEND SUMS OF MONEY- AND
SOMEBODY MADE THE POINT THAT
GRADE SEPARATIONS ARE EXPENSIVE
AND I'M CONTINUALLY ASKED BY MY
CONSTITUENTS LIKE. YOU KNOW WHAT
WE GET FOR TWENTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS AND DID. YOU KNOW THAT
THAT'S A TEENY TINY FRACTION
RIGHT TO THERE'S A GREAT SAYING
LIKE BILLION HERE A BILLION
THERE SIMILAR TALK ABOUT REAL
MONEY. AND WE'RE WE'RE TALKING A
REAL MONEY AND WE'RE WE'RE
PROBABLY NOT DOING A TERRIFIC
JOB COLLECTIVELY- ED CONVEYING
TO OUR CONSTITUENTS TO YOU KNOW
TO TAXPAYERS- HOW WE'RE SPENDING
THAT MONEY HOW WE'RE
PRIORITIZING THESE PROJECTS. AND
THE VALUE THAT WE'RE BRINGING TO
THEM WITH THEIR. HARD EARNED TAX
DOLLARS SO THANK YOU. I'M SORRY
I HAD MORE. BOMB WOULD COME. OF
LAID REQUIRED. BOB FOR PROJECTS
FUNDED THROUGH THESE PROGRAMS
HOW DO WE MAKE SURE THAT THEY
ARE GOOD. HIGH PAYING JOBS. I
DON'T KNOW WHO WOULD LIKE. FOR
THE QUESTION- YEAH A GOOD HIGH
PAYING. JOBS AND TRANSFERRED.
ARE YOU MINISTRY PRIORITY WELL.
AND WE WOULD BE LOOKING IMPROVE
CRITERIA THAT ADDRESSED. THOSE
THOSE AT GOALS AND OBJECTIVES
AND- THAT WOULD BE INCLUDE AS
WELL- SO THAT WE- TARGET THIS-
TO GO HI JOBS COULD WORKFORCE.
AND PROJECT REMEMBRANCE. I'M
SORRY TO YOU SAY THAT AGAIN DID
QUITE CATCH THAT. SECOND THIS IS. THAT'S RIGHT PRIORITIES PRIOR
TO BE GIVEN AGES THAT BRING UP
THE MANY COURSE PROJECT WE
PROBABLY AGREEMENTS. OKAY GREAT
I WILL HAVE- HIGH ROUTE- THE
PROGRAMS HOST. LANGUAGE IT ALL
OF THE AND DOES NOT LANGUAGE BE
AND IN THE LINE- IN WE DO A THAT
IN OUR ON A TYPICAL THE RCP R.
PROGRAMS AS WELL KNOWN MAN ONE
LAST THING FOR WOULD ALSO BE
GIVEN THE FORCE TO FOR IN HIGH
POPULAR AND COMMUNITIES RIGHT
THANK ALL VERY MUCH- IF WE CAN
WE LIKE TO MOVE ON ISSUE SAID
THANK YOU ON. YES TO SUB ONE
MORE THING ON THE GUARD AND-
BACK TO THIS ISSUE WHEN THEY
WILL BE READY WILL. WELL THE ANY
ENGAGED. A B. TWO. THE AND- OF
THE REGIONAL. IT TO THE CMP- THE
REGIONAL- THE- PRIOR TO. SERVICE
SEVENTEEN INTO TO A FINAL SET OF
GUIDELINES WILL THEY HAVE AN
OPPORTUNE THIS IS A LITTLE COULD
GOING BACK SOMEWHAT TO CENTER
NEWMAN'S POINT THERE THE NEXT
LEVEL- NOT QUITE AS CLOSE AS THE
COUNTIES OR THE CITIES TO THE
GENERAL PUBLIC BUT- YOU KNOW
THERE THE NEXT LEVEL DOWN I'M
JUST WONDERING. IF THOSE LOCAL
OFFICIALS TYPICALLY WHO SERVE ON
THOSE REGIONAL ENTITIES WILL
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO RESPOND
RESPOND OR REACT TO THE
GUIDELINES BEFORE THEY'RE
ADOPTED. SENATOR YES. THE
GUIDELINES ON WOULD BE-
CONDUCTED IF THEY'RE IN DEVELOP-
THROUGH A PUBLIC ENGAGEMENT
PROCESS- WE WORK CLOSELY AND
WE'RE WORKING CLOSELY WITH OTHER
TRANSIT RAIL STAKEHOLDERS RIGHT
NOW ON THE- CURRENT CYCLE FOR
TIER CITIES TAT WE'VE BEEN
HAVING A LOT OF THESE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT HIGH
PRIORITY PROJECTS- AND WHAT
PROJECTS ARE READY TO BE FUNDED
AND COMPLETED- AND WE WOULD HAVE
A PUBLIC ENGAGEMENT PROCESS-
RELEASING DRAFT GUIDELINES ON
BEFORE FINALIZING. OKAY GREAT
ANSWER THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK
YOU EVERYONE WILL NOW MOVE TO
ISSUE SIX WHICH IS THE FUEL
EXCISE TAX PROPOSAL AND TO CALL
ON THE ADMINISTRATION. TO PLEASE
PRESENT. CHURNS. IN ADDITION.
THE PROPOSAL- LAW REQUIRES THE
STE YOU ACCESS RATES ON JULY
EVERY YEAR YOU JUST WANT TO TALK
MANAGING THE CAL CONSUMER PRICE
WHICH GENERALLY MEASURES THE
PRICE CAL STATE FOR REGIONS ARE
. IN AN EFFORT TO POTENTIALLY
LOW THE PRICE GASOLINE AND
DIESEL AND PROVIDE SOME- TO
COULD IT MAY PROPOSED TO FORM
THE AND INFLATION ADJUSTMENTS TO
THAT EARLY ON FEEL LESS TAX TO
ON JULY. TWENTY TWENTY TWO. THE
ANNUAL ADJUSTMENT WOULD BE
RESUMED BY TWO TWENTY TO TWENTY.
BUT FLEXIBILITY IS DELAYED YOU
JUST SHOULD ECONOMIC WERE IT. IS
POLL WOULD DECREASE TAX BY. FIVE
HUNDRED TO THREE TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. BASED ON. ESTIMATE FIVE
POINT SIX PER INFLATION RATE.
ADMINISTRATION WOULD RECEIVE
BACK THE SHARE OF REDUCE. ON A
ONE TIME BASIS WILL STAY HIGH
CAL. ON THIS SIDE AND HI.
REPRESENTED IN COUNTY IS FIND
AVAILABLE TO RESPOND ANY
QUESTION THANK YOU. THANK YOU-
WOULD DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE LIKE
TO COMMON. THIS IS STEVE THE
FINANCE- JUST WANT TO ADD THE-
YOU KNOW THAT THERE ARMS. THE
STATE DOES HAVE A WHOLE LOTTA
LOVE IT CAN PULL TO IMPACT- GAS
PRICES SO- WE'RE LOOKING AT THIS
AS AS ONE OF THE FEW AREAS WHERE
WE ACTUALLY- DO HAVE SOMETHING
THAT WE CAN DO- THAT DIRECTLY
THERE ARE. IN FACT THE FIRST
BOX. AND WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS. ARISE. OKAY OF THANK
YOU- ANYONE FROM THE L. A. O.
OFFICE. YES SIR CHRISTINE WITH
THE L. A. L. THE GENDER IT
COVERS OUR ANALYSIS IN DETAIL SO
I'LL JUST SUM IT UP BRIEFLY. AS
A ROUGH GUIDE. THANK LINE NINETY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS. I'M SORRY
MR ENDS AT THIS CHRISTINE STATE
FOR THE TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
FISCAL YEAR IT CAN EFFECTIVELY.
L. ONCE AND IN INTACT REYES
SEVEN. HOLD ON MR CHRISTINE HOLD
ON JUST ONE SECOND IS NUMBERS
AND MINE'S A LITTLE RESTAURANT
FOR THE LEGISLATURE HELLO IS
SLOW BUT NOW ONE SEARCHING HELLO
HELLO I'M SORRY YOU'RE BREAKING
IN AND OUT IT'S VERY DIFFICULT
TO FOLLOW YOU MAY BE IF YOU TURN
OFF THE VIDEO YOU MIGHT HAVE A
LITTLE BIT MORE. JUICE. OKAY YOU
WANT TO START AGAIN THANK YOU
SURE SURE I'LL GIVE IT A TRY-
MICHELLE START FROM THE
BEGINNING YES. OKAY THANKS%
CHRISTINE WITH THE L. A. L. E. A
IN DETAIL SO I WILL JUST. SUMMIT
UP BRIEFLY AS A ROUGH GUIDELINE
FOR EVERY ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN FUEL TAX
REVENUE THAT THE STATE FORGOES
AND TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
FISCAL YEAR IT CAN EFFECTIVELY
BY A ONE CENT PER GALLON
REDUCTION IN GASOLINE TAX RATES.
AND A SEVEN TENTHS OF A CENT PER
GALLON REDUCTION IN DIESEL TAX
RATES SO- FOR WITH THOSE NUMBERS
IN MIND THE KEY QUESTIONS OF THE
LEGISLATURE IS WHAT BALANCE TO
STRIKE BETWEEN REDUCING FUEL
EXPENSES AND FUNDING STATE
HIGHWAY. PROJECTS. OKAY THANK
YOU THAT SUMS IT UP PRETTY
SUCCINCTLY- CENTER NEWMAN AND
THEN CENTER CORTESE I'M GOOD
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR SO ON THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE THE IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING. THAT THE- THIS IS
A PAUSE AND NOT A PERMANENT
ABATEMENT SO I GUESS MY THIS IS
MY QUESTION FOR MR WELLS I'M
SURE WE'RE GONNA HEAR PLENTY
ABOUT THIS IN PUBLIC COMMENT-
IT'S ONE THING TO REDUCE BY AS
THE L. A. O. POINTS OUT THE FUEL
COSTS BY A VERY SMALL AMOUNT BUT
IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT NOTED THAT
WE'RE GONNA TRUE THIS SHOP- IN
IN THE FOLLOWING YEAR AS PART OF
THE NORMAL PROCESS SO WHAT'S THE
RATIONALE HERE- PARTICULARLY
WHEN YOU CONSIDER THAT. SB ONE
WHICH WAS IN A VERY
PAINSTAKINGLY. PASS DELIVER THE
STRUCTURE. EVEN IN ITS BEST
WON'T ADDRESS YOU KNOW THE THIRD
THE TOLD OF OUR INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDS. AGAIN I THINK THAT THE
RATIONALE OAKS I'M SORRY SEE
BOTH THE PART IN A FINANCE. THE
RATIONALE IS THAT- YOU KNOW IN
IT THAT THE ADMINISTRATION IS
LOOKING TO HAVE- IT TO TRY TO
IMPACT THE PRICE OF GAS IN- IT
AS BEST AS THEY CAN. AND THIS
WILL ALLOW US TO ADDRESS IT IN
THE IN THE BUDGET YEAR- YOU ARE
RIGHT THAT WOULD- WE ARE
PROPOSING THAT IT COULD BE TRUE
IT UP. IN THE TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR YEAR SO THIS IS ONLY
A ONE YEAR- ONE YOUR IMPACT. BUT
BUT YEAH THIS IS. THIS IS REALLY
ONE OF THE WAYS THAT WE HAVE ANY
DIRECT IMPACT ON THE PRICE OF
GASOLINE. AND AGAIN I'M SURE
WE'LL HEAR MUCH MORE ABOUT THIS
PRETTY GOOD YOU KNOW I WOULD
POINT OUT THAT IT'S SORT OF.
INTERNAL CONSUMER PSYCHOLOGY
THAT THEY MOST CONSUMERS
PROBABLY WON'T SEE THE BENEFITS
THEY WOULD CERTAINLY FEEL THE
PAIN- IN IN TWO YEARS- AND SO I
WOULD SUGGEST THIS IS WORTHY OF.
SOME SECOND THOUGHT. THANK YOU
MEASURE. THANK YOU SENATOR
NEWMAN CENTER COURTESY. THE
THIRTY WILL CHAIR. MAYBE THE
OLEO CAN HELP ME IN TERMS OF-
CLARIFYING HOW. WE HAVE
ASSURANCE THAT THIS WILL
DIRECTLY IMPACT RETAIL GASOLINE
PRICES TO THE CONSUMER. I'M
SORRY M. MR- CHRISTINE I'VE BEEN
TOLD THAT YOU NEED TO BE ON
CAMERA WHEN YOU SPEAK SO WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO. HOPEFULLY
WE'LL GET A GOOD CONNECTION THIS
TIME THANK YOU GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR SORRY
ABOUT THAT I SENATOR CORTESE
THERE IS NO THERE IS NO
GUARANTEE AND STRUCTURING- S.
YES STATUTES TO TRY TO ENSURE A
GUARANTEE IN THAT REGARD AS FAR
AS THAT YOU CONSUMER IMPACT
WOULD BE PROBABLY IMPRACTICAL-
BUT OUR ANALYSIS DID CONCLUDE
THAT- THIS SUBSTANTIAL MAJORITY
OF. OF THE- TAX REDUCTION LIKELY
WOULD BE PASSED THROUGH TO
RETAIL PRICES ARE BASED ON- SORT
OF OUR REVIEW OF THE EVIDENCE
REGARDING THE EFFECTS OF PAST-
SHE'LL TEXT CHANGES IT WAS NOT
PASSED THROUGH. RECEIVES THE
BENEFIT OF. WELL THEN THEM BE-
BUSINESS OWNERS AND WORKERS
INVOLVED IN THE- FUEL SUPPLY
CHAIN. REYES WHO THE FOSSIL FUEL
INDUSTRY YOU WILL. IS SENSUALLY
RECOUP THE BENEFIT OF ANYTHING
THAT DOESN'T END UP AT THE
RETAIL PUMP IS ANOTHER WOULD HE
SAID. YES OKAY. IN HIS. GIVEN
GIVEN THAT WE HAVE NO PRACTICAL
WAY TO CONTROL RETAIL PUMP
PRICES EVEN FROM. DISPENSER TO
DISPENSER STATION TO STATION-
ISN'T THERE SOME CURL CLEAR
THAT. IF YOU'RE WRONG ABOUT
WHERE THE MAJORITY OF IT GOES.
THAT THE BACKLASH ON THIS
PROPOSAL IS THAT WE JUST CUT A
DEAL WITH A POSSIBLE INDUSTRY TO
. BENEFIT THEM BUT IT ISN'T
THERE SOME POTENTIAL BACKLASH
HERE THAT THE GENERAL PUBLIC
SAYS MY GAS PRICES WENT UP. OVER
THE PAST YEAR NOT DOWN. THANKS
FOR THE QUESTION SENATOR ASKED
CERTAINLY- THERE'S UNCERTAINTY
IN THE IN THE OUTCOME MOST MOST
STAFF POLICY ACTIONS AND SENATE
IT'S CONCEIVABLE THAT SAD
BUSINESSES AND MANY IN THE
FOSSIL FUEL INDUSTRY WOULD
BENEFIT TO SOME CERTAIN EXTENT
FURNACE- BUT WE DO THINK THAT
THE WEIGHT OF THE EVIDENCE
SUGGESTS THAT CONSUMERS WOULD
DERIVE. MOST OF THE BENEFITS I
RESPECT THEM YOUR PROJECTION ON
THAT I DON'T MEAN TO CELICA
DON'T AND I TOOK- JUST ENOUGH
ECONOMICS AS AN UNDERGRAD IN
SPENT ENOUGH TIME IN BUSINESS
INCLUDING. A ONE POINT IN MY
LIFE POSTING GASOLINE PRICES. AT
A SERVICE STATION SO I KNOW. A
HOW DIFFICULT IT IS TO CONTROL
IT BUT I ALSO UNDERSTAND THE
ECONOMIC PRINCIPLE YOU'RE
PUTTING OUT THERE IS THAT IF YOU
LOWER THE WHOLESALE COST
ESSENTIALLY THROUGH THIS MEASURE
IT SHOULD SHOW UP ON THE RETAIL
SIDE ALL THINGS BEING EQUAL I
JUST DON'T HAVE A STRONG SENSE
OF ASSURANCE THAT WOULD ACTUALLY
HAPPEN IN THIS PARTICULAR
INDUSTRY SO. THANK YOU FOR
ANSWERING THE QUESTION. YEAH I
FIGURED WE COULD CALL ON MISTER
WELLS TO. ADDRESS THIS BECAUSE-
MISTER WELLS YOU DO SAY THAT THE
PURPOSE OF THIS IS TO HAVE AN-
IMPACT ON GAS PRICES AND HAVE AN
IMPACT ON PRICES AT THE PUMP. IF
WE DON'T HAVE. A WAY TO CONTROL
WHERE THAT REDUCTION IN TAXES
WOULD GO. UP AND IT'S JUST OUR-
TOM PREDICTION RIGHT THE-
ESTIMATE IT WOULD GO TO THE TO
THE- THE CONSUMER- WHY WOULD WE-
TAKE THAT- TAKE THAT RISK HOW IS
IT THAT WE COULD SAY IT'S
ACTUALLY GOING TO IMPACT THE
PRICE AT THE PUMP ONE QUESTION
SECOND IS. IF IT IMPACTS IMPACTS
THE PRICE AT THE PUMP PUTS IT
WHAT AMOUNT WILL THE AVERAGE
CONSUMER SAVE PER YEAR. SO THAT
WE COULD THEN A MATCH THAT-
COMPARE THAT TO THE LOSS OF FIVE
HUNDRED OVER FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS. AND AGAIN ALL I
CAN SAY WELL FIRST LOG SAID
THERE'S- ON ON AVERAGE WE DO
ABOUT FIFTEEN BILLION GALLONS OF
GASOLINE- CONSUME PER YEAR SO-
EVERY EACH ANY CHANGE IN THE
PRICE OF GAS IS ABOUT A HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS- IN
GASOLINE TAX REVENUE. SO THE
IMPACT OF NOT INCREASING- THE
PRICE. BY THREE CENTS A GALLON
SPOCK'S NOT WE WHAT ARE THAT
AMOUNT WOULD BE WOULD BE ABOUT
YOU KNOW FORTY FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN GASOLINE AND THEN A
SIMILAR TYPE OF WORK- SIMILAR
TYPE. OF CONSUMPTION ALGORITHM
FOR DIESEL. WHICH IS ABOUT THREE
BILLION GALLONS OF DIESEL PER
YEAR. SO ALL IN ALL THAT'S WHERE
WE GET TO THE FIVE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY BILLION DOLLARS WITH FIVE
HUNDRED TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
APPROXIMATELY. IN REVENUE THAT
GOES ON CASH. I'M SURE. YOU KNOW
WE ARE RELYING ON THE ECONOMIC
PRINCIPLE THAT THE PRICE IS
BASED ON- THE COLLECTION OF
IMPORTS AND THAT THIS REDUCTION
IN THAT INPUT WITHIN RESULTS IN
A REDUCTION IN THE PRICE- THAT
THE PRODUCT IT SOLD FOR- LIKE-
OUR CALL WE GET THE L. A. O.
SAID IT WOULD BE- DIFFICULT AND
BURDENSOME TO STATUTORILY
DETERMINED- THE WAY TO.
GUARANTEE THAT BOTTOM OUT THIS
PRICE THIS PASSED ON- PASSED
ONTO THE CONSUMER BUT
HISTORICALLY- CHANGES IN AND- IF
YOU'LL TAXES HAVE. RESULTED IN
COMMENSURATE CHANGE- TO THE
PRICE AT THE PUMP SO WERE. GOING
BY THE HISTORICAL NORM. OKAY YOU
HAVE A LOT OF FAITH THAT THE
CONSUMER IS GOING TO SEE THE
BENEFIT OF THAT A TAX REDUCTION-
THIRTY MORE. QUESTIONS
COLLEAGUES NO OKAY GREAT THANK
YOU MISTER WELLS AND OTHERS
FREESHEET- WE'RE MOVING ON NOW
TO ISSUE SEVEN WHICH IS THE
SUPPLY CHAIN RESILIENCE ND PORT
INFRASTRUCTURE OF SOMEONE FROM
THE ADMINISTRATION. OR THE
DEPARTMENT. THANK YOU BETTER
CALIFORNIA STATE TRANSPORTATION
AGENCY I'M HAPPY TO PRESENT HIS
PROPOSAL. HELLO SOME SOME OF
THEM ARE CARGO FOURTEEN. ARE TOO
LARGE FOR LEN LONG BEACH RIGHT
THERE FIVE OR OF ALL THE IN THE
STATES APPROXIMATELY 4% OF US
IMPORTS AND 25% OF THE NATION'S
EXPORTS TO THE SAN PEDRO BAY.
PORTS ARE EXPERIENCING MAJOR
DISTRIBUTION CHALLENGES SUCH AS
CONTAINER OVERCROWDING IMPORT
TERMINALS EQUIPMENT SHORTAGES
AND HISTORIC BACKLOG OF CARGO
VESSELS IN ADDITION TRUCK
DRIVERS HAVE FACED UNCERTAINTY
INCLUDING A LACK OF DETAIL CAR
OVER DINNER TICKET SCHEDULES.
SOLEIL'S CANCELLATIONS AND I'M
CLEAR DELIVERY DESTINATIONS
RAILROAD OPERATORS HAVE ALSO
BEEN IMPACTED BY A CERTAIN CARGO
INFORMATION DETAILS. THE SUPPLY
CHAIN PROBLEMS ARE HINDERING
THIS MOVEMENT INCREASING COSTS
FOR CONSUMER AND BUSINESSES I
DON'T NEGATIVELY IMPACTING THE
ENVIRONMENT. TO ADDRESS THE
CHALLENGES THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSES UNPRECEDENTED
INVESTMENTS AT THE STATE LEVEL
TO LEVERAGE AVAILABLE FEDERAL
FUNDING THROUGH THE
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT JOBS
AFTER SUPPORT CALIFORNIA SUPPLY
CHAIN PORTAL FOR STRUCTURE.
INFRASTRUCTURE RESIDENT JOBS ACT
MAKES SEVENTEEN BILLION DOLLARS
AVAILABLE FOR PORTS AND
WATERWAYS AND FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS AVAILABLE. AVAILABLE FOR
FREE RAIL. THE REQUESTED ONE
TIME JENNA FUND INVESTS OF ONE
TWO BILL DOLLARS TO LEVERAGE OUT
FUND TO UPGRADE OUR SUPPLIES
INTEREST. TO SUPPORT OF FISH
SYSTEM. AND RESILIENT MOVEMENTS
. READY GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
. CONSIDERS OF ARM IMPACTS
COMMUNITY. MOORE SAYS. THE
REQUESTED FUNDING BE USED TO
HIGH PRIORITY FOR PROJECTS THAT
INCREASES MOVEMENT CAPACITY ON
RAILROADWASTE CERTAIN PORTION
IMPORTANT MINERALS INCLUDING
RAILYARD EXPANSIONS NEW BRIDGES
AND ZERO EMISSION MODERNIZATION
PROJECTS. FUNDING WOULD BE
ALLOCATED BY THE TRANSPORTATION
AGENCY WITH 70% OF THE FUNDING
GOING TO INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS
SUPPORTING THIS MOVEMENT RELATED
TO THE PORT OF LA AND LONG
BEACH. 30% OTHER HIGH PRIORITY
PROJECTS SUPPORTING PORTION
GOODS MOVEMENT INFRASTRUCTURE IN
THE REST OF THE STATE INCLUDING
INLAND PORTS. WE BELIEVE THIS
ALLEGATION CLOSELY ALIGNS WITH
ACTUAL INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS ARE
REFLECTED ON THE NATURE OF THE
LA AND LONG BEACH PORTS. AND
STATEWIDE ITS MOVEMENT. GEN
AGENCY WILL WORK WITH STATE.
DEVELOP GUIDE FOR LIKE. WELL THE
GUY ARE NOT YET DEVELOPED. WE
INTEND TO PRIOR IN FOR. PROJECTS
THAT ALIGN THE GOOD WHAT THE
GOALS ARE. IN MINUTE CLIMATE
ACTION PLAN TRANSFER TO FOR.
CALIFORNIA MOBILITY. INCLUDING
GREEN AND WE GREENHOUSE GAS AND
TO PROMOTING SOCIAL EQUITY AND
ENHANCE SAFETY. UNPLEASANT
OVERVIEW SUPPLY CHAIN RESILIENCE
IMPORTS FOR STRUCTURE. MY
COLLEAGUES AND I ALSO HAPPY
ANSWER ANY BY YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY JUST QUANTIFY. WE
WILL NOW ANYWAY FROM FIVE COULD
LIKE TO. ATTENTION POLITICS SIGN
. NOTHING CAN WE CAN CURB POINTS
MY BANK COASTLINE FROM
TRANSPORTATION A- THANK YOU- AND
A FROM THE L. A. O. IN MORNING
CHAIR AND JUST EUNICE THE LEDGES
AND OFFICE. AND SO WE HAVE A
COUPLE OF COMMENTS AND ASSESSING
THE PROPOSAL OF THE LEGISLATURE
MAY WANT TO CONSIDER- SEVERAL
ISSUES AND POTENTIALLY MODIFY
THE PROPOSAL SO THAT BEST MEETS
LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES- SO FIRST
THE LEGISLATURE ME ONCE IS JUST
CONSIDERED THE ROLE OF THE STATE
THIS PROPOSAL WOULD REPRESENT A
SIGNIFICANT ONE TIME INCREASE IN
STATE FUNDING FOR GOODS MOVEMENT
INFRASTRUCTURE. THE LEGISLATURE
WANT TO CONSIDER THE STATE'S
ROLE IN SUPPORTING AND
MAINTAINING THESE TYPES OF
ANSWER STRUCTURE- ESPECIALLY
JUST GIVEN THE NUMBER OF OTHER
ENTITIES INVOLVED INCLUDING THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT OR
AUTHORITIES. AND FREIGHT
RAILROAD COMPANIES. AND NEXT A
LEGISLATURE ME ONE TO CONSIDER
WHAT THE PRIMARY GOALS OF THE
FUNDING SHOULD BE. I'M IN
ADDITION TO INCREASING THAT'S
MOVING CAPACITY THIS PROPOSAL IS
INTENDED TO MEET SEVERAL OTHER
GOALS AND ACCORDING TO THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE. INCLUDING
REDUCING GHG EMISSIONS AND
PROMOTING TRANSPORTATION EQUITY.
AND THE LEGISLATURE WANT TO
CONSIDER WHETHER THESE VEHICLES
REFLECTED SURPRISED ALREADY- OR
IF ANY ADDITIONAL CALLS NEED TO
BE ADDED. AND GIVEN THAT-
LIMITED. BERMAN TEACHING DETAILS
AND THE INVESTORS PROVIDED IF
ANY LEGISLATIVE- GUIDANCE IS
NEEDED TO ENSURE FUNDING WILL BE
ALLOCATED BEST. SCHOOLS AND IN
ADDITION THE LEGISLATURE MAY
WANT TO CONSIDER THE TIME FRAME
OF THE PROPOSAL THIS PROPOSAL
MAINLY ADDRESSES LONG TERM
CAPACITY ISSUES AT PORTS. I'M TO
ADDRESS SHORTER TERM ISSUES
RELATED TO PORT CONGESTION- AND-
OTHER TYPES OF ACTIVITIES MIGHT
BE MORE APPROPRIATE BUT YOU KNOW
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER WHETHER
THE STATE ACTION IS NEEDED KIND
OF IN THE SHORT OR LONG TERM
AND- MODIFY THE PROPOSAL
ACCORDINGLY. AND LEGISLATURE MAY
ALSO WANT TO CONSIDER WHETHER
THAT THE PROGRAM THROUGH WHICH
M. OR THE PROGRAM THROUGH WHICH
TO PROTEST ENDING WILL BE
ALLOCATED. TO THE FUNDING IS
CURRENTLY PROPOSED TO BE
ALLOCATED DURING NEW PROGRAM
UNDER CAL STAT. BY OTHER
EXISTING PROGRAMS DO YOU FIND
SIMILAR PROJECTS AND COULD BE
USED ALLOCATE THE PURPOSE
FUNDING FOR PORT RELATED
INFRASTRUCTURE. THE LEGISLATURE
WILL WANT TO CONSIDER THE MERITS
AND TRADE OFFS OF- PROVIDING
FUNDING FOR A NEW OR EXISTING
PROGRAMS. FOR EXAMPLE OF
PROVIDING FUNDING DURING
EXISTING PROGRAM MIGHT LEAD TO
FASTER IMPLEMENTATION EVEN S.
EXISTING GUIDELINES WILL HAVE TO
BE MODIFIED. ALTERNATIVELY A NEW
PROGRAM MIGHT JUST BE NEEDED IF
THE INTENDED GOALS AND TYPES OF
PROJECTS PRIORITIZE DIFFER
SIGNIFICANTLY. WITH THE EXISTING
PROGRAM. THANKS THE LEGISLATURE
MAIL WANT TO BECAUSE THE-
DISTRIBUTION OF THE FUNDING AS
PROPOSED 70% OF THE FUNDING IS
DEDICATED TO THE PROJECTS OF. IN
AT THE PORTS OF LOS ANGELES AND
LONG BEACH BECAUSE- THE MAJORITY
OF THE GOODS MOVEMENT OCCURS IN
THIS REGION- COVER THEM
LEGISLATURE MAY ALSO WANT TO
CONSIDER THE NEEDS OF PORT
INFRASTRUCTURE. STATEWIDE TO
ENSURE THAT NEEDS OF SMALLER
INLAND PORTS ARE MET WITH THE
AVAILABLE FUNDING. AND THE
LEGISLATURE CAN CONSIDER
REQUESTING CAL TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL RATIONALE BEHIND THE
PROPOSED FUNDING SPLIT. AND
PARTICULARLY HOW IT ALIGNS WITH
THE INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS ACROSS
REGIONS. AND IN ADDITION THE
LEGISLATURE MIGHT WANT TO DEFER
ACTION ON THIS PROPOSAL UNTIL
LATER IN THE SPRING TO SEE IF
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION ON
ANTICIPATED FEDERAL FUNDS ARE
AVAILABLE. THEN ANY ADDITIONAL
STATE FUNDING COULD BE BETTER
TARGETED TO FILL ANY FUNDING
GAPS PROVIDE ANY NECESSARY STATE
BATCHING FUNDS TO MAXIMIZE
FEDERAL FUNDED INSURANCE FUNDING
IS DISTRIBUTED ACROSS. PROJECTS
OF DIFFERENT TYPES AT ALL COURTS
STATEWIDE IN A MANNER CONSISTENT. WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES. I AND FINALLY
LEGISLATURE ME ON CONSIDER. THE
TO. ON FUNDING OUTCOMES AND ON
GOING NEEDS OF THE GOODS WITH
THE INFRASTRUCTURE. ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION WOULD HELP THE
LEGISLATURE- ANY ADDITIONAL
STATE FUNDING FOR THESE
ACTIVITIES IS NEEDED IN THE
FUTURE. AND THAT CONCLUDES OUR
COMMENTS THANK YOU MEASURE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- IT JUST
WITH REGARDS TO OF THE L. A.
O.'S OFFICE COMMENTS- I DO I DO
WANT TO COP A COMPLIMENT TO
COMMEND THE ADMINISTRATION FOR-
TALKING AND PROPOSING- OF GOODS
MOVEMENT WORKFORCE TRAINING
CAMPUS IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA I
THINK THAT'S- A GREAT STEP TO GO
FORWARD WITH- BUT IT DOES RAISE
IT WELL I WOULD SAY BUT IT
RAISES THE ISSUE OF WHAT WE CAN
DO SHORT TERM- I UNDERSTAND THE
DRIVER'S LICENSES. OF PROPOSAL
MIGHT TRY TO ADDRESS THAT BUT-
IT I DON'T SEE HOW THAT ALONE IS
GOING TO ADDRESS THE SHORT TERM
NEEDS THAT WE HAVE SO IF
SOMEONE- COULD ADDRESS THAT
PLEASE- HOW DO WE DEAL WITH THE
SHORT TERM ISSUES. THAT HAVE
WE'VE ENCOUNTERED. I AM. AND I
SEE A SENIOR ADVISER CALIFORNIA
STATE TRANSPORTATION AGENCY SO
I'M JUST POINT OUT BACK IN
OCTOBER GOVERNOR NEWSOM- ISSUED
EXECUTIVE ORDER AND NINETEEN
TWENTY ONE- WHICH DIRECTED STATE
AGENCIES TO. LOOK AT IF I WRITE
SHORT TERM OPERATIONAL THINGS
THEY CAN DO TO ADDRESS SUPPLY
CHAIN AS WELL AS PUTTING FORWARD
A BUDGET PROPOSAL ADDRESS LONG
TERM ISSUES LIKE INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND SINCE THEN THERE HAS BEEN A
SUPPLY CHAIN TASK FORCE LED TO
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE CAL STAR
HAS BEEN A LEADING MEMBER OF
THIS THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE ON MY
BUSINESS ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT GO
BUSINESS ALSO MADE ANOTHER
LEADING MEMBER. AND THE
REVALUATION PUT INTO EFFECT A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT SHORT TERM
OPERATIONAL THINGS WERE- THERE'S
A RIGHT NOW WE'VE RECOVERY
STUFF- BROWN TRUCK WAIT. I'M
SORRY. CONTAINER TRUCKING. FOR
SEALED GOT ARGUMENT. MOVING
MOVING THROUGH THE TODAY. POINTS
THAT WAS A MEASURE CALTRAIN TOOK
WE DON'T WE CAN PASS. FOR
COMMERCIAL DRIVE LICENSE TO DO
B. I ADDRESS SOME OF THE WEREN'T
. ISSUES OR C. AND IN THE END-
IF YOU KNOW WITH THE TRUCKING
FORCE- THERE'S BEEN AN EFFORT TO
MY D. S. TO IDENTIFY STATE LAND
TO BE A- FOR A- BIRD TO BE MADE
AVAILABLE FOR A- CONTAINER YARD
AND- THROUGHOUT. THE STATE OF
THE STATE OF AN SIX ALRIGHT
THROUGH A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
IDEAS. GO CAL STUFF. BEEN KIND
OF WORKING WITH IMPORTS
OPERATIONAL ISSUES WAS ANNOUNCED
IN A FEW AGO ABOUT A U. S. A. R.
SPONSORED CAN. CONTAINER YARD-
THE PORTABLE INTO CHAT. AVENUE
NEXT SO. THIS IS CLEARLY ARE.
PROPOSAL IS INTENDED TO REALLY A
LONG TERM POSITIONS IN THE SOME
CHAIN- DOWN BUT IT'S A- BUT.
STATION WHERE THERE'S A SORT OF
A- START. POINT ON FORMER DEPUTY
SECRETARY JOHN MCCARTY THIS KIND
OF LOVE BROWN LEADING THIS
EFFORT ON THE FEDERAL. SIDE SO
WE'VE BEEN A REGULAR. TO WORK
THROUGH A LOT OF THESE ISSUES
AND SO THAT'S WHAT WE'RE DOING
ON THE ON THE SHORT TERM
OPERATIONAL ASSIGNMENT. OKAY OF. IT JUST DOES ONE MORE OF I
THAT FOR YEARS BOB THERE HAS AN
ISSUE OF- THE PORT TRUCKERS
BENE- MISCLASSIFIED AS
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS AND
THAT'S BEEN A HUGE PROBLEM FOR
SEVERAL YEARS ESPECIALLY WITH
REGARDS TO HOW MUCH THOSE TRUCK
DRIVERS EARN IF THEY ARE HELD
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE UPKEEP AND
ALL THE COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
THE TRUCK- I THINK THAT'S A
REALLY IMPORTANT ISSUE TO TAKE
ON BECAUSE WE'RE ONLY KIDDING
OURSELVES AS WE SAY THAT WE'RE
GONNA DO THESE OTHER THINGS BUT
YET THE DAILY. WELL BEING OF
THOSE TRUCKERS IS NOT COMING UP
AS AN ISSUE THEY REALLY NEED TO
BE CLASSIFIED FOR WHAT THEY ARE
BY LAW WHICH IS EMPLOYEES BOMB
AND SO THEY COULD BE PAID THE
PROPER AMOUNTS HOW CAN YOU BE-
MOTIVATOR INSPIRED TO BECOME A
TRUCK DRIVER IF YOU'RE GOING TO
CARRY ON THE RESPONSIBILITIES OF
AN INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR AND
NOT HAVE THE WAGES THAT YOU NEED
FOR YOUR FAMILY SO- CAN ANYONE
SPEAK. SPEAK TO THAT. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. WE WORK WITH THE
CAL WORK AT ALL FOR CHILDREN
THOSE ISSUES. OKAY I HOPE THAT
MEANS ADDRESS SYSTEM. THOSE
TRUCKERS ARE. WHAT CLASSIFIED AS
THEY SHOULD BE AS EMPLOYEES-
CALL. QUESTION SENATOR. NO
DIFFERENT CIRCUITS FOR YOU LET
ME GO FIRST. OKAY DUMPING- SO I
I'D MY QUESTION- RELATES TO THE
ONE FOR TWO BILLION- ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND THE IN FOR- GOOD TO
AND IN FIRST RUBBER TERM FOR.
THAT AND I'D I'D ASK HIM STOOD
TO WHAT EXTENT IF DOES THAT
INCLUDE- PLAN. WERE FOR ALL-
MIDDLE FIVE THE STATE RIDDLE.
SIR CERTAIN TRY THIS CONGRESS ON
A TO ENSURE LABOR PEACE BUT
OBVIOUSLY HAS DEPENDING ON YOU
DO IT BIG IMPAIR ON THE PORT'S
EXISTING AND FUTURE WORKFORCE-
TO IT LIKE TO HEAR A LITTLE BIT
FROM KALISTO. ON THAT TOPIC. SO
I BELIEVE THAT OPPOSE TRAILER
LANGUAGE. THE FUNDING FOR THIS
WEEK NOT. WELCOME OF THE STRUCK
THAT. THAT AWFUL THERE FULLY
WITH. ON. PRECIADO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THANK OKAY GREAT I
MR HER THINK WERE READ TO MOVE
ON PUBLIC COME. RIGHT SURE. OKAY
OF. SEE IT HERE. SHE. OKAY I
THINK WE GO ON TO MOTOR. H. NEED
THIS FOR I'M I'M WHICH YOU HERE
THIS IS BRAD BRAD WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE A- YEP THANK YOU- PUBLIC
COMMENTS PLEASE PRESSED AND THEN
. I'M SORRY CRITICAL TO LINE
NUMBER WE CAN WHICH WHAT BUT
HOLD ON ONE SEC I'M SORRY. I'M
SORRY WELL BEFORE WE ON- WE ARE
GOING TO HEAR FROM. A WITNESS
HERE IN ROOM. SIR WE WOULD STEP
UP AND I YOURSELF I I'D LIKE TO
ASK EVERY WHO'S GONNA SPEAK TRY
TO IT TO A MINUTE PLEASE AND- IF
YOU COULD JUST TAKE RIGHT IN AND
MAKE THE MOST USE OF YOUR TIME.
BOTH YOURSELF AND ANYONE CALLING
MAN WE WANT TO GET YOUR INPUT
AND THAT'S WHERE WE SET ASIDE A
SPECIAL PUBLIC. COMMENT TIME- GO
AHEAD SIR. CHECK RAZA CAN ASK A
QUICK QUESTION SURE OF THE DRESS
MULTIPLE ISSUES HERE OR JUST IN
ORDER THAT YOU PRESENTED THE
NOTE YES THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION
WE HAVE THREE ISSUES BEFORE US
SO IF YOU WANT TO DRESS ALL
THREE. ISSUE FIVE SIX AND SEVEN
WELL WHATEVER YOU WANT TO SAY
ABOUT ANYONE OF THOSE THREE
ISSUES PLEASE JUMP RIGHT IN
THANK YOU FOR THE DIRECTION
APPRECIATE THAT. A CHAIR
TERRAZZO SENATORS NEWMAN
PARTISAN MY NAME IS MARC WATTS
I'M REPRESENTING TRANSPORTATION
CALIFORNIA AND GENTLY THE
TRANSPORTATION INDUSTRY. WE ARE
HERE TO EXPRESS OUR ENTHUSIASTIC
SUPPORT FOR THE ONCE IN A
LIFETIME OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE A
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT IN
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND WE'RE LOOKING AT THE
GOVERNOR'S. TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE BUDGET PROPOSAL FOR NINE
POINT ONE BILLION DOLLARS. IN
THE BUDGET ACT- IN WORKING WITH
THE STATE WE KNOW THAT THE
TRANSFER IS STATE AND LOCAL-TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES. WERE
AWARE THAT THERE IS A
SIGNIFICANT STATEWIDE SHORTFALL-
AND IF IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO
NOTE. THAT TRANSPORTATION
REVENUES ARE DOWN AND- THE NEEDS
CONTINUE TO GROW I COULD SHOW
THAT THAN. REVENUES ARE DOWN BUT
IF YOU LOOK BACK OVER TWO YEARS
THE AMOUNT OF TAX REVENUES THAT
WE LOST TO IMPLEMENTATION OF
COVERT- PROTOCOLS HAS OVER A
BILLION SIX SO THAT'S SOMETHING
WE'VE HAD TO SEE. FOR A FILTER
THROUGH OUR SYSTEM. THAT A
COUPLE OF THE POINTS FOR US MOVE
ON TO THE- TAX HOLIDAY.
TRANSPORTATION CAL. AND OUR
ALLIES ARE VERY MUCH OPPOSED
THIS- THIS PER- THE A ONE YEAR
WE TALK AS WELL AS DISK- WE'RE
APPETITE WITH THE- WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CITIZENS AND
MOTORISTS. AND ADDRESSING THE
CHALLENGES OF DEALING WITH THE
INFLATIONARY- HI YOU CAN ECONOMY
THAT WERE. HOWEVER THE NIGHTS WE
THINK WE'RE MISSING THE BOAT BY
TAKING ON THE GAS TAX ITSELF.
FOR EXAMPLE BETWEEN JULY OF
TWENTY. IN JULY OF TWENTY ONE
THE PRICE WENT UP OVER A DOLLAR
AND YET TAKE GAS TAX ONE OF
THREE CENTS SO I THINK FOCUSING
ON THE GAS TAX AS THE WAY THE
STATE CAN DEAL WITH. MOTORISTA
DEALING WITH THE ECONOMY IS
MISPLACED. AND WE WOULD LIKE TO
SUGGEST THAT THERE MAY BE OTHER
WAYS TO ADDRESS. THE PUBLIC'S-
HARDSHIPS IN THIS INFLATIONARY
TIME- THERE ARE A COUPLE OF THE
POINTS I MAKE PUT IN THE- I
INTEREST OF YOU TIME- MILES-
STOP AT THAT POINT YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR OCT. PRECIADO THE WORK. YOU
DO- I THINK THERE'S NO ONE ELSE
HERE. THEN- WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON
TO A PUBLIC COMMENT OF TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER PLEASE IS
EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR. MAX GET ACCESS
CODE IS THREE FIVE THREE ONE TWO
EIGHT THREE UP PLEASE KEEP YOUR
REMARKS TWO WITHIN A MINUTE. NOW
MODERATOR UP PLEASE PROMPT THE
INDIVIDUALS AND LET US KNOW HOW
MANY ARE IN THE QUEUE. CERTAINLY
AGAIN LATE IN DAMAGE ONE AND
THEN ZERO TO MAKE A COMMENT. AND
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE FIFTEEN AND Q.
FIRST GO TO LINE NUMBER TEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. RIGHT THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MICHAEL PIMENTEL-
THE CALIFORNIA TRANSIT
ASSOCIATION I'D LIKE TO. THINK
THAT YOU HAVE ADMINISTRATION
LEGISLATURE CONTAIN TO ELEVATE
INVESTMENT TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THIS YEAR'S
STATE BUDGET THAT I REALLY DO
APPRECIATE MORE FRAMING MADAM
CHAIR THAT IN LIGHT OF THE
PASSAGE OF THE FEDERAL
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL. OPEN WITH
STAND TO BENEFIT FROM TRACKING%
ADDITIONAL BUDGET SURPLUS THE
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
WITH A FOCUS ON TRADE THE GRAIL
AND IT'S WITH THAT THAT CONTACT
THAT ARE BUDGET LETTER CALLED
FOR ADDITIONAL IT MORE FLEXIBLE
FUNDING FOR TRANSIT RAIL CAPITAL
PROJECTS. AND INCREASED FUNDING
FOR ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE THE
NUMBER STRUCTURE NOT WANTING
DOLLAR TRIGGER CORTESE'S COMMENT
BY AND WE ARE SUGGESTING THAT
THE BUDGET BILL INCLUDE CLEAR
LANGUAGE BUT FIND THAT EXISTING
PROJECTS BE ELIGIBLE FOR T. R.
C. P. AS- A MEANS OF A- COSTS IN
. OR I CHALLENGES HE SAID THAT
HE MAY BE THREE BY THE PROJECTS
. TO THE WE CALL FOR YOU ACCESS
FOR PUBLIC TRANSIT PIECE
PROPOSED QUIET AT FTA FUND IN
VERY TO GET WE ARE REQUESTING
FUNDING FOR TRANSIT ON. TO
ADDRESS FUNDING FOR. ALL RIGHTS
TO THREE EMERGENCY FUNDING IS
DEPLETE FINALLY I WOULD LIKE TO
LEARN WITH OF. HEALTH HI IN AB
THAT- THIS STEP CAN REJECTED GAS
TAX. WITH BROKEN TO ISSUE SIX
THANK YOU MUCH. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR CALLING. NEXT WILL TO
LINE NUMBER ONE PLEASE GO. SHARE
DRIVE NUMBERS DEMAND ON BEHALF
OF THE INTERNET LONG SHORT WAR
UNION LOCAL STATE KEEPS 390%
INTENT ONE AT THE END. OF A
COURT ORDER YOU AND LONG BEACH.
WHY EQUITIES AND YOU MAY ARE
COMMENT THE CLUB FIVE YEARS
ABOUT. AND THE GOVERNOR BY HAVE
. PUT WHICH IMPOSED FUNDS FOR
USED. FOR THEIR NINETY FOUR I.
BUT MAKE SURE THAT PUBLIC FIVE I
AM BACK SIX PROTECT WORKERS.
SOME OF THE EXAM WHERE THE FOR
AND THEN WE SHOULD IN THE PAST
CARE TAKES. I GUESS TAX AND THEN
FEDERAL BECAUSE FOR THE- I'M OF
THE STATE I THINK COULD GO THAT
THE- A VERY. FOR CALLING NEXT.
THANK TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MATT
ROBINSON CALLING TODAY ON BEHALF
OF CALTRAIN WHICH WILL SOON
BEGIN OPERATING THE STATE'S
FIRST ELECTRIFIED EVERY COMMUTER
RAIL LINE SPANNING FIFTY ONE
MILES BETWEEN SAN FRANCISCO AND
SAN JOSE CALTRAIN SUPPORT
SIGNIFICANTLY INVESTING IN
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
FROM THE STATE'S PROJECTED
BUDGET SURPLUS. PARTICULARLYFOR
TRANSIT RAIL IN GRADE
SEPARATION- IN LINE WITH
COMMENTS MADE BY SENATOR CORTESE
CALTRAIN HOLDS THE ANY
ADDITIONAL STATE FUNDING WOULD
ALLOW CALTRAIN TO ADDRESS ITS
CAPITAL NEEDS AND COMPLETE THE
CALTRAIN ELECTRIFICATION
PROJECT- IN THE BAY AREA
CALTRAIN ALSO SUPPORTS HIGH
SPEED RAIL AND THE PROPOSED USE
OF BOND FUNDS TO ADVANCE THE
PROJECT IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY
AND FOR THE DISCUSSION. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR CALLING
PRECIADO THANK YOU. NEXT IN LINE
TWENTY EIGHT. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS DUNCAN MCFETRIDGE
REPRESENTING THE METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION AND
MANY OTHER AREAS PARTNER
AGENCIES- ASKING FOR AT LEAST
TEN BILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
GENERAL FUND- IN THE FOLLOWING
MANNER FIVE BILLION PUBLIC
TRANSIT TRANSIT- TWO BILLION FOR
ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION ONE
BILLION FOR. CLIMATE RESILIENCY
IN ADDITION WANT TO ALIGN MY
COMMENTS WITH- HE I. R. C. P-
THAT REFORM IN AND- WOULD LIKE
TO- ALSO OPPOSE. THE PROPOSAL
THE GAS TAX HOLIDAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR CALLING. NEXT NINE
TWENTY NINE. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING- MANAGER MEMBERS
INCREASED- WHAT IS YOUR ATTITUDE
ON BEHALF OF MAYOR LICCARDO IN
THE SAN JOSE CLINIC BY JUST READ
COMMENTS ON ITEM FIVE THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR THE
TRANSIT- HERE'S THE REAL PROGRAM
THE MANAGER YOU WILL LEAD SEE
THE GOVERNOR'S INCLUDING THAT OF
THIS ITEM. HOWEVER WITH RESPECT
REQUEST THE LARGEST CONSIDER
I'VE MADE GLOBAL MUCH ALONG THE
COMMENT THE DIGESTION BY THE
COURT CASE INCLUDING AND ON
JOINED NOW AVAILABLE PRO DOLLARS
MAKING NEEDED ADJUSTMENTS GUY
LIKE TO ENSURE THAT.
TRANSFORMATIONAL IT WILL TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF OUR STATE BUDGET
SPECIFICALLY OF THE- BART HM
PROJECT. LOCATION BAR SIX MILES
FROM AREA THE. DOWNTOWN SAN AND
IN THE CENTRE. BASED WITH US
LADY CARE TO GET THOUSAND PASSED
EACH DAY BEST DRUG. X. PLEASE.
NINE THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. GOOD MORNING MANTRA MEMBERS
UNETHICAL BECAUSE TATTOOS ON
BEHALF OF THE PORT OF OAKLAND WE
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS THEIR
SUPPORT ADDITION NUMBER SEVEN
THE ONE POINT TWO BILLION
DOLLARS THE CHAIN RESILIENCE AND
POOR INFRASTRUCTURE PROPOSAL AND
WE ARE LOOKING FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
AND THE LEGISLATURE IN SHAPING
THE FINAL PACKAGE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR CALLING NEXT. NINE
FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU GOOD MORNING SHARING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS RUNNING THE
HIGHLANDER JERRY CALLING ON
BEHALFOF THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION-
REGARDING ISSUE NUMBER FIVE RCTV
STRONGLY SUPPORTS THE INLAND
EMPIRE COX'S REQUEST FOR TWO
POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS IN
BUDGET FUNDING TO DELIVER
TRANSPORTATIONPROJECTS. TO
DELIVER IMMEDIATE RELIEF
CORRUGATIONS RESIDENT YOU KNOW
THE STATE'S GROWING MOBILITY AND
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS ARE
COMPOUNDED BY CONTINUED-
POPULATION GROWTH AND COARSENING
SUPPLY CHAIN CRISIS IN RECENT
LIKE THE ONE EMPIRE WHICH
CONTINUES TO EXPERIENCE DRAMATIC
POPULATION HAS FROM LA AND
ORANGE COUNTY THE RIVER THANK
THEM ENOUGH COUNTY. PROP SIXTEEN
THEM WE RECEIVE 4% OF THE NAY-
THAT- THAT GOOD TIME TRAVEL FROM
THE PORT TO THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY AND DECENT DECENT ARE-
YOU KNOW OUR CONTACT BY THE OF
UNDER BACKING IN THE REGION. SO
WE WOULD- CREATURES APPRECIATE
THE PORT THAT THE AND EMPIRE
OFFICER HE SUBMITTED THIS LETTER
AND BRIAN ALONG A COPY OF COPY
LETTER AND IT ACROSS THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU FOR
CALLING. NEXT PLEASE. YEAH FROM
LINE TO TWO PLEASE AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING WALLICH AFTER THE ACROSS
TRANSIT THIS THE L. KKK
COMMISSION AND THE GOLDEN GATE
BRIDGE HIGHWAY TRANSPORTATION
DISTRICT WE LIKE TO START BY
LINING ARE WITH THE PROPOSAL
FROM THE- TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION. THAT IN ANOTHER
BUDGET MISHANDLING DOLLARS FOR.
PROJECT IN PARTICULAR. FIVE
BILLION DOLLAR TO GO TO. THE BAR
TOP. AND CAPITAL. STATE FARM AND
THE CHURCH PROGRAM. THANK YOU
TRANSIT MAIN THEY'RE LOOKING A
HUNDRED MILLION. OPERATING
DEFICIT MY COMING YEARS. AS
FEDERALLY FUNDED BY THE
CROWDRISE. AND DIE KOSTEN BUT BY
STILL REMAINS. SO WE STILL NEED
THAT YOU KNOW THAT. THAT I RAMP
AS YOU TRANSIT TO OVER THE NEW
IN. I WAS TRYING TO. WE CURRENCY
DON'T HAVE A AT THAT ONE OTHER
POINT I WANT TO MAKE YOU- THAT
WOULD WORKFORCE ABOUT. YOUR
CREDIT. BETTER TRAINING SCHOOL
YOUR BUS- MECHANICS. READILY ON
THE JOB. YOU TRY WITH ITS
EXPERIENCE YOUR MUCH CRITICAL
TO. ITS OWN CLINICAL. AND
TRAINING PROGRAM- BUT NEED TO
DEVELOP THEIR OWN OF GERM BUT-
UNIVERSITY WHAT CALLING A- SO
FUNNY COULD BE TO MY. INCREASE
THE ALLOCATION TO- TRANSCRIPTION
PROGRAMS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS NEXT PLEASE. IT'LL COME
FROM LINE THIRTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MICHAEL TURNER
REPRESENTING THE L. A. COUNTY
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY AND WE WANT TO THANK
THE GOVERNOR FOR HIS HISTORIC
INVESTMENTS IN PARTICULARLY ZERO
EMISSION TECHNOLOGIES AND
INVESTING IN THE SUPPLY CHAIN
CROSS CRISIS AS THE LEGISLATURE
MOVES FORWARD THAT WE'D LIKE TO
URGE YOU TO CONSIDER- INVESTING
ADDITIONAL SURPLUS FUNDS. IN
TRANSIT IN PARTICULAR L. A.
COUNTY IS UNITED ALL THIRTEEN
BOARD MEMBERS HAVE SIGNED ON TO
THE GOVERNOR THE GOLDEN
OPPORTUNITY RECOMMENDATION WHICH
WE HAVE SUBMITTED TO THE
LEGISLATURE THAT IS ALSO
SUPPORTED BY THE COGS.
REPRESENTING ALMOST EIGHTY EIGHT
CITIES IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY AND
THIS PROPOSAL CALLS FOR A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN FUNDING
FOR TRANSIT WHICH CAN FIND
SHOVEL READY AND SHOVEL READY
PROJECTS LIKE THE WHAT'S IN IT
AND A BRANCH TRANSIT CORRIDOR AS
WELL AS THE FOOTHILL GOLD LINE
EXTENSION WE ALSO URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO ADOPT
SIGNIFICANTLY LARGER FUNDING FOR
THE OLYMPICS. THERE A NUMBER OF
MAJOR EVENTS COMING TO LOS
ANGELES COUNTY OVER THE NEXT FEW
YEARS AND WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO INVEST
SIGNIFICANTLY IN THOSE PROJECTS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR CALLING
SOME MODERATOR NEXT PLEASE. YOU
LINE EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
MATT KREMIN HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA NEVADA CONFERENCE
OF OPERATING ENGINEERS GOOD AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION ISSUE SIX
ON YOUR AGENDA RELATED TO THE
SUSPENSION OF THE ANNUAL
INFLATION ADJUSTMENT OF THE SB
ONE GAS TAX THIS COMMITTEE KNOWS
WELL THIS ANNUAL ADJUSTMENT WAS
INCLUDED IN THE HARD FOUGHT
EFFORTS TO ENACT SB ONE IT WAS
LEFT INTACT TO THE SUBSEQUENT
DEFEAT A PROPOSITION SIX- TO
SPAIN IS ADJUSTMENT WILL RESULT
IN AN ESTIMATED LOSS OFFIVE
HUNDRED TWENTY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN
USED TO SUPPORT DESPERATELY
NEEDED MAINTENANCE
REHABILITATION OF HIGHWAYS.
STREETS AND ROADS ACROSS THE
STATE ALL WHILE PROVIDING LITTLE
RELIEF TO THE TAXPAYERS IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD ALSO RESULT IN
LOST WORK OPPORTUNITIES FOR
MEMBERS AS WELL AS DESPERATELY
NEEDED APPRENTICESHIP
OPPORTUNITIES FOR YOU CAN DO A
CAREER IN ROAD MAINTENANCE AND
REHABILITATION FOR THESE REASONS
AND MANY MORE- WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT YOU REJECT ISSUE
SIX ONE THE TIME IS APPROPRIATE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
FOR CALLING. NOW PLEASE. FIND
TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MY
NAME IS LAURA LANE AND I'M
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION SUPPORT
ORTIZ OR KAPPA WHICH REPRESENT
CALIFORNIA'S ELEVEN PORT TALBOT
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE FUNDING
DISCUSSION ISSUE SEVEN THE ONE
POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS IN
GENERAL FUND SPENDING PROPOSED
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WILL
PROVIDE SOUND INVESTMENT TO
IMPROVE FOR INFRASTRUCTURE AND
ENSURE SUPPLY CHAIN RESILIENCY.
BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND AND TWENTY
TWENTY CONTAINERIZED CARGO
VOLUMES IN CALIFORNIA GREW BY
80% THE CONTENTS GROWTH HAD
SERIOUS IMPLICATIONS ON THE
SUPPLY CHAIN OUR CALIFORNIA
COURTS TO PROACTIVELY TAKEN
STEPS TO ALLEVIATE BY TRAIN
CONGESTION HOWEVER AS WE
CONTINUE AS WE CONTINUE TO MEET
THE NEEDS OF CONSUMERS TODAY AND
IN THE FUTURE ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENT IS NEEDED. BUT
INVESTMENT PROPOSAL OUR PORTS TO
RESPOND TO THE GROWING TRADE
VOLUME IMPROVE THE COURTS
OPERATION AND INCREASE THE
CAPACITY TO MOVE GOOD
EFFICIENTLY ON BEHALF OF KAPPA
THANKS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
EXPRESS OUR STRONG SUPPORT IN
THIS BUDGET WILL BOTH LOCAL AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE
DISCUSSIONS. ON THIS TOPIC THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR CALLING. NEXT
PLEASE. FIND FOURTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I'M SURE MEMBERS ENTERING
INTO HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
PORT OF LOS ANGELES SPECIFICALLY
IN SUPPORT OF- THE GOVERNOR
SUPPLY CHAIN INVESTMENT PACKAGE-
STARTING WITH- OUR AGREEMENT
WITH YOU MADAM CHAIR THAT THE
INVESTMENT OF THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSES FOR ONE HUNDRED TEN
MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE STATE
GENERAL FUND FOR WORKFORCE
TRAINING CAMP WHICH IS A GOOD
IDEA- SOMETHING THAT WE'VE BEEN
WORKING. AT THE PORT NUMBER VERY
LONG IMPORT COMMUNITY ON THIS
WE'VE ALREADY IDENTIFIED A
SIXTEEN ACRE SITE AT CORPORATE-
THIS FOR US ESPECIALLY FOR THIS
PURPOSE WE ALSO SUPPORTED THE
OTHER ELEMENTS OF A STRING OF A
VERY SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS
FROM THE STATE JOURNAL ON. THE
TRANSITION TO ZERO EMISSION WHEN
ANOTHER SUBCOMMITTEE WILL FOCUS
IN ON THAT- ALSO THEIR
INVESTMENTS FROM THE ONE POINT
TWO BILLION DOLLAR PACKAGE WE
BELIEVE WILL HELP BUILD
RESILIENCY. IN THE SUPPLY CHAIN
NETWORK SO THAT WHEN WE FACE
ANOTHER SURGE OF CARAMEL- WILL
BE BETTER ABLE THESE
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS AND
INVESTMENTS FOR OPERATIONAL
IMPROVEMENT- TO- ANTICIPATE THAT
AND MANAGE THAT WHEN IT COMES-
THE SUPPLY CHAIN. SHOULD
DIGITALIZATION INVESTMENT. IS-
ALSO VERY IN. GULBIS WE NEED ALL
OF ALSO ONE OF SURE THE IN DATA
THAT COULD GENERATED THERE
pARE AT THE DOCK. AND SO THAT WE
JUST WANT TO OUR- AND GET ON
RECORD THIS. IN ANY OTHER
SUBCOMMITTEE ARE LOOKING
ELEMENTS OF THIS ENTIRE. TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT. THANK YOU CAN
MEASURE. THANK YOU CALLING. NOW
PLEASE FIND NINE FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBER
OF THE CAN THAT HE THAT WHEN
THIS CALL TODAY A BEHALF OF THE
AT THE GENERAL CONTRACTORS OF
TELL. CALLING THE WILL LINE OUR
COMMON WITH THOSE MAY BY OUR AT
TRANCE CAN IN OUR STRONG. TO
ISSUES BUT THE PROPOSED FOR THE
GAP BACK HOME AND WHEN THE TIME
THE PROBE WOULD ASK YOU TO
REJECT THAT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR. NEXT PLEASE. IT WILL CUT
THE LINE THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
TODD BALLOON SIGN FOR THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION ALSO OPPOSED TO ITEM
NUMBER SIX PRIMARILY BECAUSE IT
BREAKS THE SPIRIT OF SB ONE. WE
ASK THAT YOU WOULD HOLD THIS
ITEM- WHEN IT'S APPROPRIATE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR CALLING
NEXT PLEASE. A LINE NINETEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS CHALLENGING
ABOUT THE AMERICAN COUNCIL OF
ENGINEERING COMPANIES
CALIFORNIA- WE WOULD LIKE TO
ALIGN OUR COMMENTS WITH THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKER FROM
TRANSPORTATION CALIFORNIA ON THE
THREE ITEMS BEFORE YOU AND ALSO
THANK THE GOVERNOR FOR HIS
INVESTMENT INFRASTRUCTURE. WHICH
IS BUDGET- SPECIFIC ISSUE SIX
WELL AS YOU TO CALIFORNIA'S VERY
CONCERNED WITH THE GOVERNOR AND
GAS TAX HOLIDAY PROPOSAL. THE
PRIMARY REASON WHY SB ONE WAS
PASSED IN THE FIRST PLACE WAS TO
RESTORE THE PURCHASING POWER OF
THE STATE'S HEALTH TAX REVENUES-
THE HEAD ON THE ROAD THE OVER
THE FIRE DECADES- TRANSMISSION
REVENUES DOWN ONE POINT SIX
BILLION DOLLARS. TO COVER
NINETEEN ANOTHER FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR DECREASE IS NOT
WHAT OUR AGING OBSTRUCTION THE-
KNOW REALLY IS A GOOD SIGNAL TO
THE FEDS WHEN YOU'RE SAYING
BILLION DOLLARS COMING THE STATE
UNDER AYE AYE J. AND THEN DECIDE
TO FORGO OUR OWN DEDICATED I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR CALLING MAN. NEXT
BY MODERATING HOW MANY. OUR
REMAINING WITNESSES. CERTAINLY
THREE. THANK YOU PLEASE NEXT.
NUMBER THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS JIM LIGHTS ON BEHALF
OF THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA
RAPID TRANSIT DISTRICT WE
CERTAINLY ASSOCIATE OUR COMMENTS
WITH THOSE OF THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSIT ASSOCIATION AS WELL AS
THE METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION. URGING CONSIDERATION
OF THE BROADER TEN BILLION
DOLLAR INFRASTRUCTURE PACKAGE
FOR TRANSPORTATION SPECIFICALLY
WE'D LIKE TO NOTE THAT PARK FEEL
STRONGLY THAT TRANSIT AGENCIES
AS WELL SHOULD HAVE GREATER
ACCESS TO CLIMATE ADAPTATION
FUNDS. AS WELL AS CONSIDERATION
OF FUNDING FOR OPERATING
EXPENSES PART TWO HAS RIDERSHIP
VOLUMES THAT ARE SIGNIFICANTLY
BELOW PRE COLD IT LEVELS AND
LASTLY WOULD LIKE TO NOTE THAT
THE WITH ACT LIKE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE STRONGLY CONSIDER
ADDING TRANSIT AGENCIES TO
ACCESS FOR HOMELESS ASSISTANCE
FUND. WITH THAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM CHAIR PRECIADO. GREAT
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS NEXT
PLEASE. I'M THIRTY NINE YEAR
OPEN. JERRY MEMBERS SOLO ON THE
HALF OF THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY
AREA WATER EMERGENCY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY OR THE
LARGEST PUBLIC TRANSIT WATER
FERRY SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA WE
COVER THE ENTIRE BAY AREA
REGION- ALIGN OURSELVES WITH
WHAT THE COMMENTS- CALIFORNIA
TRANSIT ASSOCIATION INVOLVED THE
METROPOLITAN. TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION WERE- FOCUSED ON THE
MAX AMOUNT OF FUNDING POSSIBLE
FOR. PUBLIC TRANSIT AGENCIES IN
THE STATE AN ADDITIONAL ONE OF
THE HIGHLIGHTS THAT WE ARE NOW.
ABOUT TO BE UNDER- CARD- MANDATE
THE TRANSITION AND ZERO EMISSION
FERRIES THAT GOING TO COST
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
FOR THE FERRY THEMSELVES ALL THE
SHORE SIDE CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE. ONE EXAMPLE IS
OUR NEED FOR THIRTY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE MISSION
BAY FERRY TERMINAL IN FRONT OF
THE NEW WARRIOR STADIUM WILL
WHICH WILL HELP LINK UP- ALL OF
BAY. AREA COMMUNITIES TO A NEW.
A JOB. THERE AND THEN THE THEY
NAY- SO APPRECIATE YOUR- LOOKING
AT THE MAX AMOUNT OF FUNDING IT
FOR TRANS INTEREST PROGRAM AS
WELL TREND IS TO GENERAL AND-
VEHICLE THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU CALLING UP PLEASE. THANK YOU
AND WE'RE GOING TO NUMBER SIX
WE'VE GOT. GOOD MORNING CHARTER
ALSO NUMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THIS IS CRITICALLY ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
OF COUNTIES CALLING REGARDING
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE. WE'RE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE GENERAL FUND
VESTMENTS PROPOSED IN
TRANSPORTATION SPECIALLY ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION. CLIMATE
ADAPTATION AND HIGHWAY SAFETY
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM ON THAT
THIRD PROGRAM IT'S A LITTLE BIT
OF A SLEEPER PROGRAM BUT IT
FINDS VERY IMPORTANT SYSTEMATIC
SAFETY IMPROVEMENTS. IN THE LAST
ROUND OF GRANTS UNDER THIS
PROGRAM THERE WERE OVER TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
UNFUNDED BELOW THE LINE IT
GRANTS. REPRESENTING A HUNDRED
FIFTY PROJECTS ACROSS THE STATE
SO WE ENCOURAGE YOU TO CONTINUE
TO INVEST IN THAT PROGRAM AND TO
CONSIDER EVEN GREATER INVESTMENT
SPECIALLY AS WE'VE SEEN LEVEL
THE FINALITY THE COLLISIONS
INCREASE DURING THE PANDEMIC
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT PLEASE. NO FURTHER COMMENT
AT THIS TIME. OKAY GREAT WE WILL
THEN- FOR NOW FOR THESE ISSUES
WERE ENDING PUBLIC COMMENT WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO THE REST OF
THE DISCUSSION- ISSUES AND THAT
IS FROM EIGHT ISSUE EIGHT
THROUGH ISSUE TWENTY TWO. WE'LL
START WITH THE ISSUE EIGHT AND-
WITH OKAY. HEY OKAY- ISSUE EIGHT
IS THE OPERATIONAL NEEDS. THE
MANAGER WAS ONE AGAIN
TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES
PUBLISHERS AND ITS LOCAL. WHAT
IS THE PROBLEM THE REQUESTED
POSITION IN ACROSS ONE TWO. I'M
GOING TO ESTABLISH AGENCY LEVEL
POLICY ASSIGNED BUDGET FOR
TRANSFER RESEARCH PROJECTS AND
SUPPORT INCREASE RENT COSTS I
WILL BRIEFLY GO REACH COMPONENT
OF OUR PROPOSAL BEGINNING WITH
THE REQUEST ESTABLISH AGENCY
LEVEL FREE POLICY TEAM. AS YOU
LEVEL RESOURCES TO- OVERSEEING
FOR POLICY PROCESS. EXISTING
STRUCTURE OF FREE FALL OVER SO
IS FRACKING. AND INCLUDES STATE
INCLUDING. BUILDERS AND- AIR
RESOURCES BOARD EACH WITH
DIFFERENT RESPONSIBILITIES
RELATED DIFFERENT POLICY
OVERSIGHT. UNDER THE CURRENT
STRUCTURE THE STATE IS NOT
HAVING OVERSIGHT AGENCY
COORDINATED COMPREHENSIVE
RESPONSE TO ADDRESS EMERGING
TRADE INDUSTRY ISSUES. THE
PROPOSAL ESTABLISH A FREE POLICY
TEAM TO SHOULD. LEAVING MINISTRY
POLICY DEVELOPMENT TO SUPPORT
THE ECONOMIC. IS TO
SUSTAINABILITY OF CALIFORNIA'S
MULTI MODAL FREIGHT SECTOR.
RESOURCES WILL PLAY A CRITICAL
ROLE IN WORKING STAKEHOLDERS IN
THE LOCAL STATE FEDERAL AND
PRIVATE SECTORS TO ADDRESS
URGENT AND EMERGING ISSUES
AFFECTING CALIFORNIA'S. FREIGHT
SECTOR AND SUPPLY CHAIN. THE
NEXT OF THIS INCLUDES A REQUEST
TO ESTABLISH AN ANNUAL. RESEARCH
BY OF FIVE DOLLARS. PER
CALCIFICATION TYPEWRITER
TRANSFER WHICH PROJECT.
TRANSPORTATION RESEARCH IS
CRITICAL TO INFORM. POLICY AND
WE DON'T HAVE A CURRENT WE DON'T
CURRENTLY HAVE A BUDGET FOR
RESEARCH. WE THE LATTER PART TO
CONTRIBUTE FUNDING TO CONDUCT
AGENCY LED RESEARCH PROJECTS.
LIMITED FUNDING AVAILABLE CAN
POSE CHALLENGES TO FULLY FUNDING
RESEARCH PROJECTS IN A TIMELY
MANNER. THIS FUNDING IS
NECESSARY TO PROVIDE POSSIBLE
READILY AVAILABLE RESOURCES TO
CONDUCT RESEARCH NECESSARY. TO
MEDIATORS AND EMERGING ISSUES
AFFECTING THE SUPPLY CHAIN
FULFILL LEGISLATIVE REQUIREMENTS
AND SUPPORT ADMINISTRATIONS
PRIORITIES. FILE UNDER THIS
PROPOSAL INCLUDES A REQUEST FOR
ONE HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND
ANNUALLY DESIGN INCREASE
RECKLESS ASSOCIATED WITH
CONSTANT RELOCATION THE JUST
GENERAL BUILDING. IN ORDER TO
DEPART OF GENERAL SIR TO GO
SHOOTING LEAST FOR SPOT SPACE.
CURRENTLY WE ACT AS A MOVING
INTO OUR NEW OFFICE SPACE BY
JUNE OF THIS YEAR. I JUST SIGNED
MY COLLEAGUES ARE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS RELATING
THIS PROPOSAL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- TO HAVE SOMEONE FROM
FINANCE PLEASE. THANKS POLITICS
PERMANENT FINANCE SO WE SUPPORT
THE PROPOSAL AS REVIEWED BY
CARLOS. OKAY. WE HAVE- ANY
COMMENTS FROM THE ELIO. IN THIS
ROW WITH THE L. A. NOW WE HAVE
NO CONCERN FOR THIS PROPOSAL.
OKAY COLLEAGUES ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. NINETY OKAY I JUST
WANT IF YOU COULD JUST TAKE
ANOTHER MINUTE TO EXPLAIN WHY A
YOU NEED YOUR OWN THE DEPARTMENT
NEEDS ITS OWN RESEARCH BOTH
BUDGET AS OPPOSED TO THE WAY
IT'S CURRENTLY DONE. THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION THAT ENSURES SO
TYPICALLY DON'T WE DON'T HAVE
OUR OWN RESEARCH BUDGET SO AT
THE MOMENT WE NEED TO REQUEST
FUNDING FROM OTHER DEPARTMENTS
ARMS TO FUNDED EDUCATION
STUDIES. THERE'S CURRENTLY
TRANSPORTATION RESEARCH FUNDING
AVAILABLE TO RESCUE ONE- WHICH
IS REALLY WE HAVE TO COMPETE FOR
NOT FINDING SERVICE THE
SECRETARY PICK WE WILL SEND TO
RESEARCH PRIORITY- TO COMPETE
OTHER RESEARCH PRIORITIES AND
TRANSPORTATION. FOR INSPIRATION
AND OFTENTIMES OUR PRIORITIES
ARE NOT SELECTED FOR RESEARCH-
SERVICE FUNDING IS REALLY
INSUFFICIENT IT NEEDS ARE URGENT
AND SHORT TERM RESEARCH NEEDS AS
A PROCESS FOR ACCESSING THESE IS
REALLY TIME SENSITIVE AND THE
FUNDING ISN'T READILY AVAILABLE
SO HAVING OUR OWN RESEARCH
BUDGET WOULD ALLOW HOUSE THAT
ENSURE. WE RETAIN CONTROL OVER
THE STUDIES WE NEED TO HOLD THE
LOS REQUIRE SO EVEN. FOR GREAT
THANK YOU MUCH. OKAY BUT WE HAVE
NO. COMMENTS ARE QUESTION. WILL
MOVE ON TO. ISSUE NINE WHICH IS
IN. OF AS B. THREE NINE. MORNING
JOURNAL MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
I'M STEVEN TACT THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF FINANCE AT
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
TRANSPORTATION- BEFORE I BEGIN
WITH THIS PROPOSAL I'D LIKE TO
CONVEY THE APOLOGIES ARE
DIRECTOR TOOK SO MUCH SHOCKING
WHO'S NOT ABLE TO. APPEAR BEFORE
YOU TODAY AS I'M SURE YOU'RE
AWARE HE WAS RECENTLY APPOINTED
TO THE SECRETARY POSITION AT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE TRANSPORTATION
AGENCY IS VERY MUCH INVOLVED IN
THE TRANSITION WITH WITH THAT
NEW ROLE- SO THE THIS PC P.
FIRST UP HERE IS A REQUEST FOR
SIX MILLION DOLLARS OVER TWO
YEARS- TO CONDUCT A ROAD CHARGE
REVENUE COLLECTION PILOT. A
CONSISTENT WITH ENACTMENT OF
SENATE BILL THREE THIRTY NINE.
AT ARMINA MOTOR VEHICLES IS ALSO
REQUEST. A AND SEVENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND ONE TWO YEAR LIMITED
TERM POSITION FOR THEIR ROLE IN
THIS PILOT. THE REQUEST ALSO
INCLUDES A TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLAR ONE TIME AUGMENTATION FOR
THE C. T. C. FOR- FOR OPERATING
EXPENSES. SENATE BILL THREE
THIRTY NINE SIX TO CONTINUE THE
STATE'S EXPLORATION INTO A ROAD
CHARGE C. AS A REPLACEMENT FOR
THE GAS TAX- IT IN THE BILL
REQUIRES US TO- THE PILOT TO
DIFFERENT MILEAGE RATE OPTIONS.
ARE AND TO COLLECT ACTUAL
REVENUE AS PART OF THIS PILOT.
OF THE BUDGET WILL REQUEST WILL
ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT TO CONDUCT
THE REQUIRED PILOT UNDER THE
GUIDANCE OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY. OKAY
THANK YOU MISTER CHECK ON ANY
COMMENTS FROM THE L. A. U. WHAT
A MANAGER- FRIEDMAN HAS WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE- WE
HAVE NO COMMENT OR STANDS ON
THIS PROPOSAL THANK YOU. OKAY OF
COLLEAGUES ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. SIR NEWMAN. THANK YOU
MEASURE IT- QUESTION FOR MR
CHARACTER. MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT BAD BEFORE SB THREE THIRTY
NINE THE COMMISSION SHALL THEY
TEACH YOU SEE THAT IS IDENTIFIED
COSTS. FOR ONE POSITION AND THEN
FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
BUDGET FOR CONSULTING BECAUSE MY
VISION IS A BUNCH OF DATA THE
THAT NEEDS TO BE PURCHASED TO DO
THIS. STUDY PROBABLY. DONT BUT
YOUR BUDGET ONLY BECAUSE TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS- SO
WHAT'S THE THINKING BEHIND THAT
AND WHAT IMPACT MIGHT THIS HAVE
ON. THE IMPLEMENTATION OF. THE
PROGRAM WHICH I CONSIDER VERY
IMPORTANT. CENTER NEWMAN THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION AND THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR SUPPORT
OF THE OF THE PILOT- TO BE TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLAR REQUEST
IS BASED ON OUR HISTORICAL.
KNOWLEDGE IN DEALING WITH THE
ROAD CHARGE PILOT IN THE- THE
PREVIOUS BUDGET THAT THE
DEPARTMENT HAD CONDUCTED UNDER
SB TEN SEVENTY SEVEN A FEW YEARS
AGO- YEAH I MEAN THAT'S
BASICALLY IT IT'S BASED ON OUR
HISTORICAL- HISTORICAL
INFORMATION THAT WE HAVE ON THE
ACTUAL NEEDS ANY DATA COLLECTION
NEEDS IT WOULD BE REQUIRED
STITCHES THAT YOU HAD MENTIONED
THERE WOULD BE DONE BY THE
DEPARTMENT IN SUPPORT. OF THE
ISLAND. AND SO I'M CLOSER TO
THOSE COSTS. WOULD BE BORNE BY
THE TO DEPARTMENT- IN DOING THAT
DATA COLLECTIONS ARE CORRECT.
THAT'S CORRECT THANK YOU. WITH
GREATER SENATE QUARTERS ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS. NO OKAY ALL
RIGHT BOB THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
WE'RE DONE WITH ISSUE NINE FOUR
MOVING ON TO ISSUE TEN WHICH IS
ADVANTAGE MANAGEMENT SYSTEM
AUGMENTATION- DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION. THANK YOU
AGAINST EVEN CHECK WITH WITH
CALTRANS SO THIS REQUEST IS A- A
ONE TIME AUGMENTATION OF EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS TO UPGRADE THE
DEPARTMENT'S FINANCIAL
MANAGEMENT INFORMATION SYSTEM.
TO A NEW VERSION IS SUPPORTED BY
THE SOFTWARE VENDOR. APPROVAL OF
THIS REQUEST WILL ALOW US TO
UPGRADE OUR FINANCIAL MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM TO PROVIDE A STABLE AND
FUNCTIONAL OUR SYSTEM THAT IS
SECURE AND MEETS THE NEEDS OF
THE DEPARTMENT- WE ARE
TRANSITIONING TO HIS CAL OVER
THE COMING YEARS- BUT TO DO SO
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
CURRENT SYSTEM MAINTAINS ITS
STABILITY- AND BECAUSE THIS IS A
SYSTEM THAT. WE PROCESS- TWENTY
SIX THOUSAND ACTIVE PROJECTS
RIGHT NOW- WE COLLECT- MILLIONS
OF REVENUE AND- AND- TIMELY PAY
I'M- IN. A YEAR OVERSTAY BILLION
AND- ON. OKAY VERY IMPORTANT
SYSTEM THAT WE TO MAKE SURE IS
UP AND RUNNING AND SECURE- WHILE
WE TRANSITION TO FISCAL. OKAY OF
WOOD FINANCES LIKE TO COMMENT.
AMES MORE WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE JUST SO THAT WE CAN
CURRENT THE PROPOSAL. OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF A WITH THE L.
A- LIKE TO COMMENT. RECOMMEND IS
AGAIN WHAT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE I HAVE NO
COMMENT CONCERNS ON THE SCHOOL.
OKAY GREAT THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH DONE WITH ISSUED TEN.
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO. ISSUE
ELEVEN WHICH IS I. T. PROPOSALS. YOUR AND YOUR IN SENATORS
AGAINST EVEN CHARACTER CALTRAIN
- THERE ARE ARE BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSALS INCLUDED UNDER THIS
AGENDA ITEM- I WILL TRY TO
BRIEFLY EXPLAIN EACH OF THEM.
THE FIRST IS A FIVE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLAR ONE
TIME REQUEST TO COMPLETE THE
PROJECT APPROVAL LIFECYCLE STAGE
THREE FOR OUR ENTERPRISE DATA
GOVERNANCE TECHNOLOGY SOLUTION
PROJECT. THIS IS A PROJECT THAT
WILL EVENTUALLY PROCURE AND
IMPLEMENT A SUITE OF ENTERPRISE
DATA GOVERNANCE RELATED TOOLS
FOR US TO BE ABLE TO- STEWARD
AND MANAGE OUR DATA AND A BETTER
WAY THAN WE ARE CURRENTLY. THE
SECOND RECALL WHAT SOUNDS IN BUT
IS DIFFERENT IT IS AN ENTERPRISE
DATA STORAGE SOLUTION FOR THE
DEPARTMENT. OF AN AND THIS
PROPOSAL REQUESTING SEVENTEEN
POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE AND
FIFTEEN POINT EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS IN TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR. FOUR EQUIPMENT SOFTWARE
AND CONSULTING SERVICES AND THEN
ONGOING RESOURCES FOR SIX
POSITIONS TO MANAGE A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF DATA- THAT THE
DEPARTMENT COLLECTS AND ALSO TO
ENSURE THAT THAT DATA IS
SECURELY- YOU CAN WE MAINTAIN-
THE THIRD. IS EIGHTY SIX POINT
EIGHT MILLION DOLLAR REQUEST AND
CONDITIONS FOR THE NEXT PHASE OF
THE STATE HIGHWAY- SORRY THE-
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM NETWORK
REPLACEMENT PROJECT THIS IS A-
DATA STORAGE SYSTEM- SORRY THIS
IS A ANY. STORAGE SYSTEM FOR A
DATA RELATED TO THE STATE
TRANSPORTATION NETWORK INCLUDING
OF BOOKS STATE AND LOCAL ASSETS
THIS IS A FEDERAL REQUIREMENT
AND MANDATES- REQUIRED THAT WE
HAVETHE SAFETY DATA SYSTEM TO
PERFORM ADVANCED ANALYSIS I DO
SUPPORT OUR STRATEGIC HIGHWAY
SAFETY PAN AND THE HIGHWAY
SAFETY IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM. AND
FINALLY THE FORCE PROPOSAL. THE
REQUESTED PAGE POINTS TO FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE AND
EIGHT POINT NINE MILLION DOLLARS
IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY THREE
POINT FOUR. AND FOUR POINT FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING AFTER
THAT IN TWENTY THREE A PERMANENT
POSITION. THESE RESOURCES ARE TO
SECURE THE TRANSPORTATION
OPERATION SYSTEM NETWORK AGAINST
CYBER ATTACKS. THIS IS A-
AFFORDABLE SYSTEM AND CALTRANS
HAS MORE THAN TWENTY THOUSAND
OPERATIONAL TECHNOLOGY ELEMENTS
OUT IN THE FIELD- IT'S PART OF
THE CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
WE USED TO MAINTAIN AND OPERATE
OUR SYSTEM. THE REQUEST TO
SECURE THAT SYSTEM IS IN
ALIGNMENT WITH THE NEW THE
REQUIRED CYBER RESPONSE
ACTIVITIES- BASED ON- EXPANDING
TECHNOLOGY THAT CYBERSECURITY
GUIDANCE AND IS ALSO CONSISTENT
WITH PRESIDENT BIDEN'S MAY OF
TWENTY ONE EXECUTIVE ORDER-
INVOLVING NATION'S
CYBERSECURITY. I RECOGNIZE
THAT'S A LOT OF A LOT OF DETAIL
THERE BUT ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
ON THOSE REQUESTS. WELL I UP
VERY MUCH YOUR OF PRESENTATION
OBVIOUSLY IT'S IMPORTANT TO ALL
OF US AND ESPECIALLY WITH THE
SECURITY MEASURES THAT- WILL BE
IN. IN PLACE OF. ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS SENATORS. OKAY THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
TECH WILL MOVE ON TO ISSUE
TWELVE. WHICH IS FLEET
REPLACEMENT. THANK YOU SENATOR
AGAINST EVEN CHECK WITH WITH
CALTRANS THIS IS A REQUEST FOR A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY THREE
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY FOR TWO
YEARS- IN STATE HIGHWAY ACCOUNT
RESOURCES TO BEGIN REPLACEMENT
OF THE AGING CALTRANS FLEET INTO
INSTALL ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND FAST FUELING
INFRASTRUCTURE STATEWIDE TO
MEET- STATE MANDATES AND
REGULATIONS. THE PROPOSAL
ADDRESSES THE FIRST TWO YEARS OF
A LONGER RANGE CALTRANS PLAN TO
REPLACE OUR AGING FLEET- WE WILL
CONCENTRATE ON REPLACING
VEHICLES THAT HAVE BEEN REMOVED
FROM SERVICE ALREADY DUE TO
COLLISIONS OR INABILITY TO
REPAIR EXISTING VEHICLES. BOB
THOSE VEHICLES ARE IN THE WORST
CONDITION THAT ARE THE WORST
POLLUTERS- DOES WILL BE REMOVED
OFF THE ROAD FIRST AND REPLACED
WITH. THE BEST TECHNOLOGY THAT
WE CAN. WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE
TO ASSESS THE PLAN OVER THESE
FIRST TWO YEARS- AND THEN WE
WILL SUBMIT FUTURE PROPOSAL- AS
WE LEARNED FROM THIS FIRST CYCLE
. IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
THIS FIRST TWO YEARS WE'RE GOING
TO FOCUS A LOT ON BUILDING THE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO PUT INTO
PLACE- ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
STATIONS ACROSS OUR FACILITIES.
THIS IS GONNA HELP US TO MEET
MANDATES IN THE FUTURE AS WE
CONTINUE TO LETTER FIRE SLEET.
IS THERE ARE SOME TYPES OF
VEHICLES THAT ARE CURRENTLY NOT
AVAILABLE RELIABLY ON THE MARKET
THOSE ARE THE REALLY HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLES THAT CALTRANS USES FOR
OUR MAINTENANCE AND CONSTRUCTION
THOSE ARE NOT YET SEEING ARE
AVAILABLE FOR ELECTRIC
ELECTRIFICATION SO WE WOULD BE
F. PURCHASING THE VERY BEST
DIESEL TECHNOLOGY THAT WE CAN-
AND REALLY REPLACING SOME OF THE
OLDEST VEHICLES OUR FLEET THAT
ARE. FRANKLY GROSS POLLUTERS-
THE- A REFRESH AND SO THAT'S
WHAT WE'LL BE FOCUSING ON THESE
FIRST YEARS. OKAY FINANCE IN THE
COMMENTS. JAMES OR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE JUST
CONCUR THEIR PROPOSAL AND ARE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
GREAT THANK YOU AND THE L. A. O.
THANK YOU MANAGE THAT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE- WE
HAVE NO COMMENT TO CONCERNS ON
THIS PROPOSAL. THANK YOU I HAVE
A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS SINCE THE
- YOU MENTIONED THAT THE FOCUS
ON THE INFRASTRUCTURE BOB PART
OF WHERE ARE YOU PLANNING HOW
YOU WOULD DECIDE. OF THE
LOCATION OF THESE OF THIS
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE. I THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION SENATORS SO
ARE YOU I FIRST WANT TO BE CLEAR
THAT THIS IS CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR OUR WEEKS- IN
OTHER WORDS THIS WOULD NOT BE
PUBLIC CHARGING STATIONS THIS
WOULD BE- FOR THE MOST PART THAT
ARE MEET NEW STATIONS AND OUR
EQUIPMENT SHOPS ACROSS THE
STATE. AND REALLY WE WILL BE
FOCUSING ON FILLING OUT THOSE
AREAS WHERE THERE ARE NO
CURRENTLY AVAILABLE ELECTRIC
CHARGER SO THAT WHEN WE PLACED
ELECTRIC VEHICLES IN THOSE
LOCATIONS- WE ARE ABLE TO
MAINTAIN. THE VEHICLES AND THEN
CHARGE THEM FOR USE. HUH OKAY-
BEN WE THIS- HOW MUCH MORE DO
YOU GUESSTIMATE WILL NEED TO
PAY- TO REPLACE THE REST OF THE
CALTRANS FLEET. THAT'S A VERY
GOOD QUESTION AND I ACTUALLY
DON'T HAVE. A SOLID ANSWER FOR
YOU ONE OF THE REASONS WHY WE'RE
DOING THIS IN THIS SORT OF TWO
STEP PROCESS WHERE THE FIRST TWO
YEARS IS- IS ASK FOR NOW AND
THEN WE'LL COME BACK LATER IS WE
REALLY NEED TO SEE HOW THE
INDUSTRY'S OF BALDING AND HOW
THEY'RE BRINGING NEW
TECHNOLOGIES THE MARKET AND HOW
THAT WILL AFFECT THE COST OF THE
FUTURE REPLACEMENTS SO. WHILE
SOME OF THE VEHICLES RECEIVING A
WIDE AVAILABILITY LIKE
ESPECIALLY LIGHT DUTY FLEET-
WERE ABLE TO ESTIMATE THAT
FAIRLY EASILY BUT IT'S REALLY-
RELYING ON INDUSTRY TO SUPPLY A
BEGIN TO SUPPLY SOME OF THESE-
THESE NEWER TECHNOLOGIES FOR THE
DIFFERENT TYPES OF SLEEP THE
HEAVY DUTY CEDAR THE MEDIUM DUTY
SLEEP. SO WE'LL BE USING THIS
FIRST TWO YEARS TO ASSESS THE
LONG LONG TERM BE WITH WITH
INFORMATION. OKAY GREAT THANK
YOU IS CARE ACT THE WOMAN ON NOW
TO ISSUE THIRD. I'M SORRY ON
SORRY SENECA THE PROBLEM IS ONE
OF THE- OKAY THE- IT APARTMENT
HAS A DEPARTMENT LOOK INTO A
DOES IT HAVE USE LEASING THIS OF
CASH CAPITAL FOR FLEET VEHICLES
IN- IF NOT. ONE SO YES WE DO
DOES VEHICLES ALONG OUR- WE-
TYPICALLY HAVE SPENT ALMOST
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR IN
IN LEASING VEHICLES- A LOT OF
THE REASON THAT WE REQUIRE AND
USE OUR MAJOR MAINTAINED AND USE
OUR OWN SLEEP. THEY SAID THESE
ARE VEHICLES THAT WE NEED TO
HAVE BRADY FOR OPERATION IN A
MOMENT'S NOTICE THIS IS- YOU
KNOW AS YOU ARE AWARE CALTRANS
PERFORMS- EMERGENCY SERVICES
VERY OFTEN ON OUR HIGHWAY
SYSTEM. TO MAKE SURE THAT IT'S
UP AND RUNNING AT ALL TIMES WE
CAN'T ALWAYS RELY ON A RENTAL
FLEET TO BE AVAILABLE FOR US AT
ALL TIMES WE ALSO MAINTAIN A
VERY HUGE SPECIALTY SLEET SNOW
BLOWERS STREET SWEEPERS. ARE
DIFFERENT TYPES OF CONSTRUCTION
VEHICLES THAT ARE SPECIFIC TO
THE WORK THAT WE DO BUT YOU
CAN'T ALWAYS- ACTION TOWARDS
LEASE. FROM FROM OTHER- I WILL-
BECAUSE WE THAT. WE WOULD
CONTINUE TO THE STATE. WHERE WE
CAME AND WHERE THEY THE MOST
COST- THE WAY TO GO. BUT WE DO
MAINTAIN AND VERY SIGNATURE
SIGNIFICANTLY DOUBLE WORK
THOUSAND VEHICLES- AND OWNING
THOSE SPEAK ALLOWS TO- ALSO EACH
ALONG LIFETIME THAN WE OTHERWISE
SEE WHAT A WITH LEAST. IT IS A
FOLLOW UP- IN IN IT JUST WANTED
. YOU KNOW RENTAL. BUSINESS AND
ARRANGEMENTS. FROM TWO TO THE
FUNDAMENTAL KNOWS OF IN INTO. OF. TO FOR- YOU KNOW THE ENTOUS
ALIVE OF THE VIEW- IT SEEMS TO
ME THAT EKING OUT- ALL YOU CAN
FROM VEHICLES WERE YEP RAPIDLY
CHANGING TECHNOLOGY LIKE EVEY
THIS ISN'T ISN'T NECESSARILY A
GOOD MODEL ANYMORE IT SEEMS LIKE
. A BUSINESS MODEL. FRANKLY FROM
THE PAST WERE UNIT IN EFFECT YOU
WOULD WANT TO- DRAW THE
DEPRECIATION PERHAPS OR JUST
WILL BE USEFUL LIFE OF THE
VEHICLES ON AS YOU POSSIBLY
COULD IT SEEMS NO- IT IN GIVEN
GIVEN WHERE WE'RE AT IN TERMS OF
TECHNOLOGY YOU KNOW YOU'RE JUST
POINTING OUT. IS THAT THE SOME
OF THE FLEET. NEEDS AREN'T
AVAILABLE- ON THE ELECTRIC SIDE
YET- IN AND OF COURSE THAT'S
SEEMS TO BE RAPIDLY CHANGING SO-
I WANT TO ENCOURAGE. IRAN KERR
SAID APARTMENT TO LOOK AT FLEET
LEASING AS AS AN OPTION AND MY
UNDERSTANDING IS FROM AGAIN FROM
PURSUING IT TO SOME DEGREE. AT
THE COUNTY LEVEL THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT LEVEL THAT. YOU KNOW
MAINTENANCE CAN STILL BE
NEGOTIATED TO BE PROVIDED BY- IN
THE STATE STATE EMPLOYEES AND
STATE- MAINTENANCE DEPARTMENT SO
YOU DON'T HAVE TO RISK DOWNTIME
IN A WORTHLESS LEASED VEHICLES.
BUT AT LEAST WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
DO THAT THE COUNTY SO IT WAS
JUST SOMETHING I WANTED TO
ENCOURAGE MAYBE LOOKING AT IT
THROUGH A DIFFERENT LENS AT
LEAST AT LEAST WHERE YOU HAVE-
TYPES OF VEHICLES- THAT WERE
BEGINNING TO INVEST IN LIKE YOU
ARE HERE. ON THE EAST SIDE HELLO
LAST QUESTION. HOW DO YOU. MAYBE
I CAN JUST ASK FOR INFORMATION
OFFLINE INSTEAD OF. ASKING YOU
TO REPORT OUT RIGHT NOW BUT I'M
CURIOUS AS TO WHAT EXTENT WERE
MAXIMIZING THE ALTERNATIVE FUEL.
VEHICLES BUT IN GENERAL IN THE
FREE THAT YOU JUST DESCRIBED AS
A- TWELVE THOUSAND VEHICLES I
THINK YOU SAID. IT IS- IS ZERO A
RECAP SOMEWHERE JUST SORT OF AN
INVENTORY SHEET YOU COULD SHARE
INDICATES OF THE FUEL TYPE- PER
VEHICLE. IN THE FLEET. YEAH I'M
CERTAIN THAT WE CAN DEVELOP THAT
INFORMATION TO THE COMMITTEE BE
HAPPY TO SUPPLY THAT. OFFLINE
OKAY THANK THANK YOU FOR YOUR
REPORT TODAY VERY HELPFUL THE
COMMUNITY- THANK YOU MISTER
TECH- WE MOVE ON NOW TO ISSUE
THIRTEEN OFFICE OF UNMANNED
AIRCRAFT SYSTEMS. THANK YOU
CHAIR ONE HUNDRED OF WOMEN ONE
PERSON OR. CRAP SYSTEM OF. YEAH
IF I CAN REMEMBER THE THROUGH
THIS SO WENT AGAINST JACK WITH
DELTA. SO TODAY'S WILL TRY TO
PROPOSAL IS FOR A PERMIT
INCREASE OF FORTY FOURTEEN
THOUSAND. AND TO POSITIONS OPEN
STATE HIGHWAY SUPPORT- AS I SAID
THE POSITIONS SOFTWARE AND THE
TRAINING TO ESTABLISHED AND I'M
PERSON EVER CRAFT- SYSTEM
PROGRAM. BASICALLY WILL CALL
THESE UAS IS FROM NOW ON- THIS
IS A NEW TOOL THAT ALLOWS. THE
DEPARTMENT TO REALLY
REVOLUTIONIZE THE WAY THAT WE'RE
DOING MARK- THESE ARE WHAT YOU
MIGHT. CALL DRONES- IN THE
VERNACULAR OF THESE ARE FAR MORE
SOPHISTICATED AND WHAT THEY CAN
DO THEM IN SOME OF YOUR AVERAGE
CAMERA DRONES- THE INCORPORATION
OF THE U. A. S. INTO FIELD
OPERATIONS INCREASES EFFICIENCY
AND. SAVINGS- I'M SORRY
INSURGENCY IN. WHICH OF COURSE A
MAJOR FOR THE DEPARTMENT THAT
ALLOWS US TO DO- RUSS. MARK
OTHER TYPES OF WORKS WITHOUT
ACTUALLY HAVING TO GO AND VISIT
THE SITE. YEAH VISIT THE SITE
ISN'T THE WORD I MET WITHOUT
HAVING TO PHYSICALLY ENTER INTO
A DANGEROUS SITES SUCH AS A
LANDSLIDE OR OTHER TYPE OF- OF
ISSUE. ON THE U. S. IS. HAVE
BEEN RECOGNIZED AS AN EFFICIENCY
BY THE DEPARTMENT AND BY THE
FEDERAL HIGHWAY ADMINISTRATION
AS WELL. AND IS A SIGNIFICANT
SOURCE OF PROJECT LEVEL SAVINGS
AND WILL CONTINUE TO GROW. ITS
USE OVER TIME. I WANT TO. SAY
THAT THE SAVINGS THAT WE REALIZE
ON THESE PROJECTS IS IT IS AT
THE PROJECT LEVEL- SO YOU
WOULDN'T NECESSARILY SEE AN
OFFSETTING B. C. PETER TOPPED
WITH THE SAVINGS BUT WE DO
RECOGNIZE THE SAVINGS IN THE-
CAPITAL OUTLAY PROJECT COSTS.
GREAT SOUNDS REALLY GOOD- IS
THERE A HAVE YOU FOUND ANY
DOWNSIDE OR ISSUES THAT YOU'RE
LOOKING YOU'RE WATCHING OUT FOR
. R. THAT'S A VERY GOOD QUESTION
I THINK ONE OF THE- A. B. ALSO
STRUGGLES THAT WE'RE WE'RE
DEALING WHICH IS A LOT OF THE
FAA- OVERSIGHT OF USING THESE
KINDS OF DRONES THESE ARE AND
ARE NOT A- CONSUMER GRADE TINY
DRONE THAT YOU CAN JUST CHECK
OUT THERE'S A LOT OF- THAT. WE
NEED TO FOLLOW IN EFFECT THAT'S
PART OF WHAT THE SETTING UP OF
THIS OFFICE WILL DO IS TO ENSURE
THAT WE REMAIN IN COMPLIANCE
WITH FAA REGULATIONS. OKAY OKAY
WONDERFUL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THAT WILL MOVE ON TO ISSUE
FOURTEEN WHICH IS PEDESTRIAN
AND- BICYCLE SAFETY. TAKE THAT
ON. OKAY THIS IS THE LAST ONE I
THINK FOR THE DEPARTMENT TODAY
AGAINST EVEN CHECK WITH
CALTRANS- THIS IS A REQUEST FOR
TWELVE FULL TIME POSITIONS IN
THE AMOUNT OF TWO POINT TWO FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE STATE I
WOULD ACCOUNT. THESE WERE
RESOURCES WILL ALLOW US TO
PERMANENTLY ESTABLISH THE
PEDESTRIAN AND BICYCLIST SAFETY
INVESTIGATIONS PROGRAM IN THE
DEPARTMENT. THE PROPOSED
STAFFING WELL- PROVIDE CONTINUED
SUPPORT TO THE PEDESTRIAN AND
BICYCLIST MONITORING PROGRAMS IN
THE DEPARTMENT. IT'S GOING TO
ALLOW US TO PRODUCE ON AVERAGE
ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED EDUCATIONAL
SAFETY INVESTIGATIONS PER YEAR-
THAT WE WOULD DO IN. IDENTIFIED
HIGH COLLISIONS OR HIGH
DANGEROUS AREA SORRY HIGH DANER
AREAS WHERE- AUSTRIANS IN
BICYCLES INTERACT WITH WITH ROAD
TRAFFIC. THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT JOB PROPOSAL FOR US
OBVIOUSLY ALIGNS WITH OUR SEEK
YOU FIRST GOALS AND OUR- OUR
TOWARD ZERO DEATHS. SORRY
TOWARDS ZERO DEATHS INITIATIVE
THAT THE STATE AND FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. THANK YOU MISTER
KICKED- WITH FINANCE LIKE TO
COMMENT. BENJAMIN FALLS BERMAN
FINANCE JUST CAN KERR WITH THE
POINTS MADE BY STEVEN TACK WE
HAD SOME GOOD RESULTS AS WE DID
A TRIAL OF THIS PROGRAM OF THE
PAST COUPLE YEARS AND WE SUPPORT
ALSO AS PRESENTED. THANK YOU-
MISS ROW OR ANYONE FROM THE ELLO
LA O'S OFFICE. I IN THIS ROW
WITH L. A. L. A. WE ARE NOT
CONCERNED WITH THIS PROPOSAL.
OKAY THANK YOU JUST ONE QUESTION
MISTER CAKE BEFORE WE LET YOU GO
HOW DOES THIS- REQUEST FOR THE
FUNDING FOR BICYCLE AND
PEDESTRIAN SAFETY HOW DOES IT
CONNECT WITH THE TRANSPORTATION.
PACKAGE OF FUNDING. YEAH THAT'S
A GREAT QUESTION SO THE-
PROPOSAL HERE IS TO BEGAN TO
CONDUCT THE SAFETY
INVESTIGATIONS THAT WILL REALLY
HELP US TO IDENTIFY LOCATIONS
WHERE WE NEED TO INVEST MORE IN
A PEDESTRIAN AND BICYCLE
INFRASTRUCTURE SO WHAT THIS WILL
DO IS TO HELP US- FEED INTO
EITHER THE GOVERNOR'S
TRANSPORTATION PROPOSAL THAT WAS
DISCUSSED EARLIER TODAY OR
REALLY ANY FUTURE- SEAT YOU
PROGRAMS SUCH AS THE- THIS.
APARTMENTS STATE HIGHWAY
OPERATIONS AND PROTECTION
PROGRAM. IT WILL FEED INTO THOSE
AND HELP TO IN ADDRESS THESE
AREAS OF CPT. I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT DOESN'T STAY YOU KNOW
ISOLATED FROM WHAT IS GOING ON
IN THE- YOU KNOW INFRASTRUCTURE
OF CONSTRUCTION THAT WORLD
FUNDING IT'S HARD TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT INFORMATION IS
ACTUALLY GETS INTO. THE HANDS OF
THOSE WHO NEED IT OR SHOULD BE
USING. YEAH ABSOLUTELY AGREE
WITH YOU AND THAT THAT THAT'S
THE ENTIRE PURPOSE OF SETTING UP
THIS FORMAL PROGRAM WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT SO THAT WE CAN
IDENTIFY THOSE NEEDS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY ARE. OKAY GREAT
SENATE QUARTERS IN. THIS
SOMETHING THAT WE'VE FOR PURSUED
BUT A LITTLE BIT OF MY OFFICE
AND IN TERMS OF THOUGHT IS-
WHETHER OR NOT- TRAFFIC APPS YOU
KNOW THE TECHNOLOGY THAT WE HAVE
NOW- ESPECIALLY IN THE PRIVATE
SECTOR SIDE OF COURSE WE HAVE.
SOME THAT ON THE PUBLIC SECTOR
SIDE TO IN. ON A REGIONAL BASIS
WHETHER OR NOT- THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS A WAY TO WORK
YOU KNOW WITH THOSE ENTITIES TO
ESSENTIALLY. SIMPLY ADD TO UGH
IN A GOOD WAY TO TRAFFIC CALMING
EFFORTS IN IN LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS BY. HI TRYING TO
GET- THOSE WHO WERE- NAVIGATING
FOLKS AROUND TO HELP THEM
NAVIGATE AWAY FROM- HI FIDELITY
YOU KNOW HI COLLISION-
INTERSECTIONS OR ROADWAYS YOU
KNOW WE'VE SEEN AGREES SO MUCH
OF THIS OF LATE EVEN NONE
RECENTLY THE LOSS OF THE FORMER
LEGISLATOR HERE. A IN THE EAST
BAY- I DON'T THINK A DAY GOES BY
IN THE IN MY LOCAL- NEW STREAM
WHERE. WE DON'T HAVE. THE IT
ANOTHER TRAGEDY- POPPING UP I
DON'T KNOW WHAT ALL THE REASONS
FOR BUT BACK TO THE JUST A
QUESTION- IT BEEN ANY RESPONSE
TO THE IDEA OF WORKING WITH. OR
ATTEMPTING TO WORK WITH- PRIVATE
SECTOR TRAFFIC APPS. TO ADD A
LAYER BEYOND WHAT THEY DO NOW
YOU KNOW A TRAFFIC IS SLOWING
THIS IS YOUR FASTEST ROUTE THIS
YEAR TOLL FREE ROUTE YOU KNOW
HOW ABOUT THIS IS A ROUTE. THAT
YOU MIGHT WANT TO AVOID GIVEN
PEDESTRIAN FATALITIES OR BICYCLE
FACILITIES. I THINK YOU'RE THANK
YOU SENATOR DAISY THAT- THAT'S A
QUESTION AND I. WILL HAVE TO GET
BACK TO YOU ON A- WE DO HAVE THE
SAFETY PROGRAM WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT THAT LOOKS AT. I'M
INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENTS THAT
WE CAN MAKE BUT ALSO THOSE SORT
OF OUTSIDE OF THE BOX THINKING.
IDEAS I WANT TO WORK WITH THEM
TO SEE- WHAT WE MAY ALREADY BE
DOING IN THIS AREA AND WE'LL GET
BACK TO YOU WITH MORE DETAILS.
THE GREAT THANK YOU. OKAY I
THINK THAT WAS IT FOR YOU THANK
YOU MISTER CAKE AND- OTHERS. WE
MOVE ON NOW TO CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL. ISSUE FIFTEEN IS
THE CAPITAL OUTLAY PROPOSALS-
DEPARTMENT LIKE TO PRESENT. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE- DEPUTY
COMMISSIONER SHAGARI APPEARING
ON BEHALF OF COMMISSIONER MANTA
RAY. I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO APPEAR BEFORE YOU
TODAY TO DISCUSS THE CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL'S BUDGET
PROPOSALS I'D LIKE TO EXPRESS
OUR APPRECIATION YOUR COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR ASSISTANCE IN
PREPARING FOR THIS HEARING. I'LL
BE DISCUSSING SEVERAL PROPOSALS
THAT I HOPE YOU WILL SUPPORT WE
FEEL EACH OF THEM ARE CRUCIAL TO
OUR MISSION TO PROVIDE THE
HIGHEST LEVEL SAFETY SERVICE AND
SECURITY. TO ALL OF CALIFORNIANS
APPEARING WITH ME TODAY'S
ASSISTANT CHIEF MIKE ALVAREZ
MIKE IS OUR SPECIAL
REPRESENTATIVE LEGISLATURE AS
ALWAYS WE WELCOME ANY DISCUSSION
OR QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE ON THE
TOPICS WE PRESENT- FOR ISSUE
FIFTEEN THIS YEAR THE CHP IS
PROPOSING NINE CAPITAL OUTLAY-
ISSUES FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
AND INTEREST OF TIME ALL PRESENT
A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF EACH
REQUEST- FOR BACKGROUND THE CP
HAS A TOTAL OF A HUNDRED ELEVEN
DIFFERENT OFFICES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. IN TWO THOUSAND NINE WE
REQUESTED THE DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES TO COMPLETE A
REVIEW OF OUR AREA OFFICES FOR
VARIOUS ISSUES INCLUDING SIZE
MAKING ADA COMPLIANCE ANDTHE
CONDITION OF OUR AGING
STRUCTURES. EACH OF THE OFFICES
UP FOR DISCUSSION TODAY WERE
IDENTIFIED AND PRIORITIZED BY
THE CBN DGS AS NEEDING IMMEDIATE
REPLACEMENT. FIRST IS THE
ANTELOPE AREA ANTELOPE VALLEY
AREA OFFICE THIS FACILITY FIRST
OPENED IN NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE.
AND IS ONE OF THE MOST
UNDERSIZED CHP OFFICERS IN THE
STATE AND IT DOES NOT MEET
TODAY'S SEISMIC CRITERIA FOR
STATE BUILDINGS. WE'RE
REQUESTING A ONE MILL SEVEN OR
NINETY SO DOLLARS FROM THE J.
FUND. TO COMPLETE THE
ACQUISITION PHASE OF THIS DESIGN
BUILD PROJECT. NEXT IS THE
BARSTOW AREA OFFICE WHICH OPENED
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR- THE
CURRENT BUILDING IS NOT IN
COMPLIANCE WITH SEISMIC
CRITERIA. AND IS ALSO
SIGNIFICANTLY UNDERSIZED- THE
CTS REQUESTING JUST OVER THREE
MILLION FROM THE GENERAL FUND TO
COMPLETE THE ACQUISITION PHASE
OF THIS PROJECT. WE'RE
REQUESTING A TWO MILLION ONE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY SEVEN THOUSAND
FROM THE GENERAL FUND. FOR THE
PERFORMANCE CRITERIA PHASE OF
THE GOLD RUN AREA OFFICE
REPLACEMENT. OF THE CURRENT
OFFICE OPENED IN NINETEEN SIXTY
FOUR- THE FACILITY NOW HAS
NUMEROUS STRUCTURAL DEFICIENCIES
AND HAS EXPERIENCE EXPERIENCE
NOTICEABLE MASS MOVEMENT OVER
THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS. I'M
SORRY- COMMISSIONER WHERE IS THE
GOLD RUN AREA I'M SORRY FOR MY
NOT KNOWING THIS. WELL THAT'S
OKAY THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION IT'S
ON THE INTERSTATE EIGHTY JUST
PAST AUBURN ON THE WAY TO
TRUCKEE OKAY THANK YOU. THE NEXT
ONE WE'RE REQUESTING. JUST OVER
TWO AND A HALF MILLION FROM THE
GENERAL FUND FOR THE ACQUISITION
PHASE OF THE LOS BANOS JERRY
OFFICE- OF THIS FACILITY FIRST
OPENED IN NINETEEN SIXTY NINE.
IT IS- UNDERSIZED FOR EXISTING
PROGRAM NEEDS AND IT ALSO DOES
NOT MEET THE SEISMIC CRITERIA
REQUIRED FOR STATE OWNED
BUILDINGS. AND THEYWERE
REQUESTING- ONE POINT TWO
MILLION FROM THE GENERAL FUND
FOR THE ACQUISITION PHASE OF THE
PORTERVILLE AREA OFFICE
REPLACEMENT. OF THIS OFFICE IS
ONE OF OUR OLDEST IT OPENED IN
NINETEEN SIXTY. AND SEVERELY
UNDERSIZED FOR. IT SIR IT IS
UNDERSIZED FOR THE OFFICE IN THE
STATE AND IT ALSO DOES NOT MEET
THE SEISMIC CRITERIA REQUIRED
FOR STATE OWNED BUILDINGS. AND
IN THE READING AREA OFFICE
REPLACEMENT PROJECT IS ENTERING
THE ACQUISITION PHASE OF THE
PROJECT- THE C. TREE IS
REQUESTING ONE POINT SEVEN
MILLION FROM THE GENERAL FUND TO
COMPLETE THIS PHASE. OF THE
READING AREA OPENED IN NINETEEN
SIXTY SEVEN. IT'S AN OLD
BUILDING ITS UNDERSIZED AND DOES
NOT MEET SEISMIC CRITERIA. AND
THEY WERE ASKING FOR FIVE POINT
FOUR MILLION FROM THE MOTOR
VEHICLE COUNT FOR THE RELOCATION
OF THE NUTRI SYRIANA'S.
FOLLOWING THE COMPLETION OF THIS
PROJECT THAT WAS STARTED IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. THIS PROPOSAL
INCLUDES A ONE TIME FUNDING OF
ONE POINT NINE MILLION FOR
MOVING COSTS. AND JUST OVER
THREE AND A HALF MILLION FOR PRO
RATED RENTAL COSTS IN THIS
BUDGET YEAR IN THE BUDGET YEAR.
ONGOING RENTAL COST WILL BE FOUR
POINT TWO SIX MILLION IN THE
YEARS MOVING FORWARD- WITH THIS
PROPOSAL WE ANTICIPATE OCCUPYING
THE NEW FACILITY IN THE FALL OF
THIS YEAR. FINALLY FOR CAPITAL
OUTLAY- THE C. H. B. IT REQUEST
FIVE POINT FOUR MILLION FROM THE
GENERAL FUND FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION PHASE OF THE SIEGE
BE ENHANCED RADIO SYSTEM THAT
LIVE WITHIN PEAK. OF THIS
REQUEST AS NECESSARY TO ENSURE
THE CHP'S ABILITY TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH THE STRIPPERS
PROJECT TO ADDRESS DETERIORATING
RADIO COMMUNICATION
INFRASTRUCTURE AND IMPROVED
INTER OPERABILITY AMONG VARIOUS
PUBLIC SAFETY AGENCIES. THAT
COMPLETES OUR CAPPELLI REQUEST
ALL POSITIVE THERE'S ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF A COMMISSIONER OF
FINANCE WOULD YOU LIKE TO SAY
ANYTHING. RANDY CAST UPON A
FINANCE- WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THE CAPITAL OUTLAY PURPOSES.
OKAY AND FELLOW OFFICE. IN
ISRAEL WITH THE L. A. L. WE HAVE
NO CONCERN TO THE CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROPOSALS. OKAY GREAT. JUST ONE
QUESTION- COMMISSIONER. IS- I
NOTICES SOME OF THE PROJECTS ARE
FUNDED FROM THE GENERAL FUND AND
OTHERS ARE THE NBA FUND COULD
YOU EXPLAIN THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE TWO. YEAH I WOULD
DEFER TO THE PARTNER FINANCE ON
THAT ONE MA'AM. OKAY RANDY KATZ
DEPARTMENT FINANCE- THE- ONE
PROJECT THAT'S M. G. A. WITH THE
REST BEING GENERAL FUND AND THE
DETERMINATION WAS- THAT THE THAT
THE LEASE PAYMENTS ON THE TRACY
AREA OFFICE WOULD BE ON GOING OR
AT LEAST TO BE GOING FOR TWENTY
TO TWENTY FIVE YEARS SO THE
TERMINATION WAS MADE TO BE AT AN
ONGOING COST ME BETTER COMING
OUT OF THE MOTOR VEHICLE
ACCOUNT. WHEREAS IS ONE TIME
COSTS- DETERMINATION WAS WAS
MADE TO FIND IT GENERAL FUND TO
BEST ENSURE ABOUT THE CATHOLIC
PROJECTS MOVE FORWARD. OKAY I DO
HAVE A- COMMENTS QUESTIONS
SANDERS. NO. OKAY GREAT ALL
RIGHTS ARE THANK YOU
COMMISSIONER AND EVERYONE FOR
YOUR PARTICIPATION TODAY
APPRECIATE ALL THAT YOU DO A
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO ISSUES
SIX TEEN. ISSUE SIXTEEN IS
RESOURCES AND OFFICE SPACE OUR
FOR OUR SWING SPACE. WITH. MATT
WILL BE. AGAIN I THINK IT'S
COMMISSIONER YES MA'AM
COMMISSION DURING THE SIEGE BE-
THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL
REQUEST MULTI YEAR FUNDING FROM
THE NBA FOR THE PROTECTION AND
SECURITY THE NEW STATE CAPITOL
SWING SPACE. AND THE NEW STATE
CAPITOL ANNEX OF THIS PROGRAM
REQUEST EIGHTEEN POINT FIVE
MILLION IN FY TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE BUT JUST UNDER THIRTEEN
MILLION FY TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR A NINE POINT NINE MILLION
IN FY TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE
AND JUST OVER SEVEN MILLION IN
FY TWENTY FIVE TWENTY SIX. AS
YOU KNOW THE GOVERNMENT CO
PROVIDES TO THE CBS JURISDICTION
OVER MATTERS RELATED TO SECURITY
ESTATE OFFICERS PROPERTY ANY
OCCUPANTS OF STATE PROPERTY AS
SUCH OF THE CHP IS THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY TASKED WITH
THE PROTECTION OF THE STATE
CAPITOL CAPITOL ANNEX THE
CAPITAL SWING SPACE CAPITAL
PARK. THE LEGISLATIVE AWESOME
OFFICE BUILDING AND ALL OTHER
STATE BUILDINGS IN THE DOWNTOWN
SACRAMENTO AREA CURRENTLY THE
CHP'S CAPITAL PROTECTION SECTION
FACILITY HOUSES BOTH CAPITAL
PROTECTION SECTION WHICH ARE THE
FOLKS THAT ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
PROTECTING THOSE BUILDINGS AND
THE CHP'S DIGNITARY PROTECTION
SECTION WHICH ARE THE OFFICERS
THAT PROTECT OUR CONSTITUTIONAL
OFFICERS. THE CURRENT FACILITY
IS EXTREMELY UNDERSIZED AT JUST. UNDER FIFTEEN THOUSAND SQUARE
FEET. THE ADDITION OF A THIS
CAPITAL SO SPACE. S. THANK.
EXPANDED THE C. TREES
RESPONSIBILITY AS SECURITY FOR.
IN COORDINATION WITH THE JOINT
COMMITTEE COMMITTEE ON RULES THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND THE
LEGISLATURE THE SIEGE
PREDETERMINED THAT ADDITIONAL
PERSONNEL AND RESOURCES ARE
NEEDED TO FULFILL THE NEW
SECURITY REQUIREMENTS. THIS
INCREASE IN PERSONNEL ALSO
RESULT IN THE NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL SUPERVISORY STAFF.
CLERICAL SUPPORT STAFF LOCKER
ROOM SPACE STORAGE SPACE FOR
EQUIPMENT AND GENERAL OFFICE
SPACE. THIS AND DGS CONDUCTED A
REVIEW OF THE SPACING
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE ADDITIONAL
STAFFING AND EQUIPMENT AND
DETERMINE THE NEED OF
APPROXIMATELY FORTY FIVE
THOUSAND SQUARE FEET TO
ACCOMMODATE THE CURRENT
ADDITIONAL STAFFING- PROTECTION
RESOURCES AND EQUIPMENT. WORKING
WITH DGS WE'VE IDENTIFIED AN
AVAILABLE FACILITY THAT WOULD
ACCOMMODATE THE SPACE
REQUIREMENTS AND IN ITS CLOSE
PROXIMITY TO THE CAPITAL. THE
NEW LOCATION ACOSTA SIEGE AN
ESTIMATED TWO POINT EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN MILLION IN THE FIRST YEAR.
IN ADDITION TO THE NEW FACILITY
COSTS THIS PROPOSAL REQUEST
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR OFFICERS
TO WORK OVERTIME AND HANDLE THE
INCREASED SECURITY REQUIREMENTS.
TO MANAGE THE ADDITIONAL
WORKLOAD THIS PROPOSAL ALSO
REQUESTS THE ADDITION OF TO THE
TENANTS AND EIGHT SERGEANTS TO
THE CAPITAL PROTECTION SECTION.
I SHOULD NOTE THE OFFICER
OVERTIME IS ANTICIPATED TO
DECREASE OVER FUTURE FY SAYS THE
DEPARTMENT RECRUITS AND HIRES
MORE OFFICERS. AND REDUCES THE
CURRENT OFFICER VACANCIES. FOR
FY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE THE
SIEGE BE ANTICIPATES NINE POINT
TWO MILLION NEEDED FOR THE
INCREASE IN PERSONAL RESOURCES.
FOR FY TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR
WE ANTICIPATE THAT NEED DROPS TO
JUST OVER SIX MILLION. AND
ADDITIONAL DROP THE FOLLOWING FY
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE DOWN TO
THREE MILLION. I FY TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY SIX WE PLAN TO HAVE MORE
OFFICERS TIRES THAT THE OVERTIME
WOULD NO LONGER BE NEEDED TO
STAFF THE NECESSARY SECURITY
POSITIONS. FOR THE STATE CAPITOL
IN THE SWING SPACE ANY OTHER
STATE BOTH BUILDINGS IN THE
CAPITAL TO SANITY. ULTIMATELY
APPROVAL THIS REQUEST ONE ABLE
TO SEE SHOULD BE TO PROPERLY
PROVIDE LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
PROTECTIVE SERVICES TO THE
LEGISLATIVE LEGISLATIVE AND
EXECUTIVE OFFICES. WHILE
ENSURING THAT WE MEET THE NEW
SECURITY DEMANDS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU COMMISSIONER
APPRECIATE VERY MUCH- ANYBODY
FROM FINANCED LIKE TO SPEAK.
CATHY MCLEOD DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- WE CONCUR WITH THE
PRESENTATION OF THE PROPOSAL BY
CHP. THANK YOU AND L. A. O. IN
THIS ROAD THE L. A. L. WE HAVE
NO CONCERNS WITH THIS PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU. I JUST WAS A
COMMISSIONER TO. OUR
APPRECIATION I THINK I SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF ALL THE MEMBERS OF.
VERY MUCH THE WORK THAT YOU DO
AND PROTECTING THE PUBLIC AND-
EVERYONE CONNECTED TO THE TO THE
CAPITAL BOB THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR- FOR YOUR WORK- CAN YOU
GIVE SOME EXAMPLES I THINK COULD
BE. OF WORTH NOTING OF WHAT YOU
MEAN BY THE INCREASED SECURITY
BUT NEEDS OF THAT YOU'RE
FULFILLING THAT YOU WILL BE
FULFILLING. YEAH ABSOLUTELY IT'S
A GOOD QUESTION THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENTS ON HER OWN OF PASS
ALONG TO HER TO OUR TEAM- THE
INCREASED WENT WITH THE BUILDING
OF THE SWING SPACE IT INCREASED-
BUILDING THAT THAT WOULD BE OPEN
TO THE EXECUTIVE AND LEGISLATIVE
OFFICES AND ALSO OPEN TO THE
PUBLIC. AND SO WE ALMOST HAD A
DOUBLE OUR RESOURCES- WITH
OFFICERS IN THAT AREA TO PROVIDE
THE NECESSARY PROTECTION
SECURITY FOR THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE EXECUTIVE OFFICES IN THAT
BUILDING AND THEN JUST THE
SURROUNDING BUILDINGS. IN THE
AREA. OKAY OKAY. NONE NO MORE
QUESTIONS OKAY- THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT BUT WE'RE
MOVING ON TO ISSUE SEVENTEEN
WHICH IS CENTRALIZED UP TO STILL
BE IN OF RECORDS UNIT.
COMMISSIONER MA'AM OF THE CCP'S
REQUESTED A TWO YEAR LIMITED
TERM FUNDING OF SIX HUNDRED AND
NINETY SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM
THE NBA IN FY TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE. AND IN FY TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR FOR SIX POSITIONS TO
ESTABLISH A CENTRALIZED
CUSTODIAN OF RECORDS UNIT WITHIN
THE DEPARTMENT'S COMMUNICATIONS
CENTER SUPPORT SECTION. WITH THE
PASSING OF NEW LAWS RELATIVE TO
THE PUBLIC RECORDS ACT STATEWIDE
PR A REQUEST CONTINUE TO
INCREASE ESTABLISHING THE
CUSTODIAN OF RECORDS UNIT WILL
INCREASE THE SPEED. EFFICIENCY
AND ACCURACY AND TRANSPARENCY OF
SPECIES RESPONSES TO PRERACE. AS
A QUICK BACKGROUND THE CHP
OPERATES TWENTY FIVE
COMMUNICATION CENTERS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. OF THE UNIT PROPOSED
IN THIS B. C. P. WOULD BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR P. R. A REQUEST
SUBMITTED TO THE FOUR LARGEST
COMMUNICATIONS CENTER WHICH ARE
OUR BORDER COMMUNICATION CENTER
IN THE SN DIEGO AREA. OUR
GOLDEN GATE COMMUNICATION CENTER
WHICH ENCOMPASSES THE ENTIRE BAY
AREA BUT LOS ANGELES
COMMUNICATION. CENTER AND THE
ORANGE COUNTY COMMUNICATIONS
CENTER. THIS UNIT WILL ASSUME
ALL RISK. FOR RESPONDING TO
VARIOUS. REQUESTS AS WELL AS
REQUESTS FOR COMMUNICATIONS LOGS
AND AUDIO RECORDINGS. AS A
MEASURE OF THE UNITS OUTCOMES
AND ACCOUNTABILITY PRIOR TO THE
CONCLUSION OF THE TWO YEAR
PERIOD IN THIS PROPOSAL. WE WILL
EVALUATE THE PROGRAM'S
EFFECTIVENESS INEFFICIENCIES AND
DETERMINE IF ADDITIONAL
COMMUNICATION CENTERS. CAN BE
ADDED TO THE FOR THAT I'VE JUST
IDENTIFIED. THE ANALYSIS WILL
INCLUDE A REVIEW OF STAFF
WORKLOAD THE TOTAL NUMBER
REQUEST RECEIVED AND THE AVERAGE
PROCESSING TIME. THE TIMELY
RELEASE OF POLICE RECORDS IS
VITAL AND MAINTAINING TRUST AND
LEGITIMACY WITH BOTH THE PUBLIC
AND THE LEGISLATURE N. AS
NECESSARY TO MAINTAIN COMPLIANCE
WITH THE LAW. ULTIMATELY IT'S
OUR INTENT AFTER SHOWING THE
EFFECTIVENESS INEFFICIENCIES OF
THE NEW UNIT TO RETURN IN
REQUEST TO MAKE A STARTING A
RECORD JANET PERMANENT. GREAT
THANK YOU FOR THAT- EXPLANATION
I JUST. THOUGHT I'D LET ME GO
WITH THE- WITH FINANCE BEFORE I
START. WITH MY COMMENTS GO AHEAD
FINANCE. I THINK THAT'S IS THAT
MISS MACLEOD. I'M SORRY ABOUT
THAT IT WAS A NEW BUT AND I'M WE
HAVE NOTHING TO ADD TO DISPOSAL.
OKAY THANK YOU AND FROM THE
ELOISE OFFICE. I IN THIS ROW AT
THE L. A. L. WE HAVE NO CONCERNS
WITH THIS PROPOSAL. RIGHT THANK
YOU ARE I JUST WANT TO NOTE I
THINK HERE FROM OUR CHART-
COMMISSIONER THAT- THE TOTAL
REQUEST IN TWENTY THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN IF I CA CORRECT FROM
THESE FOUR OFFICES WAS FIVE
THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED TWENTY
NINE- THE REQUESTED TWENTY
NINETEEN WERE. PRETTY MUCH
TRIPLED FIFTEEN THOUSAND ONE
HUNDRED NINETY SIX- SO THAT
MAKES IT PRETTY CLEAR UP THE
NEED THAT THAT YOU HAVE. KIND OF
YOU WANT TO. ADD ANYTHING TO A-
NO THAT'S- YOU'RE SPOT ON WITH
THOSE NUMBERS- WE TRIPLED IN
THAT TIME FRAME AND- WE CONTINUE
TO EXPECT THOSE HIGH NUMBERS SO-
I THINK DEFINITELY JUSTIFIES THE
NEED FOR THE UNIT. GREAT
COLLEAGUES ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. OR NOT OKAY THANK YOU
COMMISSIONER OF LET'S MOVE ON
TO. ISSUE EIGHTEEN WHICH IS A
HIGHWAY VIOLENCE TASK FORCE.
THANK YOU SENATOR THE CALIFORNIA
REFERRAL REQUEST ONE TIME
FUNDING FROM THE GENERAL FUND OF
JUST OVER FOUR MILLION IN FY
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE THREE
POINT THREE MILLION IN FY TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR AND AGAIN
THREE POINT THREE MILLION IN FY
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE. TO
ADDRESS THE INCREASE IN VIOLENT
CRIMES OCCURRING ON OUR STATE
HIGHWAYS. THESE VIOLENT CRIMES
INCLUDE FREEWAY SHOOTINGS
HOMICIDES ASSAULTS AND BATTERIES
AND CRIMES INVOLVING OBJECTS
THROWN OR SHOT AT BEIT CALLS.
DUE TO SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN
VIOLENT CRIME COMMITTED ON STATE
HIGHWAYS IN RECENT YEARS THE CHP
RECENTLY CREATED A HIGHWAY
VIOLENCE TASK FORCE. ALTHOUGH
STILL IN ITS INFANCY STAGES THE
FUNDING IDENTIFIED IN THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD PROVIDE
INVESTIGATIVE AND ENFORCEMENT
EQUIPMENT INVESTIGATIVE
TECHNOLOGY NEEDS. AND
OPERATIONAL EXPENSES NEEDED TO
SUPPORT THE TASK FORCE. THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD FACILITATE
CONCENTRATED ENFORCEMENT DETAILS
AND UTILIZE INVESTIGATIVE TOOLS
DOUBLE APPREHEND VIOLATORS AND
CURB FUTURE INCIDENTS. ONE AREA
SPECIFIC CONCERN PARTICULARLY
WITHIN THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
COMMUNITIES WE SERVE OUR FREEWAY
SHOOTINGS THE CHP STARTED
TRACKING FREEWAY SHOOTINGS THAT
OCCURRED WITHIN OUR JURISDICTION
AND TWO THOUSAND AND NINETEEN.
THAT YEAR CALIFORNIA EXPERIENCED
TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY FREEWAY
SHOOTINGS IN TWENTY TWENTY OF
THE SIEGE BE INVESTIGATED THREE
HUNDRED AND NINETY SEVEN FREEWAY
SHOOTINGS THIS REPRESENTS A 65%
INCREASE OF THE YEAR BEFORE. AND
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE WE
INVESTIGATED FOUR HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY ONE FREEWAY SHOOTINGS
WHICH NEARLY IS 96% INCREASE
OVER THE BASELINE ESTABLISHED IN
TWENTY NINETEEN.SINCE TWENTY
NINETEEN WE'VE INVESTIGATED A
THOUSAND AND SEVENTY EIGHT
CONFIRMED SHOOTINGS ON OUR
HIGHWAYS. THIS PROPOSAL WOULD
ASSIST THE CHP AND REDUCING
INCREASED VIOLENCE ON
CALIFORNIA'S HIGHWAYS BY
ADDRESSING THE EMERGING NEED FOR
INCREASED LAW ENFORCEMENT
PRESENCE AS WELL AS
INVESTIGATIVE TOOLS TO ASSIST IN
APPREHENSION AND PROSECUTION. SB
PATROLLING CONCENTRATED
ENFORCEMENT IS IDENTIFIED.
LOCATIONS OF CRIME INTENSITY IS
A KNOWN EFFECTIVE COUNTERMEASURE
IN PROACTIVELY PREVENTING
CRIMINAL ACTIVITY. THE PROPOSAL
SEEKS TWO POINT ONE MILLION IN
OVERTIME FUNDING FOR
CONCENTRATED ENFORCEMENT DETAILS
THROUGHOUT THE SIEGE B. FIELD
DIVISIONS MOST AFFECTED BY
HIGHWAY VIOLENCE. ADDITIONALLY
WE HAVE IDENTIFIED A NEED FOR A
COMPREHENSIVE CRIME ANALYTICS
SYSTEM AND A DEDICATED
ANALYTICAL PERSONNEL TO COLLATE
AGGREGATE AND ANALYZE CRIME DATA
. HE'S RIGHT RESOURCES WILL
ALLOW US TO CLOSE THE CURRENT
GAP IN STATEWIDE ANALYTICAL
TOOLS AND ALLOW CHP
INVESTIGATORS TO IDENTIFY REAL
TIME CRIME RATES TRENDS AND
PATTERNS AND MORE IMPORTANTLY
CONNECT CRIMES ACROSS GEOGRAPHIC
BOUNDARIES. TO ADDRESS THIS NEED
THIS PROPOSAL REQUEST FIVE
HUNDRED ELEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
FROM THE GENERAL FUND. TO FIND
SALARIES AND BENEFITS FOR SEVEN
ANALYST POSITIONS TO ANALYZE
CRIME DATA AND CONDUCT CRIMINAL
ANALYTICS AND RESEARCH THIS
PROPOSAL ALSO REQUESTS NINE
HUNDRED AND NINETY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO PROVIDE FOR TRAINING.
I T. IN A QUICK COST ALTERNATELY
EACH ASPECT OF THIS PROPOSAL
WILL SUPPORT THE FUTURE PLEASE
WORK TOWARDS. THE REDUCTION O
VIOLENT CRIMES ON CALIFORNIA'S
HOURS. THAT'S JUST ONE EXAMPLE
LAST WEEK SEIZE PROJECT IS FROM
OUR GOLDEN GATE DIVISION
ARRESTED A SUSPECT IN CONNECTION
WITH A FREEWAY SHOOTING THAT
OCCURRED FIVE MONTHS AGO IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY THE SUSPECT WAS
ARRESTED AND BOOKED. FOR
ATTEMPTED MURDER SHOOTING AT AN
OCCUPIED VEHICLE AND ASSAULT
WITH A DEADLY WEAPON. FOR MOTOR
. THE CHP'S HIGHWAY VIOLENCE
TASK FORCE SUCCESS WILL BE
MEASURED THROUGH STATISTICAL
METRICS. CONCERNING VIOLENT
CRIME INCIDENTS AS WELL AS
CRIMINAL APPREHENSION AND
PROSECUTIONS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU COMMISSIONER OF FINANCE
PLEASE. WE SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL
AS PRESENTED BY TO SEE THREE.
THANK YOU THE L. A. O.'S OFFICE
PLEASE. THANK YOU CHAIR THIS IS
EUNICE ROAD THE L. A. L. AND WE
HAVE A COUPLE OF COMMENTS WITH
REGARDS TO THIS PROPOSAL. AND TO
THE EXTENT THAT THE LEGISLATURE
CONSIDERS HIGHWAY VIOLENCE A
PRIORITY AND ONCE YOU GET TO
KEEP THE SAME OVER ALL AMOUNT OF
RESOURCES AS THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSES. WE RECOMMEND MODIFYING
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IN WAYS
TO ENSURE THE FUNDED ACTIVITIES
WILL BE MOST EFFECTIVE AT
MEETING THEIR OBJECTIVES. SEVEN
BILLION RICK RECOMMENDS THE
FOLLOWING THE FIRST WE RECOMMEND
THE LEGISLATURE CONSIDER OPTIONS
THAT RESEARCHERS FOUND TO BE
EFFECTIVE AT REDUCING VIOLENT
CRIME. FOR EXAMPLE RESEARCHERS
HAVE FOUND THAT CERTAIN
INFRASTRUCTURE MODIFICATIONS
SUCH AS INSTALLATION OF CAMERAS
OR LIGHTING CAN REDUCE CRIME
WITHOUT REQUIRING ADDITIONAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT PRESENCE. THESE
TYPES OF SOLUTIONS MIGHT BE MORE
EFFICIENT ALTERNATIVES COMPARED
TO FUNDING OVER TIME AS PROPOSED
BY THE ADMINISTRATION. GIVEN
THAT CHP IS EXPERIENCING VERY
HIGH RATES OF SPEED CONCEIVED AS
IS NOT FULLY STAFFED CURRENTLY.
IN ORDER TO EFFECTIVELY WAIVE
THE TRADE OFFS OF THE DIFFERENT
ALTERNATIVES THE LEGISLATURE
COULD REQUEST THAT SEES PSS
SPECIFIC ALTERNATIVES AND
PRESENT A MODIFIED PROPOSAL
LATER THIS SPRING. SECOND WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVED A PROPOSED FUNDING FOR
THE SEVEN ASSOCIATE GOVERNMENTAL
PROGRAM ANALYST POSITIONS AS
WELL AS THE TRAINING I. T. AND
EQUIPMENT COSTS TO SUPPORT
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATIONS. WE FIND
THAT THESE ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
COULD HELP PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION. REGARDING THE
ASSOCIATED FACTORS OF HIGHWAY
SHOOTINGS AND HELP INFORM FUTURE
LEGISLATIVE POLICY AND FUNDING
DECISIONS REGARDING THE TASK
FORCE. THIRD WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE CHANGED THE FUNDS
SOURCE OF THIS PROPOSAL FROM THE
GENERAL FUND TO THE MOTOR
VEHICLE ACCOUNT. GIVEN THAT THIS
PROPOSAL IS INTENDED TO DIRECTLY
BENEFIT THE USERS OF THE STATE
HIGHWAY SYSTEM IT WOULD BE MORE
APPROPRIATE TO USE SEVENTY EIGHT
FOR THESE ACTIVITIES. AND
FINALLY WE RECOMMENDED REQUIRING
REPORTING C. ABER CLIENT
REQUIRING CHP TO REPORT ON THAT
NUMBER AND LOCATIONS OF HIGHWAY
SHOOTINGS. HE SAYS HE TO FACTORS
IN THE SHOOTINGS AS WELL AS THE
OUTCOMES OF THE INVESTIGATIVE
RESOURCE SAYS. THIS REPORT WOULD
ALLOW THE LEGISLATURE DID THE
TERRORISTS DETERMINE WHETHER
FUTURE AND THAT RESOURCES ARE
NEEDED TO CONTINUE THE TASK
FORCE AFTER. THE PROPOSED
FUNDING EXPIRES. AND THAT
CONCLUDES OUR COMMENTS THANK YOU
FOR. OR A HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. EIGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- COMMISSIONER OF DO YOU
HAVE ANY RESPONSE TO THE ISSUES
THAT WERE RAISED THE COMMENTS BY
THE LA- OF JURIES. THREE OR FOUR
YOU DON'T HAVE DOUBTS ALL OF
THEM BUT TO A DEGREE YOU CAN
COMMENT ON THAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL. THANK YOU SENATOR FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY AND NETWORK OF
ALL THINGS THAT THAT JUMPED OUT
AT ME THERE YOU KNOW THE- THE
RESEARCH AND OTHER TECHNOLOGIES
OR RESOURCES ARE AVAILABLE- THE
AUDIO YOU SEE EXAMPLE OF-
CAMERAS WE TOO ARE LOOKING AT
THOSE OPTIONS AND THEY ARE
VIABLE OPTIONS. THAT- ARE
PROBABLY A LITTLE MORE DOWN THE
ROAD AS WE ADDRESS THIS ISSUE-
WE FEEL VERY STRONGLY THAT THERE
IS NO REPLACEMENT FOR JUST IN
DEEPER TROUBLE HAVING THE BLACK
AND WHITE A PATROL CAR AND
HAVING THE UNIFORMED OFFICER ON
THE BEACH AND THAT DETERS. AND
DETECTS A CRIME WHAT IS
HAPPENING AND QUITE HONESTLY
PREVENTS A LOT OF PEOPLE FOR
MAKING THOSE CHOICES SO- FOR THE
NEED RIGHT NOW WE FEEL LIKE
THERE'S NO BETTER THINGS TO DO
THAN TO GET MORE OFFICERS ON THE
BEAT- WE ARE ADDRESS AND YOU
KNOW WE ARE EXPERIENCING SOME
VACANCY ISSUES WITH OUR
OFFICERS. AND WE'RE GONNA TALK A
LITTLE BT OF THAT AND ANOTHER
PROPOSAL IS COMING OUT BUT- THE
OVERTIME IS A VIABLE RESOURCE
THAT'S AVAILABLE TO GET THE
OFFICER ON THE BEAT TO GET THAT
PLANE YOU PATROL. I'M TO THE
POINT OF REPORTING WERE HAPPY TO
DO THAT WE'VE BEEN TRACKING THIS
INFORMATION ALREADY SO WE'RE
HAPPY TO SHARE THAT INFORMATION
REPORT. THE INFORMATION AS IT
COMES AVAILABLE. I THINK THERE
WAS ANOTHER. QUESTION OF WHY-
THE NBA. I AM NOT THE GENERAL.
YEAH I COULD DEFERRED OF FINANCE
ON THAT ONE BACK OKAY. THE AT
THE MCLEOD DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
THIS WAS AN ADMINISTRATION
PRIORITY AND THEREFORE WE FUNDED
FROM GENERAL FUND. OKAY. IT DOES
COMING FROM THE- MBA DOES THAT
MAKE IT LESS OF A PRIORITY I'M
NOT QUITE SURE I UNDERSTAND.
WHAT YOU MEAN BY THAT. HOW DOES
IT MAKE IT A LESSER A PRIORITY
IF IT'S MBA. A MINUTE I'M NOT
KALRA FINANCED I DON'T KNOW IF
IT'S A MATTER OF A GREATER OR
LESSER PRIORITY SO MUCH AS IT
IS- WITH THE FUNDS OR IS
AVAILABLE FROM THE- AND TO PUT
IT ON THE BILL FROM THE GENERAL
FUND. I DIDN'T EDUCATION FELT IT
WAS APPROPRIATE TO USE THOSE
RESOURCES FOR- TO ADDRESS. THERE
IS EXPERIENCING. OKAY. IT COULD
BE COMMISSIONER THERE WERE A
COUPLE OF OTHER QUESTIONS- WITH
THE PROPOSED OF SOFTWARE TOOLS-
HOW DO YOU ENSURE THAT PRIVACY
AND CIVIL LIBERTIES ARE.
INCLUDED IN THAT. SET OF TOOLS.
YEAH THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION AND
THAT'S A CONCERN THAT WE TAKE
VERY SERIOUSLY AS WELL THESE
TOOLS ARE WOULD BE- IF THE IF I
CAN EXPLAIN JUST A LAYMAN'S
TERMS IT'S JUST REALLY A
CLEARINGHOUSE OF DATA AND
INFORMATION THAT WE WOULD
ALREADY HAVE AVAILABLE TO US-
CONDUCTING OUR INVESTIGATIONS
BUT IT ALLOWS US TO. COMPARE AND
SHARE THAT INFORMATION AND
IDENTIFY TRENDS SO ONE OF THE
ADVANTAGES THAT THE DEPARTMENT
HAS THIS WEEK WE ARE STATEWIDE
AGENCY SO WE'RE ABLE TO USE THAT
INFORMATION AND SHARE LITTLE
DETAILS THAT ARE ALREADY
AVAILABLE TO US IN A CASE THAT
WERE INVESTIGATING GOLDEN GATE
DIVISION IN THE BAY AREA. WITH A
SIMILAR INCIDENT THAT HAPPENED
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA ALLOW US
TO MAKE THOSE CONNECTIONS AS WE
INVESTIGATE THESE CRIMES SO THE
PRIVACY AND PROTECTION OF THE
CITIZENS IS UTMOST IMPORTANCE TO
US AND- ALL OF THE TOOLS THAT WE
USE WOULD BE. BOUND BY THEIR
ALREADY STATUTORY SCHEMES THAT
WE FOLLOW UP WITH OTHER WITH
OTHER INVESTIGATORY TOOLS.
RELATED TO IT. OKAY SENATORS YES
SENATE QUARTERS A- THANK YOU
MANAGER I JUST WANNA SAY I
DIDN'T FEEL LIKE YOUR QUESTION
WAS ADEQUATELY ANSWERED
REGARDING THE TO FUNDS THAT THE
L. A. SUGGESTION ABOUT GOING TO
THE MOTOR VEHICLE FUND IT IT
SEEMS TO ME THAT AT LEAST SOME
OF THIS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
POSITIONS INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
AND EQUIPMENT. AT A MINIMUM SOME
OF IT WOULD IT WOULD COME OUT OF
THE- MP AND I JUST SAY TO THE-
TO THE COMMISSIONER- I MEAN THE
CONCERN WITH GENERAL FUND IS
GENERAL FUND COMES GENERAL FUND
GOES IN THIS IS. NOT SOMETHING
THAT YOU WANT TO HELP ON THE
CHOPPING BLOCK AT SOME. POINT IN
THE IN THE NEAR FUTURE AFTER YOU
GET- GET YOURSELF BUILT UP- WE
DON'T KNOW THAT WOULD BE THE
CASE BUT IT SEEMS LIKE THE MOTOR
VEHICLE PHONE MIGHT BE A MORE.
STABLE FUND- GOING FORWARD-
QUESTION I HAVE IS REALLY. GIVE
ME WE DON'T REALLY HAVE A
BREAKDOWN OR MIKE CAN ASK FOR
THAT IN TERMS OF EQUIPMENT
TECHNOLOGY AND POSITIONS I DO
AGREE. THAT YOU WOULD NEED
POSITIONS IN OVERTIME. EVEN IF
YOU HAD TECHNOLOGY BECAUSE
SOMEBODY'S GOT TO GO THROUGH THE
TECHNOLOGY INTO THE- DISTANCE OF
THE DETECTIVE WORK TO FIGURE
OUT. WHAT'S ON THOSE CAMERAS
BUT- I GUESS I WANNA ASK ARE
THERE WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT TRENDS
- ARE THERE IDENTIFIED TRENDS
JUST IN THE LOGISTICS OF WHAT'S
HAPPENING I DON'T MY MIND WANTS
TO TELL ME THAT. YOU KNOW IN
TERMS OF THE SHOOTING DEATHS- IN
THIS. THE DISCOUNTS TASKFORCE'S
IS LOOKING AT IT THERE WOULD
LIKELY BE ON COMING TRAFFIC
THERE WOULD LIKELY BE PEOPLE IN-
PERCHED IN A- YOU KNOW ON COMING
TRAFFIC POSITIONED OVER PASSES
THINGS LIKE THAT I'M NOT ASKING
YOU TO GIVE UP. INFORMATION THAT
WOULD PUT. THE STATED
DISADVANTAGED INVESTIGATING
THINGS BUT I'M REALLY JUST
ASKING ORDERED. TO TRANSLATE
THAT THAT YOU HAVE IDENTIFIED AT
THIS POINT UP AND DOWN THE STATE
THAT ARE THAT ARE CONSISTENT IN
THE REASON I ASK THAT IS BECAUSE
IN THE FUTURE- IT MAY MAKE SENSE
ESPECIALLY. WITH THE
INFRASTRUCTURE MONEY THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO EMPHASIZE WITH A
CONVERSATION EARLIER. YOU KNOW
MAYBE THERE SHOULD BE CAPITAL
IMPROVEMENTS- IT ON THE HIGHWAY
SYSTEM IN IN A MORE SIGNIFICANT
MANNER THAT TIED TO THE TRANSIT
YOUR SCENE BUT I GUESS THE FIRST
QUESTION IS. DO YOU HAVE THAT
KIND OF DATA. THROUGH GOOD COST
. CENTER IS AN EXCELLENT
QUESTION AND I APPRECIATE YOUR-
RECOGNITION OF THE SENSITIVITY
OF SOME OF THE INFORMATION THAT
WE MAY HAVE AVAILABLE AND HOW IT
MIGHT JEOPARDIZE. FUTURE
INVESTIGATIONS OR QUITE FRANKLY
SOMETIMES A ENCOURAGE COME ALIVE
TIVITY SO- I WILL ANSWER THAT
THERE ARE DEFINITELY TRANSIT WE
HAVE FOUND IN REGARDS TO
LOCATION OF WHERE THESE CRIMES
ARE HAPPENING AND THEN ALSO
COMMON TRENDS- NGUYEN IN REGARDS
TO- SOME OF THEM BEING GANG
RELATED AND OTHERS- I MEAN OUT
OF ROAD RAGE INCIDENTS. SO THOSE
ARE DIFFERENT TRANSIT WE ARE
FOUND AND- THERE ARE- LOCATIONS
FOR IT SEEMS LIKE A HIGHER
NUMBER OF THESE ARE HAPPENING
THAT WOULD LIKE TO FOCUS OUR
EFFORTS AND SO THERE ARE
DEFINITE TRENDS THAT- THAT AS
FAR AS LOCATION IN THE TYPES OF
THINGS THAT LEAD UP TO THE
SENSOR THAT'S OCCURRING.
WOODBINE I FOR ONE WOULD
ENCOURAGE YOU TO. ASSUMING THIS
ITEM IS FUNDED APPROVED AND
FUNDED- MANY HAVE THE ADDITIONAL
A PERSONAL IN ADDITIONAL
POSITIONS SAID PART OF THEIR
ASSIGNMENT GOING FORWARD WOULD
BE TO PUT TOGETHER A MORE
ROBUST. OF PUBLIC INVESTMENT IN
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WOULD ASSIST
OUR EFFORTS SO THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS THE OPPORTUNITY
TO. IN ORDER TO. CONSIDER THAT
AT SOME POINT I DON'T THINK IT'S
SOMETHING THAT LEGISLATORS COULD
- WOULD HAVE ENOUGH INFORMATION
ON TO. TO TRY TO DRAFT THAT KIND
OF SUPPORT YOU KNOW IN A PIECE
OF LEGISLATION FROM WHOLE CLOTH
YOU KNOW IT WOULD ALMOST HAVE TO
COME- FROM YOU FOLKS A MORE
PROBABLY MORE VERTICALLY FROM
THE TASK FORCE SO. BUT AGAIN I
WOULD JUST ENCOURAGE SAID TO BE
PART OF WHAT THIS TEST FOR DUST
TASK FORCE DOES GOING FORWARD.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CENTER-
THANK YOU- EVERYONE WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE ON TO ISSUE NINETEEN
WHICH IS INCREASED FUNDING FOR
RECRUITMENT ADVERTISING
COMMISSIONER. THANK YOU SENATOR
HOW THE DEPARTMENTS REQUESTING
TWO MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY
FROM THE MOTOR VEHICLE COUNT FOR
THREE YEARS TO SUPPORT OUR
RECRUITMENT EFFORTS- FUNDING
WOULD SUPPORT THE INCREASED COST
OF ADVERTISING CAMPAIGNS EXPAND
THE SCOPE OF RECRUITMENT EFFORTS
AND IMPROVE DIVERSITY
INCLUSIVENESS ONE ADVERTISING-
THE CHP IS COMMITTED TO
IDENTIFYING THE HIGHEST QUALITY
CANDIDATES WITH DIVERSE LANGUAGE
SKILLS AND CULTURAL
COMPETENCIES. AND WHO REPRESENT
CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE DEMOGRAPHIC
MAKE UP HOWEVER AS WE ARE ALL
AWARE RECRUITMENT OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT PERSONNEL HAS BEEN
DECLINING ON A NATIONAL LEVEL
AND UNFORTUNATELY THE CG IS NOT
IMMUNE TO THIS TREND. MEANINGFUL
EFFORTS TO RECRUIT HIRE AND
RETAIN OFFICERS JUST CRITICAL TO
PUBLIC SAFETY ADVERTISING TO THE
PUBLIC IS THE FIRST STEP IN THE
RECRUITMENT PROCESS THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD PROVIDE THE CHP
WITH THE NECESSARY FUNDING TO
ENGAGE ADVERTISING EXPERTISE
DIGITAL AND PROGRAMMATIC
MARKETING AND SECONDARY
ADVERTISING TO REMAIN
COMPETITIVE AND I'M PRESIDENT IN
EVER CHANGING MARKET PLACE. I
SHOULD NOTE THAT THIS PROPOSAL
IS BUILT ON SOME EXPERIENCE THAT
WE HAVEN'T IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN THE SIEGE RETESTED A
STATEWIDE ALL DIGITAL MARKETING
CAMPAIGN WITH OUTSTANDING
RESULTS IN DECEMBER IN DECEMBER
OF TWENTY NINETEEN AT THE ONSET.
OF THE CAMPAIGN THE CHP RECEIVED
JUST UNDER NINE HUNDRED
APPLICATIONS THE NUMBER OF
APPLICATIONS INCREASED
INCREMENTALLY INCREMENTALLY
MONTH OVER MONTH DURING THE
CAMPAIGN WHICH ENDED UP WITH
NEARLY SIXTEEN HUNDRED
APPLICATIONS. RECEIVED IN JUNE
OF TWENTY TWENTY. HOWEVER CHIANG
TO MAY MARC ADVERTISING. HAVE
FORCED THE PRICE OF DIGITAL
MARKETING TO RECORD LEVELS
ACROSS THE STATE AND NATION. FOR
THE C. H. P. THE DIGITAL
MARKETING CAMPAIGNS HAVE
SUCCESSFULLY REACHED OVER THREE
POINT ONE MILLION. POTENTIAL
APPLICANTS AND ARE RESPONSIBLE
FOR PRICING 80% OF THE TOTAL
APPLICATIONS WE RECEIVED. THESE
PROGRAMS ARE PROVEN TO BE THE
BEST AND MOST EFFICIENT USE OF
RESOURCES. AND PROVIDE FOR THE
HIGHEST RETURN ON INVESTMENT IN
THE FORM OF CANDIDATE
APPLICATIONS. FINALLY THE
REQUESTED BUDGET INCREASE WOULD
SUPPORT BRINGING NEW OFFICERS
AND SUPPORT PERSONNEL INTO THE
DEPARTMENT THEREBY REDUCING THE
NEED FOR OVERTIME TO MAINTAIN
SERVICE LEVELS TO THE
COMMUNITIES WE SERVE. WITH THIS
PROPOSAL THE CHP'S GOAL IS TO
INCREASE APPLICATIONS BY AT
LEAST 50% OVER THE PAST THREE
YEAR AVERAGE OF APPROXIMATELY
THIRTEEN THOUSAND APPLICATIONS.
ADDITIONALLY AS RECENTLY
MENTIONED BY COMMISSIONER RAY WE
ASPIRE TO RECRUIT AND HIRE A
THOUSAND NEW OFFICERS TO CLOSE
OUR CURRENT VACANCY RATE. WE
BELIEVE THIS PROPOSAL WILL HELP
US ATTAIN THAT GOAL ALLOW US TO
RECRUIT A DIVERSE WORK FORCE
THAT REPRESENTS OUR GREAT STATE
AND CONTINUE TO BE A LEADER IN
LAW ENFORCEMENT THROUGH
PROFESSIONALISM. DIVERSITY AND
INCLUSION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- THE FINANCE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO COMMENT. AT THE MCLEOD
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WE HAVE NO
COMMENT. THANK YOU LL'S OFFICE
PLEASE. IN THIS ROW AT THE L. A.
AND WE HAVE NO ISSUES WITH THIS
PROPOSAL. THANK YOU BOB
COMMISSIONER HAVE A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS IT SEEMS THAT YOU
BECAUSE OF THE STATEWIDE DIGITAL
CAMPAIGN THAT YOU SORT OF
DOUBLED IT LOOKS LIKE ALMOST
ALMOST DOUBLED THE NUMBER OF
APPLICATIONS- IN ACTUALLY LESS
THAN A YEAR- WOULD YOU STILL
HAVE CURRENTLY OF ELEVEN HUNDRED
VACANT UNIFORMED POSITIONS SO
HOW IS THE HOW IS THE
ADVERTISING AND THE RECEIPT OF
SO MANY MORE APPLICATIONS. HOW
DID THAT HELP WITH THE OUTCOME
OF ACTUALLY FILLING THE
POSITIONS. S. A GOOD QUESTION
SENATOR- YOU JUST PICKED UP. A
NUMBER THAT YOU SHOULD KNOW IT
IT TAKES TWENTY TWO APPLICANTS
CITY TO YIELD ONE CADET IN OUR
CATEGORY- SO WHAT TO FILL THE
THOUSAND VACANCIES WE NEED OVER
TWENTY TWO THOUSAND APPLICANTS
TO TAKE CARE OF THOSE THOUSAND
AGENCIES BUT- THAT'S JUST ONE
PART OF THE PROGRAM THAT. WE'RE
WORKING ON THAT WE REALLY LOOKED
AT IT A THREE PRONGED APPROACH
WE- INCREASING EFFICIENCIES AT
OUR ACADEMY TO ALLOW US TO
MAXIMIZE THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
THAT WE CAN GET THROUGH AN
AMOUNT OF TIME. WE ARE ARE
LOOKING AT EFFICIENCIES THAT WE
CAN CHANGE IMPROVE AND THE
BACKGROUND PROCESS TO MINIMIZE
THE AMOUNT OF TIME THAT
APPLICANTS ARE IN THE BACKGROUND
PROCESS AND THE THIRD PART ONCE
YOU CLEAR OUT THAT BACKGROUND
POOL IS TO RECRUIT AND THAT'S
WHERE THIS PROPOSAL COMES AND AS
JUST. INVESTING IN THE
RECRUITMENT PROCESS AND GET IN
AS MANY. CANDIDATES TO THE POSTS
WE CAN. AND HOW IT THAT THIS GUY
. HELPS WHAT WHAT IS IT ABOUT
THE CAMPAIGN THAT YOU FEEL. BOND
MAKES IT CHANCES OF. INCREASING
THE RECRUITMENT RATE AND
EVENTUALLY OF FILLING THE
POSITIONS WHAT IS IT ABOUT THIS
CAMPAIGN THAT HELPS TO GET THEIR
- YEAH I THINK THE DIGITAL
MARKETING CAMPAIGN HELPS US
REACH THE PEOPLE THAT THAT WE
NEED TO. AND HE GETS OUTSIDE OF
TRADITIONAL THINGS WE'VE USED IN
THE PAST WITH RADIOS AND
BILLBOARDS AND DIGITAL MARKETING
CAMPAIGN ALLOWS US TO. BE A
LITTLE MORE TARGET SPECIFIC WITH
THE APPLICANTS THAT WERE LOOKING
TO REACH OUT TO AND RECRUIT INTO
A CAREER WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT.
OKAY ALL RIGHT- THAT'S IT FOR ME
. THE SENATORS ANYMORE QUESTIONS
HELLO. I DO HAVE A QUESTION OKAY
SENATOR THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR
THE COMMISSION BUT I WANT TO
REITERATE THE CHAIR'S COMMENTS
THANK YOU- AND YOUR YOUR
PERSONAL FOR DOING SUCH A
WONDERFUL JOB IN THE COUNCIL'S
FISHING DURING WHAT HAS BEEN AN
INTERESTING YEAR ABOUT MY
QUESTION IS SORT OF THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE RECRUITING. QUESTION
WHICH IS ABOUT RETENTION- AND SO
YOU KNOW VERY BRIEFLY- WILL YOU
KNOW WHAT'S THE STATE OF PLAY
AROUND THOUGHT CHP OFFICER
RETENTION- AND YEAH I AGREE THIS
IS SORT OF BEYOND THE SCOPE OF
THIS BUT IF YOU WOULDN'T MIND
BRIEFLY WHAT WHAT CAN WE THE
LEGISLATURE TO BE DOING IN
SUPPORT. OF YOUR RETENTION
EFFORTS. I APPRECIATE THAT
BECAUSE CENTER- I HAVE TO GIVE
THAT SOME THOUGHT AND DEFINITELY
GET BACK TO YOU ON WHAT YOU
COULD DO TO HELP US I COULD GIVE
YOU SOME. SOME NUMBERS JUST
GENERALLY SPEAKING- LAST YEAR WE
LOST ABOUT THIRTY THREE OFFICERS
A MONTH NOW. A LOT OF THOSE ARE
JUST. NORMAL ATTRITION WITH-
RETIREMENTS AND- BUT THERE ARE
OTHER ISSUES THERE ARE SOME JEWS
IN NYC TO GO. OTHER PLACES AND
WORK WITH OTHER DEPARTMENTS OR
LEAVE LAW ENFORCEMENT AS A WHOLE
SO- WE'RE WE'RE WORKING TOWARDS-
TOWARDS THAT ISSUE. AND WE'LL
GIVE IT SOME THOUGHT AND I
DEFINITELY APPRECIATE THE
SUPPORT AND PER SHOULD THE
COMMENTS OF SUPPORT THANK YOU-
AND I APPRECIATE. WHAT YOU DO IS
HAVE YOU KNOW GLAD BE PART OF
THE CONVERSATION I CAN'T IN ANY
WAY. OKAY GREAT THANK YOU FOR
THAT I WE MOVE ON TO ISSUE
TWENTY WHICH IS THE I. T.
BASELINE COST INCREASE
COMMISSIONER. THANK YOU SENATOR
HATCH I THINK THIS IS OUR LAST
ISSUE FOR YOU IN THIS EACH PIECE
REQUESTED A ONE TIME FUNDING OF
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS IN FY
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE FROM THE
NBA TO COVERED INCREASED
TECHNOLOGY COSTS. AS THE CB
CONTINUES TO IMPROVE SERVICE AND
SAFETY TO CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
NEW TECHNOLOGIES AND PROGRAMS
THE DEPARTMENT HAS EXPERIENCED
AN INCREASE IN I COST MORE
SPECIFICALLY THE DEPARTMENT
CONTINUES TO LEVERAGE NEW
TECHNOLOGIES TO ENHANCE
EFFICIENCIES AND BETTER MEET THE
NEEDS OF THE PUBLIC. THESE NEW
TECHNOLOGY SOLUTIONS RESULT IN
IMPROVED DELIVERY OF PUBLIC
SAFETY AND SERVICE TO THOSE WHO
RESIDE IN TRAVEL WITH IN
CALIFORNIA. THE BASELINE COSTS
FOR THESE TECHNOLOGIES INCLUDE
BUT ARE NOT NECESSARILY LIMITED
TO THINGS LIKE OUR COMPUTER
AIDED DISPATCH SYSTEM THE
STATEWIDE NETWORK UPGRADES
SOFTWARE LICENSING STATEWIDE
WIRELESS INSTALLATIONS AND MOTOR
REPLACEMENTS DISASTER RECOVERY
PRIVACY AND RISK MANAGEMENT
CYBERSECURITY AND THREAT
ASSESSMENT AND CLOUD COMPUTING.
IN ALIGNMENT WITH THE DEPARTMENT
STRATEGIC PLAN AND TO MEET
CURRENT FEDERAL AND STATE
TECHNOLOGY REQUIREMENTS TO CBS
CONTINUALLY UPDATING OUR IT
INFRASTRUCTURE IN ORDER TO
INCREASE NETWORK SECURITY
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL ONLINE
SERVICES TO THE PUBLIC AND
PROVIDE OFFICERS WITH TECHNOLOGY
BASED TOOLS THAT ENABLE THEM TO
DEDICATE MORE TIME TO MISSION
CRITICAL DUTIES. THIS BUDGET
AUGMENTATION WILL ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT TO COVER INCREASED
COMPUTING SUPPORT COSTS AND
COMPLETE NECESSARY IT PROJECTS
FOR THE IMPROVEMENT OF PUBLIC
SAFETY AND SERVICES. ALTHOUGH
THE LIST OF I. T. SERVICES AND
PRODUCTS PROVIDED IN THE B. C.
B. S. LENGTHY IT REFLECTS AN
INCREASE OF APPROXIMATELY
THIRTEEN POINT THREE MILLION IN. BASELINE COST OVER THE LAST
DECADE. THE TABLE AND B. C. P.
OUR DOES NOT INCLUDE OF TO A
EFFORT. OR FUTURE PROJECTS UNDER
DEVELOPMENT ESTIMATED TO COST AN
ADDITIONAL ONE POINT SEVEN
MILLION. THE ONE POINT SEVEN
MILLION WILL FUND THE
MODERNIZATION OF THE CHP ACADEMY
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THE
VIRTUALISATION OF DIVISION AREA
OFFICES. ALSO IN THE PROPOSAL
SUPPORTS THIS FEATURE BE
STRATEGIC PLAN TO PROVIDE
QUALITY SERVICE TO ALL
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES ENHANCE
TRANSPORTATION SAFETY AND OBTAIN
TRANSPARENCY AND EFFECTIVE
REPORTING ON PERFORMANCE
OUTCOMES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- FINANCE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO COMMENT. ETHNIC CLASS
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO
COMMENTS THIS TIME. OKAY ALEJO'S
OFFICE LIKE TO COMMENT. IN THIS
ROAD THE L. A. I. WE HAVE NO
CONCERNS IT'S CHARLES ALL GREAT-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- I HAVE NO
PARTICULAR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
CENTER CRITICIZING SIR NEWMAN.
NO OKAY- WELL COMMISSIONER AND
ASSISTANT CHIEF ON LOTUS
APPRECIATE YOU COMING BEFORE US
ANSWERING ALL THESE QUESTIONS
AND- WE CERTAINLY TRY TO BE A
SUPPORTIVE OF YOUR NEEDS-
BECAUSE WE KNOW YOU'RE OUT THERE
TAKING CARE OF SO MANY
CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR BEING WITH US. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU FOR THE
SUPPORT. OKAY WE MOVE ON NOW TO-
ISSUE TWENTY ONE. ARE HAVING TO
DO WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR
VEHICLES THIS IS CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROPOSALS. RIGHT SURE AND COULD
NOT IMMERSED MY NAME IS THE
START CHIEF BUDGET OFFICER AT
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT MOTOR
VEHICLE STOP WITH ME TODAY IS
OUR DIRECTOR KEEP WARM. THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY FOR US
THE COMMITTEE TODAY THE PURPOSE
SIX ISSUES ON THE AGENDA- ELECT
PROVIDE A QUICK OVERVIEW. OF
EACH OF THEM WILL BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
MIGHT HAVE ABOUT FIVE PLUS
REQUESTED RELATED TO COP OUT
LIKE. THE FIRST REQUEST IS FOR
THE TV SOCCER HEADQUARTERS
BUILDING ELEVATOR REPLACEMENT
PROJECT. A DEVIOUS REQUESTING
EIGHT HUNDRED THIRTY THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM THE
GENERAL FUND TO FUND THE PRIMERA
PLAN FACE- THAT'S THREE HUNDRED
TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS AND THE
WORKING DRAWING PHASE WHICH IS
ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED THIRTEEN
THOUSAND. WITH TO YEAR
EXPIRATION DATE TO COMPLETE THE
ELEVATOR MODERNIZATION PROJECT
FOR THE DMV HEADQUARTERS CAMPUS
IN SACRAMENTO OF THIS CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECT WILL
MODERNIZE ELEVEN H. ELEVATORS
ONE CHAIR STAIR CLIMBER I
INCLINED PLATFORM LIFTS. AND THE
RELATED ELEVATOR MACHINERY HAVE
THEIR CONTROLS IN BOTH THE DMV
HEADQUARTERS BUILDING PIECE
WHICH IS ABOUT SIX YEARS OLD AT
THE BUILDING BUS WHICH ABOUT
SEVENTY YEAR OLD SEX. TAKE A
PAUSE THERE DOES IT DO YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT THE FIRST
ONE. NO SIR JUST ARM YOU COULD
PROBABLY MOVED. THROUGH ALL OF
THEM. YEAH OF THE NEXT REQUEST
IS THE L. CENTRO BRAWLEY FIELD
OFFICE. ENCOURAGE TRY TO
SURPRISE. DEVIOUS FOR. THREE
POINT ONE MILLION THE GENERAL
FUND I IN TWENTY TWO TO THREE
TO. THAT WAS PHASE OF THE
DEERFIELD. PROBABLY LOCATION.
BOB THIS. WILL CONSULT THE SO
PUBLIC FIELD OFFICE IN A Y.
COULD FALL SITE. THAT WILL
ADDRESS COULD FISCAL
INFRASTRUCTURE DEFICIENCY CO
DEFICIENT. AND IMPROVE CUSTOMER
SIR. THIS REQUEST COULD A DRY
SEE TED TO FISH. IN THIS AREA.
THAT'S THE REQUEST FOR BY TIMELY
CDL REYES AND IN DEBATE AND YET
THE HOUSE COMMITTED EXPAND CITY
OF SERVICES IN EXCESS AFTER
JEWEL CASE. THE CURRENT GOAL SO
- OFFICE HAS LOW OF THE TO OFF
ADDITIONAL CITY TEST. MICHAEL
MICHAEL INTEREST TO FISH. OUT
THIS- SHALL CENTRO AS HEAD OF
STATE COMMUNITIES ARE GROWING AT
CENTRO BUILD OFFICES I ABLE TO
THE KERN NEEDS OF THE
ANTICIPATED GROWTH THE POP. THE
NEAREST DMV COMMERCIAL TETER-
CENTER IS LOOKING R. RANCHO
DIEGO WHICH IS A MULTI TO SORT
WHICH SERVES INDUSTRY I CUSSED
AND IS UP A HUNDRED MILES AWAY
FROM ALSO. THIS NURSES AS HE
TEST IS IN FONTANA WHICH LOCATED
ABOUT SIX FIVE MY FROM CENTRO TO
THE GROWTH OF THE ALSO AREA
GEOGRAPHICAL ICE FROM OTHER
CITIES SIDES AN INCREASE IN THE
TO SERVE ACROSS TRUCKING
INDUSTRY I JUST CRITICAL IT
APART SEE CULTURE TO THE EXTENT
USES LIKE. BUT THURMOND IS A
REQUEST FOR THE- HILL FIELD THE
RELOCATION FROM. DEVIOUS
REQUESTING ONE FOR TWO. AND
TWENTY TWO THREE. ONE POINT
EIGHT MILLION AND TWENTY TWENTY.
AND ONE ONE NINE BY TO TWENTY
TWENTY IN OUR- TRY NEW. LOOK
GOOD HILLS OFFICE DUE TO THE
LOSS THE LEAST THE CURRENT. THIS
FUNDING ALLOWED TO GIVE YOU
CONTINUE SERVING GENERAL. AND
MEETING. IN CUSTOMER. DUE TO THE
RELY DEADLINE. BY THE FUNDING OF
THOUGHT TO REACH WILL BE. OF DUE
CUSTOMER OVER AND THE SERRANO US. NUMBER FOUR. DIRECT IS FOR THE
FEDERAL AND- IN. THE RELOCATE
PROJECT. DBS FOR. FIFTY DOLLARS
IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY SIX HUNDRED
AND SIXTY AND TWENTY THREE
TWENTY AND HOW EIGHTEEN INTO
FOUR TO FIVE AND AUG TO COULD
SEE AND RELOOK THE LIGHT
INVESTIGATIONS DISTRICT AND TOOK
ONE OUT. THE VILLAGE
INVESTIGATIONS OFFICE DOES NOT
HAVE THIS REQUIRE TO HOUSE THE
ENTIRE VALLEJO IN THE DISTRICT.
CURRENTLY THERE ARE TEN EMPLOY
TO SIGN TO THE WHITE HOWEVER
THREE ARE LOCATED IN A SUBTLE
OFFICE AND SO ROSA. AND GAVE
FIELD OFFICES TO SPACE
CONSTRAINTS AT THE LOW OFFICE
THIS REQUEST- RELOCATE BELL
STYLE INTO ONE CONSOLE LOOK
WHICH WILL IT THE TO BE MORE
USUALLY JUST SHOULD. CASE. TO
APPROPRIATELY PROVIDE
STREAMLINED PROCESS. USED HIGH
WORKERS. PROVIDE MENTAL OVER
TRAIN AND DELIVER. TIMELY SO TO
BOTH INTO AND CUSTOMERS THIS
REAL WILL THE BY A THE OFFICE TO
YOUR- VACATED SPACE FIELD OFFICE
SPACE TO FISH. AT THE LAST COUNT
BUT LABOR IS THIS WHY PLAN AND
SITE IDENTIFICATION FUNDS. TVS
ARE SIX DOLLARS DOLLARS FROM
GENERAL BY TO PERFORM ADVANCED
PLANNING AND I TO PARTS TO RIP
CHIEF OFFICE. PROJECT INTENSE
DOUBLE STUDIES FOR THE GOT ROOF
. WHETHER ON SITE OR AS WE OF A
SUCCESSFUL SITE SEARCH AND UP
THREE RE- PROJECT. I WILL PAUSE
THERE. THANK YOU SCOTT OF
FINANCEANY COMMON. RANDY KATZ
SAID THE PART OF FINANCE WE HAVE
NO CONCERNS I'LL JUST NOTE THAT
WE USE THE SAME STRATEGY ON
DETERMINING NBA FIRST AS GENERAL
FUND SO NDA FOR LEASE AND
GENERAL FUND THE SAME STRATEGY
THAT WAS APPLIED WITH CHP. I
THANK YOU. HELLO WOULD YOU LIKE
TO COMMENT. IN THIS ROW AT THE
L. A. L. WE HAVE NO CONCERNS
WITH THIS PROPOSAL THANK
SENATORS. COMMENTS CENTER
COURTESY DISK I'M JUST CURIOUS-
ON ON THE NEW BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION AND I THINK THIS IS
THE PRIME READING THIS WRITER
HEARING IT READ IT MIGHT BE
JUST- NUMBER TWO. THE SECOND
BULLET POINT- IN MY NOTES-
CENTER BRAWLEY BUT ARE THESE
BUILDINGS BEING- SPECT OUT HIS
NET ZERO BUILDINGS NOW. TELL ME
IF YOU DON'T MIND I'LL I'LL TAKE
THE FIRST QUESTION SO SENATOR HI
STEVE MARTIN DIRECTOR CALIFORNIA
VEHICLES. CURRENTLY WE ARE- YOU
SEEN A RENTED FACILITY IN
BRAWLEY IT WAS CONVERTED OUT
FROM I THINK AN AUTO PARTS STORE
SO I DON'T BELIEVE THAT IT
ACTUALLY NEEDS. THOSE THAT LEVEL
OF- A CERTIFICATION- AND THE
PROBABLY FACILITY WAS BUILT YOU
KNOW HAS YOU HEARD FROM OUR
FRIENDS IN THE C. SUITE WAS
BUILT IN NINETEEN SIXTY ISHE SO
I DON'T THINK IT FOLLOWS ANY OF
THE ANY OF THE STANDARD FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL CARE ENERGY
EFFICIENCY AND SO ON. BUT BUT
MANY OF OUR NEW OUR OFFICES DO
SO I THINK AS WE AS WE BUILDINGS
OUT THERE WHETHER THEY'RE BEASTS
OF THE GOLD CERTIFIED I THINK WE
ARE HEADED IN THAT DIRECTION FOR
MANY OF OUR NEWEST OFFICES- BUT
NOTHING NOT THE ONES THAT ARE IN
PLACE TODAY BECAUSE MANY OF MARK
DATED AND ONE AS I MENTIONED WAS
JUST RENT IT WAS JUST RECENTLY
OPENED. IN THAT FACILITY. AND
BROUGHT. THANK YOU FOR
CLARIFYING THE- THANK YOU. THE
NEW NO NO MARK. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ON ISSUE TO ONE REMOVED
LAST WEEK. ISSUE OUGHT TO TWO
WHICH- OF SUPPLY CHAIN WITH THE
COMMERCIAL LICENSE- MISTER SCOTT
. PICTURE SO YOU'RE CORRECT THE
LAST ISSUE S IN RELATION TO THE
SUPPLY CHAIN RESILIENCE PROPOSAL
AND ADDRESSING FUNDING- TO
INCREASE ACCESSIBILITY TO
COMMERCIAL DRIVER'S LICENSES TO
THE DMV HAS A REQUEST IN A
PROPOSAL SUBMITTED BY THE
SECRETARY OF TRANSPORTATION TO
SUPPORT THE SUPPLY CHAIN
INVESTMENTS IMPORT FREIGHT AND
GOODS. MOVEMENT STRUCTURE. AGAIN
DEANNE BECAUSE A OF MILLION TO
ENHANCE COUPLE COMPOUND IT
JUDICIARY BECAUSE PRECISE
INSISTS. THAT'S FUNNY INCLUDES
AND A HALF MILLION AND JUST YEAR
TWENTY TO TWENTY AND MILLION
ANNUALLY. THROUGH FIVE TWENTY
SIX TO FIND THE SCENE BECAUSE TO
ESTABLISH DEDICATED COMMERCIAL
DRIVE TEST CENTRES. IN BOTH THE
STEPS THE SCOPE AREA AND OR THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY. BUT IN
ADDITION IT'S PROPOSAL INCLUDES
ONE TIME FUNDING OF SIX NINE AND
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE TO FIND
OVERTIME ON SATURDAYS FOR
LICENSING REGISTRATION
EXAMINERS. UNNECESSARY SPORTS
STUFF WHICH WILL BE REDIRECTED
OR WILL BE DIRECTED TO CDL SITES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THAT HAVE
APPOINTMENT WAIT TIMES IN EXCESS
OF THIRTY DAYS. IT WILL ALSO
FUND OF SOCIO TRAVEL COSTS FOR
STAFF AND- FOR THESE EXPENSES-
OUT BUT THAT WE ARE HAPPY TO
ANSWER. ANY QUESTIONS PERTAINING
TO THIS REQUEST. OKAY FROM
FINANCE. ANY COMMENTS. THE
MISSOURI DEPARTMENT OF FINE- WE
SUPPORT THE- COM MADE THE IN THE
- OKAY AND- MISS ROW. THANK YOU
CHAIR I UNITS ROAD DELL'ANNO
THAT WE JUST HAVE A COUPLE OF
COMMENTS WITH REGARDS TO THIS
PROPOSAL FIRST WE RECOMMEND THE
PROPOSAL BE FUNDED THROUGH THE
NBA AND STATE OF THE GENERAL
FUND THE COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
ADDITIONAL AS WELL ARE DIRECTLY
RELATED TO PROCESSING COMMERCIAL
DRIVE TESTS WHICH THE STATE
COLLECTS A FEE TO SUPPORT.
SECOND WE RECOMMEND ONGOING AND
REQUIRING ONGOING REPORTING TO
GET A BETTER SENSE OF WHETHER
THE INCREASED WAIT TIMES FOR
COMMERCIAL DRIVE TEST WILL BE AN
ONGOING OR A ONE TIME ISSUE.
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION ON THE
DEMAND FOR COMMERCIAL DRIVER
LICENSES WOULD ALLOW THE
LEGISLATURE TO. DETERMINE
WHETHER I'M GOING FUNDING FOR
COMMERCIAL DRY SET TEST AND
THERE'S IS NEEDED BEYOND TWENTY
FIVE TWENTY SIX. AND THAT
CONCLUDES OUR COMMENTS HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS AS WELL. I
THANK YOU- SOMEWHAT ALONG THOSE
LINES. I HAVE A QUESTION IS HOW
DID YOU OR HOW OR WHAT
INFORMATION CAME TO YOUR
ATTENTION THAT- SOMEHOW THE DM
B. WAIT TIMES OR THE BOTTLE
NECK- FORGET THE MORE TRUCK
DRIVERS ON THE ROAD. WHAT WHAT
LED YOU TO OR ANYBODY TO THAT
CONCLUSION- I STEVE GORDON. ALL
STEP IN HERE AS DIRECTOR
CALIFORNIA FOR MOTOR VEHICLES-
SENATE I SHARE YOUR CONCERN- I
THINK MORE ONE PART OF THIS
ECOSYSTEM BUT A VERY IMPORTANT
PART OF THE ECOSYSTEM TO MAKE
SURE THAT AS DRIVERS ARE TRAINED
AT VARIOUS TRAINING SCHOOLS AND
SO ON THAT HAVE A CHANCE TO GET.
CERTIFIED CREDENTIAL HI
COMPLETES THEIR EXAMINATION SO
THEY GET ON THE ROAD I DON'T
THINK WERE THE ONLY PART OF THIS
ECOSYSTEM THAT IS THE BIG
CHALLENGE WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO
MAKE SURE WE CAN STEP UP AND
MAKE SURE DRIVERS ARE SORT OF
WHY WE DO HAVE AN AGING
POPULATION AND CALIFORNIANS CDL
HOLDERS CALIFORNIA COMMERCIAL
DRIVER HOLDERS. ARE OLDER THAN
THE POPULATION IN GENERAL AND
MATTER OF FACT YOU KNOW 60% OF
OUR CURRENCY HOLDERS ARE ABOVE
AGE FORTY FIVE. YOU KNOW 35% OR
ABOVE AGE FIFTY FIVE SO WE HAVE
A NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT ARE
LEAVING THE FIELD SO PART OF IT
IS JUST THE DEMOGRAPHICS ARE
PART OF THE PROBLEM AND YOU KNOW
YOU MIGHT LOOK AT THE STUDIES ON
SPECIALLY LONG HAUL DRIVERS.
IT'S NOT A GREAT JOB AND PEOPLE
THAT PEOPLE ARE TURNING OVER BUT
OF COURSE THAT DRIVES THE NEED
FOR NEW DRIVERS SHOULD BE PUT
INTO THE FIELD SO IT'S A IT'S A
VERY COMPLEX ISSUE AND WE'RE
TRYING TO DO OUR END OF-
TRANSPORT OUR END OF THE
SOLUTION TO MAKE SURE THAT
DRIVERS WHO WANT TO BE
COMMERCIAL DRIVERS. CAN GET SORT
OF. YEAH I AND I AM. THAT I'M DO
- I'M JUST. ASKING WHAT. AND HOW
DID WE REACH THE CA. THAT PASSED
WHERE THE- IS. BECAUSE THIS IS
QUITE A HUGE. INVESTMENT AND IF
HE SAID. OKAY BASED ON THIS
SYSTEM THAT. THIS IS THE
CONCLUSION THAT OUR PEACE. IS
ESSENTIAL TO GETTING MORE TRUCK
DRIVERS I JUST. I HAVEN'T HEARD
WHY AND WHO CAME UP WITH THIS AS
WAS THE RATIONALE FOR IT OTHER
THAN WE SEE A LOT ON ON YOU KNOW
TV WE SEE A LOT ON THE NEWS THAT
THERE'S A SUPPLY CHAIN OF
PROBLEM BUT- I HAVEN'T SEEN
SPECIFICALLY THAT HAS ANYTHING
TO DO WITH NOT BEING ABLE TO GET
A- DRIVER'S LICENSE. I JUST
THINK IT CLARIFIED YEAH YEAH I
TEND TO AGREE WITH YOU THAT WE
ARE IT'S A COMPLEX PROBLEM AND
WE HAVE A STRATEGIC ROLE IN IN
RESOLVING OUR PORTION WEEKEND WE
HAVE THESE DRIVERS ARE EXTREME
SCHOOLS SAY. THEY'VE BEEN PAYING
A LOT OF THE SCHOOLS THEY HAVE
THAT THEY'RE EXPECTING TO BE
ABLE TO YOU KNOW GET YOU ON THE
ROAD AND PLAY- YOU KNOW.
PARTICIPATE IN SOCIETY MORE
FULLY SO I THINK WE HAVE AN
OBLIGATION TO THEM TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY CAN YOU KNOW TAKE
THEIR EXAMS AS AS THE- THESE
KIND OF GENERALLY TAKE EXAM
SOMEWHERE CLOSE TO THEIR
RESIDENTS AND BRING OUT OF LOS
ANGELES- IT WAS OVER. 20% OF OUR
EXAMS ARE IN THAT GREATER AREA
AND IF YOU GO TO THE FURTHER
EAST YOU KNOW WE'VE GOT ANOTHER
YOU KNOW 1520% AND DIDN'T KNOW
WHERE THAT PROPOSALS ARE TO BE
NORTHERN L. A. AND ALSO IN THE
BAY AREA. IT'S ANOTHER 10% IN
THE BAY AREA THAT ARE
CONCENTRATED THERE SO WE HAVE A
FAIR AMOUNT OF THE BAND AND SO I
CAN'T TELL YOU IS THAT DEMAND.
YOU KNOW I CAN'T TELL YOU WHAT'S
GENERATED OTHER WANT TO SHARE
WITH YOU THE DEMOGRAPHICS B. THE
QUALITY OF LIFE ESPECIALLY LONG
HAUL DRIVERS BECAUSE YOU TURN
OVER. WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE SURE
WE DO OUR PART I THINK DOING
NOTHING AND I MEAN PRETTY MUCH
FROZEN DO NOTHING HERE BUT I
THINK. YOU KNOW NOT NOT
COMPLETING THIS TASK FOR THE
STATE AND INCOMPLETE IT
CURRENTLY IN PROCESS I THINK
ALSO REPRESENTING YOU PROBABLY
HAVE ALL THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
TRAINED LOOKING FOR JOBS I CAN'T
GET CERTIFIED IN THE STATE AND
WORK. TO HELP CLEAR THE PORTS
AND OTHER THINGS SO. IT'S
COMPLEX AND IT'S NOT QUITE CLEAR
WHAT EXACTLY THE PROBLEM IS WE
ARE TRYING TO MAKE SURE WE CAN
KEEP THE EXISTING. PROCESS
WORKING AS EFFICIENTLY AS WE
CAN. M. I'M SURE I BEEN CUT. OF
THAT TO THAT YOUR CURRENT DO
HAVE A HOUSE OF. TWENTY THREE
TO. SITES IN THE CASE- IT ONLY
FOR. REALLY TO KIND OF HANG.
WHAT THE TEST WOULD. KIND OF
ANCHOR. BOB WHITTEN BETWEEN THE
BIG. BACK THE BASICS. IN THE ROW
TEST. THAT'S A LOT OUR KIND OF
IT THE FEEL OFFICE IS WELL AND
SO WE HAVE. A LOT OF. SPACE TO
FISHING- THE KIND OF. ON TOP
STREETS IN COLD SAC- THEY WERE
BE. SUB FIELD OFFICES WERE OF AB
. AS AN EXAMPLE. IN ON OUR LOCAL
AREA. I'M REAL. ST AS- WHERE THE
POP. IS PROBABLY WHAT IS. TWENTY
THIRTY YEARS. BUT I'LL POPULAR.
ARE IN. THE MORE OF AN ISSUE
SAFETY. WEBER CONDUCTING THIS.
SO WE JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT
ALL ARE COMPOUND. IS GOING TO BE
A BILL. IN THE EVENT THAT MORE
TRUCK DRIVER ARE DIDN'T FOR THE
PORT TO ME. THAT WHEN WE'RE
CONDUCTING A TEST OF THEIR DONE
A- IF. AND- IN THE SAME
ENVIRONMENT. SURNAME IS. YOU
SHOULD NOT SURE JUST JUST I'VE
GOT A- A FRAMEWORK FOR ABOUT THE
IF THE CURRENT WAY TIME- BUT
MISTER GORDON THIRTY SIX AND IT
WAS TO TWO DAY COUPLE YEARS AGO
WHAT BUT IMPROVE THAT WE CAN
EXPECT FROM THE INFO AND BY. SO
IT ACTUALLY SEEN AN IMPROVEMENT
SENATOR FROM DAYS ABOUT A AGO.
T. AROUND THIRTY DAYS NOW ON IT
IN VERY IN A COUPLE CENTERS
FONTANA GARDENIA ARE THE- MORE
POPULATED AREAS THERE ARE A MORE
IN- THAT'S- DRIVERS HAVE COME TO
THE AREAS YOU THERE ARE TWO
CHASEN'S. AROUND THERE SOMEWHERE
SEEMS. IMPROVEMENTS MADE. MANY
STEPS. NOW THIS IS A OF THE
STATE JUST WEEK FRESNO PARTY.
AND FONTANA VISITED THE- SO WE
OPEN AT SOME O'CLOCK THE MORNING
WE WERE SIXTY A WEEK WE HAVE
STAFF THAT ARE ROAD. FROM AREAS
WE IS HOW WE WAIT TIMES DOWN
FROM A YEAR AGO JANUARY WAS
SIXTY DAYS NOW TO ON AVERAGE
AROUND DAYS- YOUR GOAL WOULD BE
TO GET IT UNDER. MAYBE JUST TO
TWO WEEKS LIKE A REASONABLE TIME
. SO MAY HAVE SIX PROGRESS FOR
YOU DATA OR UNDER OR BECAUSE ARE
TO MAKE SURE WE INTO THE RIGHT
AREA WHERE. THE WAY WE WILL BE
TESTING SUCH AS A- THAT ACTIVITY
THAT ARE UNDER WAY THAT I'VE
BEEN TO SEE. I THINK IN IN THE-
OF ARKHAM TESTING BUT WE STILL
HAVE ROOM TO GROW AND WE NEED TO
AS MISTER SCOTT SUGGESTED. YOU
KNOW BE ABLE TO TAKE THESE OUT
OF UNITS LOCAL OPS TAKE VEHICLES
OFF PUBLIC STREET TEN AM TEN.
AND INSPECTED AND SO ON ON A
LARGE PAD SO THEY ARE SAFE AND
WE CAN DO MANY OF THEM
SIMULTANEOUSLY. AS WE'RE DOING
THIS ON OUR LARGER SITES. ADD ON
TO THAT TO. DIRECTOR AT ALL OF
OUR SITE ARE DOING THE TEST
BARLOW OF TEMPER. SITES SUCH
REALLY CUT OFF ALL. TO CONTINUE
TO. WITH THE- TO. THEM THEY NEED
TAKE THEIR TIME THAT SOME KIND
OF A- ON HOUSING- YEAH IF YOU
WERE TO. IT SOME BIG LIKE
DOCTORS. GOING WOULD BE ABLE TO
IT UNTIL. BASEBALL'S BY IN TOWN
OR MAYBE A LARGE CAP. WHERE THEY
HOLD A FAIR AND THE FAIR. AS OF
THOSE PARTIES BECAUSE FIRST OVER
A- WE'RE LOOKING FOR. DATA AREA
THAT'S GOING TO BE BOTH THE
NORTH AUSTIN. CLOSED THE PORT-
PUTS THE PARTS AS WELL AS- AND A
BIGGER. TO MAKE SURE WE'RE NOT.
AND ALL OF CAL. RICHARD THAT TO
SHOW. WE WERE TO REDUCE. THE
TIME TO TEST TO. YOU KNOW TO. OF
THE COSTA. FIFTY TO. HOW LONG.
DOES IT TAKE FROM THEIR- A-
DRIVE. TO RECEIVE. HIS HIS OR
HER. CITY L. AND- IS. OF THIS.
DUG YOUR TOWARDS STREAM. THAT
PHASE THE WORK FLOW. SO SENATE
WERE WISHING EVERY PHASE OF THE
WAR FLOW AND INCLUDING HELPING
TO SCHEDULE- WHERE PEOPLE WORK
CAN OUT OF EXAM TO SURE THAT WE
CAN SORT OF I CAN HEAR WHERE YOU
MANAGE WE KNOW. WHAT PERCENTAGE
OF PEOPLE FAILED STRIPES PEOPLE
TELL MORE OFTEN- AND SO WERE
TRYING SCHEDULE A FREE SO WE
MAKE SURE THAT OUR OUR-
CONSTRAINED THEY ARE OUR WORK AT
PEAK EFFICIENCY. SO I THINK
WE'RE WE'RE DOING JUST ABOUT
EVERYTHING WE CAN OF NO
CERTAINLY WELL. FEEDBACK ALSO AS
WE IT THE CENTER ARE FORTY
PEOPLE TO TRY ACROSS THE LOS
ANGELES CA THE BASIN. TO THE
EAST OF ON TO THIS REGARD. AND
BUT WE DON'T HAVE A AYE NOR WELL
LOS LOCATION WE DON'T HAVE A BAY
AREA THE- THAT IS THAT IT- I TO
DEDICATED PATH OR THE CAN'T LINE
UP THE DRY SCHOOL COME TO THE
SAME VEHICLE. FIVE I'LL YOU TEST
IN TODAY. AND IT'S YOU KNOW IT'S
THE NOT SAFE AND WAYS BE IN SOME
OF RESIDENTS NEIGHBORHOODS WE DO
OUR OFF SO I THINK A COMMON OF
ALL THOSE AND IT. THAT ARE MEAN
YOU SEE THE IN THE BASIC PACKAGE
AND TALK A NUMBER OF THINGS WE
WERE. DOING THAT EVERY THE
WEIGHT. AND WE THINK GONNA GET
TO A PET TOWARDS AT CENTER JUST
KEEP OUR EYE ON FOCUS OFFICIALLY
. OUR OP OF THE OPERATIONAL
ABILITY AND WE'RE WITH SCHOOL
THAT HAVE. YOU KNOW UNDER
DRIVERS WE CAN GET DOWN YOU
SEPARATED THE PEOPLE THAT ARE TO
GET THEM OUT OF THE WAY SOME CAN
MAKE SURE THAT. PROPER DRIVERS
YOU'RE MAKING OUT ON THE ROAD
AND PEOPLE THAT ARE NOT READY
ARE ARE WILL CONTINUE TO
CONTINUE TRAINING UNTIL THEY ARE
READY WILL PROVE EVERYONE'S
EFFICIENCY AND ROAD SAFETY. YEAH
I DID ADD UP TO THAT TICKET WITH
THE VEHICLE INSPECTION BASIC
SKILL AND WROTE THOSE ARE THE
THREE AREAS OF WHERE- AN
APPLICANT BUT THAT WOULD TAKE
THE TEST WE'RE MAKING SURE TO BE
CLEAR THAT IN THE EVENT THAT
THEY FAIL A PORTION OF IT THAT
THEY CAN GET THROUGH BUT THAT
PIPELINE. THANK YOU FOR LOOKING
SYSTEM TO GET THEM BACK AND
TESTED HIM AND HOPEFULLY
APPROVED AS FAST AS POSSIBLE
JUST MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE
STAYING EFFICIENT AND- SHOWING
THAT WERE- BOAT BUT APPLICANT
LOTS. TO GET ACROSS AND GET
SUCCESS FOR. THAT WERE DIRECTOR
IN THE RIGHT WAY. THANK YOU AND
THANK YOU MANAGER. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT THE SEE NUMBER QUITE OF
WHERE THE END OF THANK YOU FOR
MUCH OF A MRS MISS GORDON. YOUR
TO TODAY OF WHERE THE AND THE
OUR ISSUES DISCUSS WE'RE NOT
GOING TO MVED PUBLIC COMMENT ON
IS EIGHT THREE TWO TWO. OF
ANYONE WILL TO PER PUBLIC WE
THESE ITEMS- TODAY'S
PARTICIPANTS NUMBER IS
844-291-6364 AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS. THREE FIVE THREE ONE TWO
EIGHT THREE. OF DUE TO THE
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE LENGTH
OF THE HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING UP
PROTOCOLS. WE ARE WILL I WILL.
INSTITUTE A TIME LIMIT ON
TODAY'S TESTIMONY WHEN ASKED
THAT EACH MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
PROVIDING COMMENT KEEP YOUR
REMARKS WITH LESS THAN ONE
MINUTE- BOB MODERATOR WE CAN
BEGIN. UP COULD YOU LET US KNOW
HOW MANY ARE IN THE QUEUE. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND AT THIS TIME
WE DO HAVE ONE PARTY IN THE
COMING Q. GO AHEAD. ONE NINE
FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. M. AND SHARON
MEMBERS THIS IS ROSS BARKLEY ON
BAPTIST NECKWEAR BY TRANSLATION
FORTY I GOT CLUB EARLIER BUT
JUST WANT TO SPEAK TO ISSUE BY
REAL QUICK. WE CAN ALSO BIG
DEMONSTRATION FOR THE TRANSITION
PACKAGE INCLUDING THE JERRY
BUDGET PROPOSAL WE LINE OUR
COMMENT FOR CENTER CORTESE AND
WE JOIN OUR CARE AGENCIES AROUND
THE STATE CONCRETE SEEK THEM
OUT. OF GENERAL FUND SURPLUS
REVENUES TICKET FOR
TRANSPORTATION PRIORITIES IF
ONLY WE ARE SIGNIFICANT INCREASE
IN THE FUNDING FOR TRANSIT
INVESTMENTS BUT T. R. C. P.
HELLO PRODUCTS REQUIRED STATE
FUNDING YOUR OR MY TO PART BUT-
MCCALL ONE IT JUST THAT TRC P.
PROGRAM STRUCTURE. COOPER STOP
WHILE WARD TO CRUNCH. BURKE
FRAZIER THE PRODUCT FOR JUST BE
. ARE LOOKING. EIGHTH TWO
EXTENSION PROJECT AND CALTRANS
ELECTRIC ACROSS. COMPLETE THEIR
FUNDING PLAN AND- PAINT CREEK
INCIDENT. SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. BYE I'M I
HAD DIDN'T CALL ON THE ROOM HE-
THE- A COMMENT NO ONE HE-
OFFERING COMMENT- THEY YOU
MODERATOR- IF WE HAVE NO MORE
INDIVIDUALS. TO WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS IN THE QUEUE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- HAVE
INFERRED FROM ALL OF THE-
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. ON OUR
SENATORS TO HAVE AN ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ON THESE
ISSUES OKAY. NOW WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO THE VOTE ONLY CALENDAR-
AND THOSE ARE ITEMS. ONE THROUGH
FOUR BUT WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ITEM ONE TO THE NEXT HEARING
PROBABLY MR HARKER OKAY ALL
RIGHT SO WE ARE VOTING TODAY ON
ITEMS TWO THREE AND FOUR AND
THAT IS VOTE ONLY DO WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THE VOTE ONLY CALENDAR
. OKAY HAVE A SECOND. THE NEEDED
WE NEED IT NOW OKAY ALL RIGHT
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR I- DO WE
SORRY MR HACKER GO HEAD. RED
LOBSTER ROUSER. I IS A HIGH
GROWTH NEWMAN ALL RIGHT OKAY
THANK YOU THAT'S- IT- THIS ITEM
IS OUT. OF. I JUST I THINK WHERE
THE END NO MORE ISSUES OKAY
THANK YOU TO EVERYONE WHO
PARTICIPATED TODAY IN THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY AS WELL AS OUR
DEPARTMENTS THAT MADE
PRESENTATIONS IF YOU WERE NOT
ABLE TO TESTIFY PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE BUDGET FISCAL
REVIEW COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS HAVE BEEN VERY VERY
IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WILL WANT
TO INCLUDE ANY FURTHER TESTIMONY
YOU HAVE IN THE VISUAL HEARING
RECORDS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MR HACKER THANK YOU TO
EVERYONE HERE WHO MADE THIS
POSSIBLE APPRECIATE ALL OF YOUR
WORK. ASK THE LOCAL.